WELCOME TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT HEARING-
DUE TO THE CONTINUED STAY AT
HOME ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN HERE I
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE ARE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASKS BE WORN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCE BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM ORDER VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A
MASK. WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR
YOU- WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR THE PUBLIC TODAY.
WHEN WE REACH THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF THE AGENDA I
WOULD ASK THAT ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM
PLEASE APPROACH THE MIKE ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. AND PLEASE
MAINTAIN SOCIAL DISTANCING AS
YOU MOVE AROUND THE ROOM. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE PROVIDING YOUR
COMMENTS. OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE. TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AND ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE
QUEUE TO PROVIDE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVE STREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. WE MAY NEED
TO LIMIT HOW LONG EACH PERSON
HAS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT.
AS WE MAY NEED TO EXIT THIS
HEARING ROOM FOR CLEANING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY FOR THE
HEARING BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AT J. T.
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT DOT
LEGISLATURE DOT CA DOT GOV
PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED PUBLIC
COMMENT AND MAY BE READ INTO
THE RECORD OR REPRINTED. I
WOULD LIKE TO START OFF TODAY
BY THANKING THE SPEAKER AND PRO
TEM AND OUR AMAZING STAFF FOR
MAKING THIS HEARING HAPPENED
TODAY. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK OUR PANELISTS AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THE
TIME OUT OF THEIR BUSY
SCHEDULES TO PARTICIPATE TODAY.
UP THE PAST FOUR YEARS HAVE
SEEN CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
FLOODS. AND DEBRIS SLIDES THAT
HAVE COST CALIFORNIANS THEIR
LIVES AND DESTROYED TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN PROPERTY
LOSSES. THIS YEAR SAW OVER FOUR
MILLION ACRES BURNED AND THE
YEAR IS NOT EVEN OVER YET. MANY
OF THESE DEATHS AND INJURIES
COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED HAD OUR
EMERGENCY ALERT AND
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM. SYSTEMS
BEEN EFFECTIVE AND FUNCTION
FUNCTIONING PROPERLY. THERE
WERE PROBLEMS WITH MESSAGING
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NOT
PREPARED TO SEND ALERTS A
FAILURE OF OUR NOTIFICATION
SYSTEMS TO BE ABLE TO REACH
EVERYONE. THE INHERENT
VULNERABILITY AND LIMITATIONS
IN OUR SYSTEMS AND FINALLY TO
INDIVIDUALS NOT OPTING INTO
ALERTS ARE TAKING APPROPRIATE
ACTION ONCE THEY RECEIVE THEM.
WHILE OUR OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE TO BE COMMENDED FOR MAKING
GREAT IMPROVEMENTS IN THE PAST
FEW YEARS WE ARE STILL NOT
WHERE WE SHOULD BE. WE'RE STILL
EXPERIENCING PROBLEMS TODAY'S
HEARING ON EMERGENCY ALERTS AND
EVACUATION WILL FOCUS ON
SPECIFIC ISSUES RELATED TO
EMERGENCY ALERTS AND EVACUATION.
FOR ALERTS HOW DO WE IMPROVE
OUR SYSTEMS HOW DO WE
ACCOMPLISH RESILIENCE AND
REDUNDANCY. HOW DO WE GET
ACCURATE AND TIMELY INFORMATION
ALERTS OUT TO CALIFORNIANS
BEFORE AND DURING MANDATORY
EVACUATIONS. CALIFORNIA ALWAYS
RESPONDS TO DISASTERS AND
ADJUST TO THE NEW TWIST AND
TURNS THAT ARE THROWN AT US I'M
CONCERNED THAT OUR EMERGENCY
ALERTS AND EVACUATIONS THAT WE
ARE PREPARED FOR OUR FUTURE.
AND THAT WE ARE PREPARED FOR A
FUTURE WORST CASE SCENARIOS.
BEFORE WE START THE HEARING. OF
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A QUICK
QUICK MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN A PILLAR
OF THIS INSTITUTION FOR MANY
YEARS. BY ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
TODAY IS SENATOR HANNAH BETH
JACKSON'S FINAL DAY IN THE
LEGISLATURE. SHE HAS BEEN CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND HAS
CONTRIBUTED A LOT. NOT ONLY TO
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT BUT TOO
MANY ISSUES THAT AFFECT
CALIFORNIANS IN AS HER AS-
DURING HER TIME IN IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ITS RESIDENTS
HAVE BENEFITTED GREATLY BECAUSE
OF YOUR EXEMPLARY EXEMPLARY
POLICY WORK OVER THE YEARS.
THANK YOU HAVE A BATH FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO THE STATE AND WE
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST IN YOUR
NEXT ADVENTURES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
WISH YOU THE BEST A LOT GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
HANNAH BETH. UP FINALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR MCGUIRE
FOR MAKING THE TRIP FOR THIS
HEARING TODAY. AS A MEMBER WHO
REPRESENTS A DISTRICT THAT
SPANS FROM THE GOLDEN GATE. TO
THE OREGON BORDER SENATOR
MCGUIRE'S DISTRICT HAS BEEN
SUBJECTED TO SOME OF THE WORST
FIRES IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
SENATOR REQUIRED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND AS THE VICE
CHAIR- WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIRWOMAN FOR HER
DEDICATED WORK ON THESE
CRITICAL ISSUES. VERY VERY
GRATEFUL MADAM CHAIR AND
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER
WITH YOU HERE THIS MORNING AND
GOOD MORNING TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU. MADAM CHAIR
LOOK I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THE SIZE AND SCOPE OF WILDLAND
FIRE VINCE IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE GETTING WORSE THESE
PAST FIVE YEARS ARE LIKE
NOTHING THAT WE HAVE EVER SEEN
BEFORE. WHETHER YOU'RE ONE OF
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS WHO
WERE EVACUATED OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS. WHO LOST THEIR HOME
OR THE DOZENS WHO LOST A LOVED
ONE THESE MEGA WHILE AND FIRES
HAVE CHANGED THE WAY WE LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE SEVERAL
LESSONS THAT WE HAVE LEARNED
FROM THIS ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATING HALF DECADE IN ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT IS THE
DESPERATE NEED FOR
COMPREHENSIVE AND EFFECTIVE
EMERGENCY ALERTS. LIVES TRULY
DEPEND ON IT IT'S CLEAR THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
SHORTCOMINGS IN OUR EMERGENCY
ALERT SYSTEM AND RESIDENTS
DESERVE RESIDENTS DESERVE
TIMELY NOTIFICATIONS AND UP TO
DATE INFORMATION. SERVER YOUR
YEARS AGO EACH OF THE GOLDEN
THE STATE'S COUNTIES WERE
DEPLOYING ALERTS DFFERENTLY IN
SOME CANDIDLY NOT DEPLOYING ANY
AT ALL. THIS LEFT TENS OF
MILLIONS OF LIES VULNERABLE TO
AN IMPENDING DISASTER. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB THREE
THREE WHICH CREATED STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY EVACUATION ALERT
GUIDELINES THIS LEGISLATION
ALSO DEVELOPED MANDATED
TRAININGS FOR LOCAL EMERGENCY
MANAGERS ON HOW TO EMPLOYEE.
DEPLOY ALERTS AND WARNINGS THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO PASSED
CRITICAL LEGISLATION IN YEARS
PAST FOR TELECOMMUNICATION
OUTAGE REPORTING. AND IT'S NOW
LA THE LAND IF THERE'S A
TELECOMMUNICATION ADAGE
WIRELESS OR WIRELINE.
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES ARE
NOW MANDATED REPORT THESE
OUTAGES TO LOCAL EMERGENCY
MANAGERS IN THE STATE OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES IN NO LESS
THAN SIXTY MINUTES. PRIOR TO
THIS TELECOMMUNICATION OUTAGES
WOULD TAKE PLACE ALERTS WOULD
BE SENT OUT AND NO ONE WAS
AWARE THAT THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
IN DANGER WEREN'T RECEIVING
THESE ALERTS SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE. NOW THERE ARE
STILL SHORTCOMINGS THAT WE MUST
ADDRESS AND I AM GRATEFUL TO
THE CHAIRMAN FOR CONVENING AS
TODAY WHICH IS SO CRITICAL.
THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE THE.
SEVEN TWO HOUR BACKUP POWER
RULES FOR CELL PHONE TOWER
STICKS THAT RECENTLY PASSED BY
THE PUBLIC. COMMISSION AND WE
NEED TO ADVANCE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS FOR WIRE LINES AND
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE ALSO NEED
TO EXAMINE HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
EVACUATIONS WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT HOW AN IF WE BUILD IN HE
MOST. SEVERE HIGH FIRED
SEVERITY ZONES. FOR THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE WE
NEED STATEWIDE POLICY AND
MANDATED FIRE BREAKS AROUND
DEVELOPMENTS MANDATED PRIMARY
AND SECONDARY ROADS FOR NEW
DEVELOPMENTS. NO MORE ONE WAY
AND ONE WAY OUT FOR ROADS IN
THE WILL WE- ALL THE ALERTING
CAPABILITY IN THE WORLD DOESN'T
MAKE UP FOR TRYING TO EVACUATE
ENTIRE AREAS ON A SINGLE SMALL
ROAD. IN AGAIN WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE THAT CHAIRWOMAN
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS AND FOR
BRINGING LIGHT TO THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. FINALLY MADAM CHAIR AND
LIKE TO BE ADDED KNOWLEDGE
SENATOR JACKSON IS YOU
ELOQUENTLY JUST DID AS WELL. AT
THIS IS GOING TO BE HER FINAL
JOINT COMMITTEE. MEETING AND I
JUST WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THAT CENTER JACKSON HAS BEEN A
TIRELESS CHAMPION. SHE'S BEEN A
TIRELESS CHAMPION FOR FIRE
SURVIVORS. CENTER JACKSON'S
DISTRICT HAS BEEN FROM HELL AND
BACK HOW DO TO THESE MEGA WHILE
THEN FIRES AND MUD SLIDES. SHE
HAS BEEN A CHAMPION TO BE ABLE
TO UPDATE ANTIQUATED EMERGENCY
ALERT STANDARD LAWS ADVANCE NEW
BUILDING STANDARDS THAT WILL
HELP KEEP CALIFORNIANS SAFE AND
A MEGA FIRE. FIGHTING FOR
RESOURCES FOR CALIFORNIA LOCAL
FIREFIGHTING AGENCIES WHEN I
SAY THAT SHE IS GOING TO BE
DEARLY MISSED THAT IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT. AND SENATE
JACKSON WE ARE GRATEFUL
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR LIFETIME.
SERVICE TO ONE OF QUALITY. TO
FIGHTING FOR THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE IN THREE STANDING
STRONG FOR FIRE SURVIVORS.
AGAIN MANAGER LOOK FORWARD TO
THE DISCUSSION APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS
HEARING TODAY. VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
CONTINUED FOCUS ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF RIVER ALERTS
AND EVACUATIONS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME. TO MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE. WHO ALSO READY TO THE
HEARING WE HAVE THREE PANELS
TODAY- THE FIRST WILL BE OF ON
THE STATE PERSPECTIVE. FOLLOWED
BY FIRE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND ENDING WITH A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- PERSPECTIVE AFTER
EACH PANEL- WE WILL OPEN IT UP
TO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. FOR THE PANELISTS.
AND THEN AT THE VERY END OF THE
PANELS WE WILL. OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- SO FIRST WE'D
LIKE TO HEAR FROM. TINA CURRY
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. GOOD MORNING
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY
GOOD MORNING YES WE CAN.
EXCELLENT JERRY VESTS RIGHT
CARE MCGUIRE CENTER JACKSON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ALONGSIDE OR CALIFORNIA
OR PUBLIC SAFETY AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COLLEAGUES ON THE
ROLE OF HELLO YES IN THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF EMERGENCY
ALERTS WARNINGS AND EVACUATION.
AGAIN MY NAME IS TINA CURRY AND
I AM THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
HERE AT HELLO YES. SO JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW HOW WE'RE
ORGANIZED ON JUST ABOUT ALL
DISASTERS EMERGED AND AT
PRESENT THEMSELVES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND SO YOU KNOW LONG
WITHOUT LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAVE
SYSTEMS AND PROCESSES TO SEND
EMERGENCY ALERTS AND WARNINGS
TO THEIR COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
HELLO YES ALSO HAS A ROLE IN A
LEARNING MORNING WE HAVE A-
CALIFORNIA STATE WARNING CENTER
THAT IS STAFFED TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN AND IS IN CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION WITH WHAT WE CALL
FORTY POINTS AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL LEVEL ALL THE
TIME THEY'RE RELAYING THINGS.
LIKE WEATHER WARNINGS AND OTHER
TYPES OF. CRITICAL INFORMATION
WHICH THEN IT EXTENDED TO THE
PUBLIC. AND ALSO CONSISTENT
WITH CALLAS IS ROLE TO SUPPORT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN ALL FACETS
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER THE STATE ALSO
PROVIDES A ROLE IN THE A
LEARNING LEARNING SPACE-
TRAINING. GUIDANCE AND
PROVIDING A PLATFORM CONSERVE
OUR CONSISTENCY ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS AND TO ACCESS
TOOLS SUCH AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S INTEGRATED PUBLIC
ALERT AND WARNING SYSTEM OR
IPODS IN ORDER FOR TO THAT TO
THAT ACKERMAN OPPORTUNITY
TIMES. THE ISSUE OF ALERTS OR
WARNINGS AND EVACUATIONS AS
ADULT THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
LEADER TO OBVIOUSLY TOOK CENTER
STAGE AFTER SERIOUS SERIES OF
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS TRAGICALLY
CLAIMING LIVES DURING THE TO
SET THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRES AND OTHER SIGNIFICANT
EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA. WE KNEW
MORE NEEDED TO BE DONE. THE
STATE LEVERAGED ITS
STANDARDIZED EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE AS A
PROGRAM. I FOUNDATION FOR
EMERGENCY MAN AND CAL. FOR DECK.
AND WE FORM TO THE- COLOR AND
WARN WHAT WE CAN SPECIAL
COMMITTEE. BACKED COMMITTEE AS
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL ALL
CORNERS OF CALIFORNIA ALL THE
REGIONS OF THE STATE STATE
GOVERNMENT- AND IT'S SAD REALLY
CALIBRATED TO WORK TOGETHER
WORK THROUGH ISSUES
IMPROVEMENTS AND EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. THAT'S THE BODY
ULTIMATELY DEVELOP TO THE ALERT
AND WARNING GUIDELINES AS
REQUIRED BY YOUR BILL CENTER
REQUIRE EIGHT THIRTY THREE. AND
THESE ARE PUBLISHED BACK IN
MARCH OF TWENTY NINETEEN. THERE
IS NOTHING- SOLUTION THAT WILL
WORK THE SAME WAY AND EVERY
INCIDENT WE KNOW THIS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES SOMEONE OF IMPORT MOST
IMPORTANT COMPONENTS OF THE
GUIDANCE. IS EMPHASIS ON THE
USE OF MULTIPLE SYSTEM SO THAT
WE ARE COMPREHENSIVE AND
REDUNDANT AND THEN WITH THIS
VERY CRITICAL STATUS OF
ALERTING AND WARNING. ALONG
THOSE LINES ONE OF OUR GOALS
WAS TO ENHANCE THE USE OF
WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERTS ARE
WE OUT WE HAS ONE OF THE-
FACETS OF THE IPOD SYSTEM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SYSTEM THAT
I MENTIONED EARLIER. SINCE
PUBLISHING THE GUIDELINES IN
TWENTY NINETEEN HELLO YES AS
APPROVED. A HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE WHAT WE CALL ALERTING
AUTHORITIES STATEWIDE. IN ALL
OF OUR HAVE ACCOUNT. AND THIS
IS UP FROM ABOUT A YEAR AGO WE
HAD WE PRESENTED ON THIS TOPIC
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND WE WERE
ABOUT IT ABOUT EIGHTY EIGHT
ALERTING AUTHORITIES- DURING
THE REASON THESE RECENT FIRES
AS ALERTING AUTHORITIES
DISSEMINATED OVER THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY PLUS ALERTS AND
WARNINGS TO THE PUBLIC. WHAT IS
AN ALERTING AUTHORITY THIS IS A
FEMALE TERM SO ESSENTIALLY THE
JURISDICTION THAT HAS SIGNED ON
AND DEMONSTRATED THEIR ABILITY
TO UTILIZE THE IPOD SYSTEM. AND
HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO SEND
ALERTS OR WARNINGS TO THE
PUBLIC SO BIG PART OF OUR WORK
IS TO. HELP COMMUNITIES- HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT SYSTEM RIGHT NOW
ACCORDING TO FEMA. THERE ARE
MORE THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED
MATCHING NOT ACROSS THE NATION
FEDERAL STATE LOCAL TRIBAL AND
TERRITORIAL OR ALERTING
AUTHORITIES ARE USING THE- IPOD
SYSTEM. MESSAGE THAT BY
LEARNING AUTHORITIES RANGE FROM
WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERTS- OVER
THE EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM R.
EA ASKED THAT MANY ARE FAMILIAR
WITH. FOR THINGS LIKE
EVACUATIONS OR OTHER EMERGENCY
ACTIONS THAT PEOPLE NEED TO
TAKE. THESE SYSTEMS ARE ALSO
USED FOR THINGS LIKE TSUNAMI
AND WEATHER WARNINGS AND TO
RELATE THOSE TO THE PUBLIC AND
ABOUT A YEAR AGO CALIFORNIA
BEGAN USING WE ASK WIRELESS
EMERGENCY ALERTS AS ONE OF THE
SEVERAL DELIVERY SYSTEMS FOR.
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING WHICH
IS A NEW TECHNOLOGY AND
CALIFORNIA. WE HVE COVERAGE OF
BANDAGES AS WE KNOW AS THE
TECHNOLOGY IS EMBEDDED IN ALL
CELLPHONES REQUIRES AN OPT OUT
IN ORDER TO NOT RECEIVE THEM SO
THE MESSAGE GO AUTOMATICALLY
UNLESS THE- US CELL PHONE
SUBSCRIBER YOU OPT OUT. BUT WE
HAS ALSO HAVE LIMITATIONS.
THERE CAN BE BELIEVE OVER
HOUSING PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF THE
INTENDED AREA TO RECEIVE ALERTS
AND BECAUSE ANDY PADDOCK. SAID
THE FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION- TOOK ISSUE WITH
THIS IN NOVEMBER THIRTIETH IS
ARE DEADLINE. OR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO REFINE WE ACCURACY
SO AS OF NOVEMBER THIRTIETH
I'VE AND NUMBER THIRTY YET- WE
HAVE NEED TO BE ACCURATE WITHIN
ONE TENTH OF A MILE FOR THE
INTENDED NOTIFICATION AREA SO
WERE WERE LITERALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT. SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT. AT UCLA YES AND WE
ARE IN THE SYSTEMS THEY DEPEND
ON. ARE ALSO SUBJECT TO
DESTRUCTION BUT STATUS POWER
SUPPLY WILDFIRES THE SYSTEM
RESILIENCY REDUNDANCY ARE
INSTRUMENTAL TO THIS CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT AND CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AS YOU ALREADY
ALLUDED TO- CPUC HAS ISSUED.
NEW RULES REGARDING POWER
REDUNDANCY. FOR COMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS. WE OFTEN HEAR ABOUT
TECH CHEN THE IPOD IT'S SOME IS
MANY DOES OUT AS WE IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S USED ALL THE
TIME. AND THAT'S BEEN A
BARRIER- FOR ACCESS TO DO WE
ARE THAT'S SOMETHING WE LEARNED
IN WORKING WITH OUR COMMUNITY
SAID TO HELP WITH THIS WE HAVE
MULTIPLE FRIENDS AT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TRAINING AND
GUIDANCE WITH COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE WORKING THROUGH EACH AND
EVERY DAY. AND THE FACT THIS
WEEK OR LAUNCHING A SERIES OF
WEBINARS FOR ALERTING
AUTHORITIES AND HAVE ABOUT
TWENTY FOUR COUNTIES AND ROLLED
SO FAR BUT WE WANT TO CONTINUE
WITH THESE. DURING THESE WET
WEBINARS THE THAT THE- ALERTING
AUTHORITIES WILL PARTICIPATE
AND ACTUALLY WALK THROUGH THE
TECHNICAL COMPONENTS OF IPODS
AND WE HAVE BUT ALSO COME OUT
OF IT. WITH A COMPLETED OR
AUGMENTED- ALERTED WARNING
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS SO THAT WE
CAN AGAIN APPROACH AND-STANDARDIZATION. AND ENSURE
THAT THAT THAT. THAT THE ROBUST
AT PLANS THAT ARE NEEDED AREN'T
THE PLACE FOR THIS IMPORTANT
CAPABILITY. AND THEN AFTER THIS
TRAINING WE'RE GONNA BE FORM
YOU KNOW IT'S GOING TO HELP US
FORMA COLBERT ALERTING
AUTHORITIES THAT ARE CONSTANTLY
CAN WORK TOGETHER IN THE FUTURE
AND SHARE BEST PRACTICES.
THEY'RE ALSO TOOLS FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND INDIVIDUALS
THAT NEED TO BE TO BE AWARE OF
AND TAKE PART IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES ALERT MORNING
SYSTEM FIRST AS ALREADY
MENTIONED. THAT INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD SIGN UP FOR THEIR LOCAL
ALERTING PROGRAM THEY CAN DO SO
BY. GOING TO THEIR COUNTY
WEBSITE OR OR THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHERE THEY LIVE.
THEY CAN ALSO VISIT CALARTS DOT
ORG THAT'S A SITE AT THE STATE
START UP THAT HAS ALL KINDS OF
INFORMATION ALERT MORNING
GUIDELINES THE THINGS THAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT TODAY BUT ALSO
LEADS TO ALL THE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AND THEIR- OTHER
PROGRAMS. IN INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES CAN ALSO TAKE BASIC
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS STEPS TO
TALK ABOUT THIS ALL THE TIME.
HAVE A PLAN BUT ALSO HAVE.
SOMETHING LIKE A BATTERY
POWERED AT EIGHT AM RADIO ON
BECAUSE THAT IS STILL A
REDUNDANT WAY TO GET EMERGENCY
INFORMATION OUT TO THE PUBLIC.
WHEN OTHER DISTRACTIONS OCCUR.
TURNING BRIEFLY TO THE SUBJECT
OF EVACUATION WHICH IS AB ALSO-
AND- INTEREST TO THIS HEARING
TODAY. HELLO- YES WORKS WITH
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS
EACH AND EVERY DAY AS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
MUTUAL AID. SYSTEM A MAJOR
ADVANCEMENT TRIED TO ALERT
MORNING IS STANDARDIZED
TERMINOLOGY FOR EVACUATION. IN
THE PAST DIFFERENT TERMINOLOGY
WAS USED DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU
WORK DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES-
SAID DIFFERENT THINGS IN TERMS
OF HOW THEY DIRECTED
EVACUATION. ZONE HE TO THE
MOMENT THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE IT
BE DIFFICULT NOT TO ALWAYS KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TERMS. MANDATORY EVACUATION
VERSUS VOLUNTARY EVACUATION
EVACUATION ORDER OF EVACUATION
ADVISORY SHELTER IN PLACE SO
THAT WAS DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
TERMINOLOGY USED ACROSS THE
STATE. SO IN MARCH OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THE SAME TIME WE
PUBLISH THE OTHER MORNING
GUIDELINES HELLO YES CONVENE
WILL BE CALLED THE EVACUATION.
TERMINOLOGY WORKING GROUP. I
REPRESENTED FROM A THE LAW
COURSE SERVICES FROM EVER
REGION AND STATE WITH A CALL OF
STANDARDIZATION SETTLING ON ONE
WAY TO DO THIS ACROSS THE STATE
THE GROUP UNANIMOUSLY
RECOMMENDED THE FOLLOWING. FOR
USE THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO NOW THE- THE ONLY
TERMINOLOGY THAT- THAT IS USED
AS EVACUATION ORDER EVACUATION
WARNING. AND SHELTER IN PLACE
SO THIS IS A HUGE STEP- IT'S
BEEN ADOPTED NOW IT'S IN USE-
IT'S CLEAR IT'S CONSISTENT AND
THE MEDIA IS YOU KNOW IMPORTANT
RELAY OF EMERGENCY INFORMATION-
CAN REFER TO THE SAME TERMS.
AND WE REALLY JUST APPLIED OUR
FIRE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS I KNOW THAT. SOME OF
THEM ARE PANELISTS HERE TODAY I
FOR THEIR OUTSTANDING
COLLABORATION ON THIS ISSUE
RECOGNIZING THIS NEED IT
BECAUSE I'M PRESIDENT STEP. TO
IMPROVE SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WE'VE MADE A LOT OF. THERE
IS A LOT OF WORK TO DO AS
ALREADY HAS BEEN MENTIONED IN
THE OPENING COMMENTS EVENTS IN
THE STATE CONTINUE TO SHOW
THIS. FOR OUR PART HELLO YES IS
COMMITTED TO KEEP ISSUE AT THE
FOREFRONT THE SAM'S GROUP THAT
I MENTIONED ITS WORK DIDN'T
STOP WITH PUBLISHING THE
GUIDELINES AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
RATHER THAT GROUP IS GOING TO
STAY IN PLACE TO BE CONTINUOUS
TO REVIEW EVENTS TO UPDATE THE
GUIDELINES AS WE AS WE LEARN
AND- AND MOVE THEIR OFFENSE AND
ALSO DEVELOP OTHER POLICIES IN
THIS AREA. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
COUNTIES AND LOCAL JUSTICE-
SECTIONS ON TRAINING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND GUIDANCE- THE
SYSTEMS HAVE TO BE USED ALL
YEAR STEP PRACTICED- TRADE TO
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO BE
EFFECTIVE WHEN THE TIME IS
NEEDED. OUR RELATIONSHIP IS
CONTINUING TO BE CONTINUOUS
BECAUSE WE HAVE A DEDICATED
ALERT WARNING COORDINATOR AND
BETTER HELLO YES WHOSE JOB IS
TO DO THIS AND WORK WITH OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS. EACH AND EVERY
DAY MAKE SURE THAT TESTING
OCCURS OF THE SYSTEM AND MAKE
SURE THAT MAINTENANCE OF THE
IPOD CAPABILITY THIS IS
STAYING. AT FOR THIS CRITICAL
SET OF SYSTEMS TO WORK ACTION
IS REQUIRED ON EVERYBODY'S PART
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
MEDICATION PROVIDERS AND THE
PUBLIC AS WELL. BUT I TELL
EVERYONE CAN RECEIVE TIMELY AND
ACCURATE WARNINGS EVERY TIME
OUR WORK WILL. AND SOME OF THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE IN THE
PAST COUPLE YEARS I WILL
CONCLUDE THERE AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
COMPLETION OF THE PANEL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS CURRY AND
YOUR TEAM AT CALLOW YES FOR
THIS INFORMATIVE UPDATE- NEXT-
WE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM
CHIEF CRAIG TOLD ME. OUR CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
CALIFORNIA. GOOD MORNING SURE
CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY LET ME BEGIN
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR RIVAS
VICE CHAIRMAN WIRE AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
CRAIG TOLD ME NINETEENTH DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CAL FIRE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY ON THE TOPIC OF EMERGENCY
ALERTS AND EVACUATIONS WERE
EXCITED TO BE HERE WITH HELLO
YES AS WELL AS OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COOPERATORS. WALL
COUNSELOR DOES NOT SEND UT
EMERGENCY ALERTS ARE IN FIRST
INFORCE EVACUATION ORDERS THE
DEPARTMENT PLAYS AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN THE VITAL FUNCTIONS
PROVIDE BY PROVIDING CRITICAL
INFORMATION AND INTELLIGENCE
THE LEARNING AUTHORITIES THAT
HELPS KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF HARM'S
WAY DURING THE LONG PRIOR.
TODAY I WILL BRIEFLY DISCUSS
HOW CALPERS SUPPORTS ALERT. AND
WARNINGS BEFORE DURING AND
AFTER A WILDFIRE. WELL BEFORE
THE START OF A WILDFIRE CAL
FIRE MONITORS ANALYZES AND
PREDICTS FIRE WEATHER INSPIRED
ANGEL ACROSS THE STATE AS PART
OF AN INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAM.
HOW DID OUR NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA YOUR
GRAPHIC AREA COORDINATING
CENTERS OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
GAPS. WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH METEOROLOGIST FROM THE
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE AS
WELL AS OTHER FEDERAL AGENCY
PARTNERS. THE TEAMS THAT ARE
GAC'S GATHER INTERPRET
INTELLIGENCE ON FIRE AND
WEATHER THREATS USING MAPPING
AND SATELLITE IMAGERY
PRIMATOLOGY PREPAREDNESS LEVELS
RESOURCE AVAILABILITY. YOUR
MODELS AND FIRE POTENTIAL
INFORMATION TO PREDICT WHERE
FIRE DANGER IS HIGHEST AND WERE
EXPECTED CONDITIONS COULD
IMPACTOUR AVAILABLE
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES. CAL
FIRE UTILIZES INTELLIGENCE ON
WHETHER ENTIRE THREAT
CONDITIONS TO CREATE PRODUCTS
FOR DECISION MAKERS. IN THE
FIRE SERVICE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THROUGH OUR PREDICTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM THANK OF
AN INNER. FIRE SERVE IN TELE
CLEARINGHOUSE ENSURING THAT
STANDARDIZED PRODUCTS AND
PREDICTED FIRE WEATHER AND
TRANSFORMATION IS AVAILABLE TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES ACROSS
THE STATE WHICH ALLOWED THEM TO
BE MORE PROACTIVE IN
ANTICIPATING SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANT FIRE ACTIVITY. AND
DETERMINING LOCAL FIREFIGHTING
RESOURCE NEEDS IN ADVANCE OF AN
INCIDENT. ONE OF THE PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY IS A PREDICTIVE
SERVICES IS TO PROVIDE SOUND
GUIDANCE DEPARTMENT FIRE
MANAGEMENT DECISION MAKERS.
CONCERNING CURRENT AND
PROJECTED SIGNIFICANT FIRE
POTENTIAL. ALTHOUGH WEATHER IS
A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO
CONTRIBUTOR TO SIGNIFICANT FIRE
POTENTIAL THIS PRODUCT IS NOT A
WEATHER FORECAST BUT RATHER A
THREAT INDICATOR FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LARGE WILDFIRES
BASED ON FUEL CONDITIONS AND
WEATHER COMBINED. IT DOESN'T
THE DAILY PROBABILITY FOR THE
OCCURRENCE OF A NEW LARGE FIRE
FOR THE POTENTIAL FOR
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH ON EXISTING
FIRES. ARE NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GEOGRAPHIC
AREA COORDINATION CENTERS
COMPILED SIGNIFICANT FIRE
POTENTIAL ANOTHER FIRE
INTELLIGENCE T IN NUMEROUS
PRODUCTS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO. THE TWO DAY OUTLOOK
OF FIRE POTENTIAL ISSUED IN
BOTH NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE SEVEN DAY
SIGNIFICANT FIRE POTENTIAL
OUTLOOK ISSUED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE SANTA ANA
WILDFIRE THREAT INDEX ISSUED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
DAILY AND MONTHLY BRIEFINGS
DISCUSSING THE CURRENT FIELD.
CONDITIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT IT CERTAINLY AVAILABLE ON
THE- CENTERS WEB. FULLER AND
WARNING. AS WELL AS FOR THE G.
PUBLIC. LISTEN LOW GOVERNMENT
MAY FROM PUSH OUT PUBLICLY
MESSAGE. THROUGH THEIR ALERT
SYSTEM TO NOTIFY COMMUNITIES OF
THE POTENTIAL FOR A WHILE PER
INCIDENT AND THE NEED TO TAKE
PRECAUTIONARY MEASURES SUCH AS
GETTING READY TO EVACUATE OR
LIMITING CERTAIN ACTIVITIES
THAT COULD CAUSE A FIRE. CAL
FIRE ALSO USES ITS OWN PUBLIC
EDUCATION COMMUNICATION
CHANNELS TO AMPLIFY. FIRE
WEATHER WARNING MESSAGES ISSUED
BY THE NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE
INCLUDING FIRE WEATHER WATCHES
AND RED FLAG WARNINGS. THE
BASIC DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THESE
TWO TYPES THE WEATHER SERVICE
ALERTS IS THAT WHILE A FIRE
WEATHER WATCH. INDICATES
UPCOMING WEATHER CONDITIONS
THAT COULD RESULT IN EXTENSIVE
WILDLAND FIRE OR EXTREME FIRE
BEHAVIOR. WHEREAS A RED FLAG
WARNING INDICATES AN ONGOING OR
IMMINENT CRITICAL FIRE WEATHER
PATTERN. FOR FIRE CONDITIONS
ARE ETHER ONGOING OR EXPECTED
TO OCCUR SHORTLY THAT WOULD BE
OF A EXTREME NATURE. WHAT'S THE
FIRE HAS BEGUN OR AFTER
WILDFIRE STARTS THE BUYERS
INCIDENT COMMANDER WILL ADVISE
LOCAL OFFICIALS IF ANY. NEARBY
AREAS NEED TO BE EVACUATED
BASED ON THE FIRES LOCATION
BEHAVIOR. AND WEATHER
FORECASTING. YEAH FIRE HAS
SEVERAL CUTTING EDGE TOOLS TO
PROVIDE REAL TIME FIRE AND
WEATHER INFORMATION TO OUR
INCIDENT COMMANDERS TO HELP
THEM ADVISED LOCAL OFFICIALS ON
THE NEED FOR ANY BACK THE WAY
HE- INCLUDING WE HAVE NINETY
TWO REMOTE UTOMATED WEATHER
STATIONS ARE WATCHES. ON STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREAS AROUND THE
STATE THAT. PROVIDE CRITICAL
INFORMATION ON CLIMATOLOGY.
BASED ON THE LOCAL PHOTOGRAPHY
THAT THEY ARE IN THERE ARE OVER
ONE HUNDRED FIRE ABOUT ASIAN
CAMERAS HOSTED BY THE ALERT BOB
FOR NETWORK THAT COULD BE USED
TO VISUALLY CONFIRM ACQUIRES
LOCATION. AND BEHAVIOR IN MANY
FIRE HAZARD AREAS ACROSS THE
STATE. WE ALSO HAVE ONDEMAND
WILDFIRE SPREAD PREDICTION IN A
WILDFIRE WITH FORECASTING
SOFTWARE THAT PROVIDES INSTANT
COMMANDERS WITH WOMEN. FIRE
BEHAVIOR MODELING AND PREDICTED
FIRE BEHAVIOR DATA INCLUDING
POTENTIAL IMPACTS NEARBY
BUILDINGS POPULATIONS. AND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. USING
VOEPEL THE GROUND ON. AND
SURVEY. THE ANSWER COMMANDER
WILL WRECK. WHICH AREAS SHOULD
BACK TO LOOK ON ON AN ONGOING
BASIS DURING AND- BUT THE
DECISION IS AN ENFORCE THE-
ORDERS REST WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN. SIMILARLY THE
DECISION MARK ALERTS THE PUB
ALSO RESTS WITH THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITY OR LOCAL
EMERGENCY MANAGERS. THE
INCIDENT COMMANDER WILL ALSO
ADVISE LOCAL OFFICIALS ONCE
INSTEAD PROGRESSES TO A POINT
WHERE YOU ACCURATE AREAS CAN BE
REPOPULATED. BUT THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITY DETERMINES
WHEN RESIDENTS CAN RETURN TO
THEIR HOMES AND ONE EVACUATION
ORDERS CAN BE LIFTED. KALPI
RECOGNIZES THE CRITICAL NEED TO
BE IN CLOSE COMMUNICATION WITH
LOCAL OFFICIALS EMERGENCY
MANAGERS. AND THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITY FOR THIS
PROCESS TO WORK EFFECTIVELY.
DURING LARGE INCIDENTS WILL
OFTEN INNER AND UNIFIED COMMAND
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
LEADERS. AND LOCAL OKAY AND
THEN IT'S A COMMAND POST SO YOU
GRADUATION RECOMMENDATIONS CAN
RELATE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
DOUBTFIRE ALSO EMBEDS ONE FOUR
SPENT REPRESENTATIVES WITHIN
EACH OF OUR INCIDENT MANAGEMENT
TEAMS IN ORDER TO FACILITATE.
RAPID INFORMATION SHARING. WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
IF NEEDED FIRE. WILL ALSO
ASSUME LOCAL FOR. THE HELP BACK
TO. INDIVIDUAL FROM A GIVEN
AREA IT CAN. WARRANT AFTER
WILDFIRE. HAS BURNED ESPECIALLY
THE MORE SIGNIFICANT WILDFIRES
AS WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS CABALLERO
COOPERATION WITH OTHER
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY DEPARTMENTS MAY DEPLOY A
WATERSHED EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TEAM OR WORK TO ASSESS
POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO SPECIFIC
VALUES AT RISK FROM ANTICIPATED
WATERSHED RESPONSES. TO BURN
IMPACT. PART NINE ALL CORD WITH
BURKE AREA NUMBER RESPONSE OF
TEAM. TO ASSESS THE OF FIRE ON
THE MAY BY AND WATERSHED. LARGE
WILDFIRES DRAMATICALLY ALTER
SOIL AND TRAIN INCREASE THE
DANGEROUS FIVE AND MUD FLOW
CONDITIONS ONE SIGNIFICANT RAIN
WATER RETURNS TO THE LANDSCAPE.
ACCORDING AFTER HE FIRED OFTEN
MORE SEVERE WHAT OTHER OCCUR
BECAUSE TO BRING IN. FIRE IN
COMBINE ONCE SAID ABOUT THE
WATER STORY ACROSS THE CHART
INTO NEEDED RIGHT. SPECIAL WORK
IN TEAMS DETERMINE THE NEED
FROM BY AND PICK THEM MINIMUM
THE TO AND PROPERTY AND WORK
WITH LOCAL AND OF. AND CA
OPPOSED FLOOD RISK IN THEIR
GIVE LOCAL INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO. EMERGENCY ALERTS AND
DOESN'T YOU LIKE ARE SHOULD
EXACTLY SIGNIFICANT WAY. ON
BURNS. IS INCLUDED LIKE TO
REMIND YOU THAT CAL FIRE IS
READY WILD APP IS A GREAT
SOURCE FOR ONE FROM ON ME OF
THE TOPICS ADVENTURE TODAY.
WHILE OUR APP SHOULD NOT BE
USED AS AN EMERGENCY ALERT TO
ALL THE PROVIDES THE PUBLIC
WITH STEP BY STEP INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO PREPARE THEIR HOMES
AND FAMILIES BEFORE DURING. AND
AFTER WILDFIRE STRIKES AND
PROVIDES A SHORT SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS RENDON REVEALS
EXAMINES ABOUT WILDFIRE
ACTIVITY BOTH IN THEIR LOCAL
AREAS. OF ALL TRAVELING THROUGH
THE STATE. IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
EVERY PERSON MAY BE IN. BY A
WILD CAL. IF YOU READY FOR AN
INCIDENT TOOK HER. THIS IN. PRE
IMAGE THE FOR SPACE AND HARD
THEIR HOME AGAINST FINANCE.
GETTING FOR OPINION. EVACUATION
BY PER IN ADVANCE AND UP TO
RECEIVE EMERGENCY ALERTS YOUR
THEIR AGENCIES AND OF COURSE
BEING READY TO GO THEY HAVE THE
BEST CHANCES RABINAL WILDFIRE
BY BEING READY TO GO AND
EVACUATING EARLY AND WHEN LOCAL
OFFICIALS ADVICE THANK YOU FR
YOUR TIME AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU CHIEF TOLD ME
N. CAL FIRE FOR EVERYTHING THAT
YOU DO TO KEEP US SAFE-
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS FIRE
SEASON- BEFORE I TURN IT OVER
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK. UP SENATOR PAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY FOR JOINING
US TODAY IN PERSON AT THIS
HEARING THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. AND NEXT. DOES ANY ANY
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS OKAY I'LL START WITH
SENATOR PAN. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I WANT TO THANK OUR
TWO PRESENTERS- I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR- DIPPY DIRECTOR
CURRY FOR- IN. SO FIRST OF ALL
UP ONE OF THE WAYS PEOPLE DO
GET INFORMATION THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA AND IN FACT- ONE EXAMPLE
WASN'T A WILDFIRE BUT WHEN THE
OROVILLE DAM WAS BEING
CHALLENGED. ARE ACTUALLY- WE
SAW ON SOCIAL MEDIA THE
EVACUATION ORDERS FROM- THAT
THE COUNTY SHERIFF AND SO FORTH
AND BEING DOWNSTREAM FROM THE
DAM WONDERED WHAT THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO MEAN. ARE THERE
GUIDELINES THAT- YES IS PUTTING
OUT OR AGAIN I KNOW THAT A LOT
OF THIS IS BEING ALSO DONE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT IN TERMS
OF. HOW SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS ARE
USED OR SHOULD BE APPROPRIATELY
USED OR NOT USED TO SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT DISASTERS
BECAUSE- I THINK AS YOU. TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER YOU KNOW WHEN THE
CONCERNS ABOUT SOME OF THE-
CELL PHONE NOTIFICATIONS OF THE
TYPES OF THINGS IS YOU KNOW THE
NOTICE IS GETTING INTO OTHER
AREAS AND CAUSING CONFUSION-
BUT THAT WAS ALSO SITUATION
SOCIAL MEDIA. AND PERHAPS
HAVING AND I'M SAYING DON'T USE
SOCIAL MEDIA AT ALL BUT SOME
GUIDELINES FOR HOW SOCIAL MEDIA
USE APPROPRIATELY BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF PEOPLE SEE
THESE POSTS AND DIFFERENT WAYS
AND THEY'LL BE SHARED AND SO
FORTH. AND THEN NOT THEN ALL
THESE PHONE CALLS ARE HAPPENING
TO DIFFERENT OFFICES SO HE HAS
TO DISCUSSION ABOUT. WHETHER
THERE'S THOUGHTS ABOUT GUY FOR.
USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA BY
APPROPRIATE AUTHORITIES LOCAL
AND STATE TO. GIVE INFORMATION
OUT ABOUT- EITHER DISASTERS ARE
IMPENDING DISASTERS. CENTER
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION-
ABSOLUTELY I MENTIONED THE
OTHER MORNING GUIDELINES I
DIDN'T TALK TOO MUCH ABOUT
WHAT'S IN THEM BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S RECOGNIZED IN
THOSE IS IT THAT OUR OUR MULTI
NODE OF WAYS TO GET INFORMATION
OUT SOCIAL MEDIA ABSOLUTELY IS
AB ONE OF THE PROMINENT WAYS WE
USE IT- TO RELATE I'M EVEN
EMERGENCY INFORMATION AS DO
MOST COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S HOW
MOST PEOPLE YOU KNOW MANY
PEOPLE. ARE LOOKING OUT IN
DENVER AND RELY ON AS A SOURCE
SO THE GUIDELINES TO ADDRESS
AND NOT JUST THE IPODS IN THE
WE- BUT LOCAL OTHER MORNING
PROGRAMS AND YOU KNOW JUST
RECOGNIZING THAT THESE EXIST
AND- YOU KNOW WAYS THAT WE CAN
STANDARDIZE THOSE SAID THAT
AGAIN WERE CLEAR AND CONSISTENT
ACROSS THE PUBLIC. TO THE
EXTENT WE NEED TO DO MORE
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT ARE YOU
KNOW ONGOING WORK IS- TO VALUE
WAIT HOW THAT WENT IF WE HAVE
TO BEEF UP THE- SOCIAL MEDIA-
KIND OF REFERENCE OR CREATE
SOMETHING EVEN AS AN ADDENDUM
WILL ABSOLUTELY DO THAT BUT
WE'LL WE'LL TAKE A LOOK. AT
THAT AND I'LL VERIFY THAT TIME
THAT WE'VE GOT TO THAT TYPE OF-
GUIDANCE CAPTURED AND CERTAINLY
AS WE WORKABLE GOVERNMENT GOING
FORWARD WE WILL BE EVALUATING
THAT BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
MAKING THAT COMMENT AND- A
GREAT. THAT THAT'S ANOTHER AREA
WHERE STANDARDIZATION AND
CONSISTENCY IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE THAT IS GOING TO BE A
REALLY PROMINENT WAY- THAT THAT
EMERGING INFORMATION WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED. WELL THANK YOU- IT
WOULD MAKE NO TO CHALLENGE
SOCIAL MEDIA IT'S HARD TO LIMIT
WHERE THE MESSAGE GOES SO THE
CLARITY THAT MESSAGE BECOMES
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
EXAMPLE EXACTLY WHICH AREAS ARE
AFFECTED ALL RIGHT- SO IT COULD
BE COMING FROM THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE. AND THEY'RE JUST
THINKING IT'S GOING TO PEOPLE
IN THE COUNTY BUT PEOPLE
AFFORDING THINGS AND PEOPLE ARE
ON THE BORDER TO GO WHAT WAS
THAT SUPPOSED TO MEAN FOR ME AS
I MENTIONED WHEN THE OROVILLE
DAM THEY HAD- ISSUE WITH THE-
THE NOW THE TAMPA TENCHI
OVERTOPPING OR DIRECT- THOSE OF
US ARE DOWNSTREAM WENT WHAT WAS
THAT SUPPOSED TO MEAN USERS
TRYING TO EVACUATE RIGHT AND
IRONICALLY THE FIRST I HEARD.
ABOUT IT WAS ON A LIST TO SEE A
ALERT ON SOCIAL MEDIA WAS NOT
THROUGH SOME OF SOURCE. SO I
THINK THAT- YOU KNOW SOME
CAREFUL EXAM. ABOUT OUR BEST
PRACTICES IT COMES TO SOCIAL
MEDIA POSTS THAT WHEN PEOPLE
SEE INFORMATION AND THEY'RE NOT
IN THE AREA WHAT HOW DO THEY
KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE AFFECTED-
YOU KNOW SO BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE SEEING IT. WHO-
WHO WILL BE INTERPRETING IN
DIFFERENT WAYS DEPENDING ON YOU
KNOW WHERE THEY ARE AND SO
FORTH SO I THINK THAT'S GONNA
BE VERY IMPORTANT. THEN I GUESS
THE OTHER QUESTION I ANSWER HAD
IS THAT I KNOW THAT THE
ABOUT.
AND NEED FOR BACK UP POWER AND
SO FORTH AND NINE AND I
UNDERSTAND CERTAINLY. IN THIS
HEARING AND THAT THE MORE
IMMEDIATE CONCERNS WILDFIRES
BUT I REPRESENT SACRAMENTO OUR
BIGGEST ISSUES TRYING TO BE
FLOOD. NOT SAY WE DON'T
POTENTIALLY A WILDFIRE. WE'RE
MORE THINK ABOUT THESE BACK UP
SYSTEMS. ARE WE ALSO PAYING
STANDARDS BE SURE THEY'RE
WALKING SINCE A FLOOD PROOF IS
PROBABLY OVER BUT THE FLOOD
RESISTANT RIGHT SO YOU NOTHING
GENERATORS ON THE GROUND. WHERE
WHEN THE WATER STARTS RISING
BASICALLY THE GENERATORS GO OUT
AND CELL TOWERS ARE STILL OUT
SO. CAN YOU AYE MAYBE TOUCH ON
THAT. WELL OUR APPROACH IS ALL
HAZARDS WILDFIRES IS- I THINK
THAT IS. OCCURRING MORE
COMMONLY THESE DAYS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT BUT WE NEVER THE
DESTRUCTION. AND HER. FROM A
VARIETY OF MEANS YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S EIGHT YOU KNOW
TRAFFIC ACCIDENT THAT TAKES OUT
POWER OR A FLOOD DISASTER AN
EARTHQUAKE OR HAVE SO WE'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING AT A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY. TO ENSURE
THERE'S REDUNDANCY I DON'T HAVE
THAT TECHNICAL KNOWLEDGE OF
EXACTLY THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CELL TOWERS AND WHAT WORKS BEST
FOR DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHIC AREAS
AND IN CALIFORNIA BUT- I DO
KNOW THAT. REDUNDANCY IN REGARD
TO COMMUNICATION SO IT ARE VERY
UPSET PLANNING EFFORTS AND
EXERCISES FOR DIFFERENT TYPES
OF DISASTER WE TALK THROUGH-
WHAT IT IS WE'RE GOING TO NEED
TO BE ABLE TO DO. AND HOW THE
STATE CAN WORK WITH OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WOULD BE THE REDUNDANCIES
WHETHER IT'S A REDUNDANCY FOR.
TRANSPORTATION A REDUNDANCY FOR
COMMUNICATIONS SO- SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO ALWAYS
ENSURE. ARE WARNING CENTER
ITSELF HAS MULTIPLE REDUNDANT
PATHWAYS- WE HAVE AND HE
COULDN'T HAVE BEEN INCLUDING A
MARKER WITH A SYSTEM. AND THAT
CONNECTS THE STATE FROM END TO
END FOR INFORMATION AND RELAY-
BY SATELLITE. INFORMATION
SYSTEM THAT'S IN PLACE IN EVERY
SINGLE COUNTY IN ADDITION TO
MOBILE COMMUNICATION- SO ALL OF
THAT'S THERE OF COURSE AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALERT
MORNING WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
MESSAGING THAT CANNOT WAIT
UNTIL WE DISCOVER THAT IT HAD
OUTAGES OCCURRED AND THEN SO OF
COURSE SOME OF THESE ARE MORE
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS THAT- THAT
AT ABSOLUTELY. AB RIGHT
REDUNDANCY IS AN ABSOLUTE
PRINCIPLE IN OUR BUSINESS AND
ANYONE WHO'S IN PUBLIC SAFETY
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
CERTAINLY- IT'S SOMETHING WE'LL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ON THIS TOPIC. THE
THE RELIABILITY OF THE SYSTEMS
THAT SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
MESSAGING THAT HAS TO GO OUT TO
THE PUBLIC. IS RIGHT AS AS
ROBUST AS IT NEEDS TO BE SO- SO
I KIND OF A- LONG ANSWER TO SAY
THAT WE LOOK AT ALL HAVE- AND
IN ADDITION TO. THAT YOU NEED
MORE COMMON HAZARDS THAT FIXED.
RECENTLY RESHAPE THAT- IT'S
HEARD STORY- NOT HERE AND TELL
BUT IN OTHER STATES WHERE
EXAMPLE IF HALF IN THE BUT ONLY
FLOOR THEN THEY WONDERED WHY
DIDN'T HAVE POWER. RIGHT-
BECAUSE THEY'RE UNDER WATER
THEN WORK VERY WELL UNDER WATER
SO- AND CERTAINLY I KNOW THAT-
WE'VE INVESTED AS A STATE
HAVING BEEN ON BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE AND VARIOUS
COMPONENTS COMMUNICATION BUT
THEN AGAIN THINK ABOUT THE
RESIDENCY TO THE PUBLIC I THINK
SPREAD THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE.
RIGHT BECAUSE YOU DON'T CONTROL
WHAT NOW WHEN WE HAVEN'T FOUND
ONLY A CELLPHONE OR HOW WE'RE
GETTING OUR INFORMATION AND YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S RADIO PHONE
OR OTHER TYPES OF SOURCES AND
INCLUDING SOCIAL MEDIA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR ANSWERS.
THANK YOU I SENATE JACK'S. HAS
A QUESTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE IT AND THANK YOU FOR
THOSE VERY KIND WORDS YOU KNOW
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
COMMITTEE- THE PRINCIPAL OR AT
LEAST THE INITIAL IMPACT CRASH
PRIMARY ROLE OF GOVERNMENT IS
THE PROTECTION AND THE SAFETY
OF ITS PEOPLE. AND CLEARLY-
WITH THE WILDFIRES AND THEN OF
COURSE THE DEBRIS FLOW WE
SUFFERED IN MY DISTRICT AND
THEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR DAM- PREACHING
AND WHAT HAVE YOU AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR EARTHQUAKES ALL
THESE THINGS ARE REAL IN
CALIFORNIA AND I APPRECIATE
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR. FOR
BRINGING THIS HEARING FORWARD
TODAY- BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT A
LOT OF THE DEATHS AND THE
DESTRUCTION THAT TOOK PLACE WAS
AS A RESULT OF INADEQUATE-
WARNINGS OR A DECISION MAKING
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT WERE THE
BEST APPROACH IS THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD TAKE- TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES- DURING THESE
INCIDENTS- SENATOR MCGUIRE HAS
DONE SOME VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION ON WARNING SYSTEMS.
I ALSO- I DRAFTED AND WAS A
FORTUNE ENOUGH TO GET PAST OF
LEGISLATION TO EXPAND- COUNTY
LISTS WHEN- WHEN IT COMES TO
NOTIFICATIONS WE FIND THAT WHEN
IT'S AN OPT IN SYSTEM WE REALLY
HAVEN'T GOTTEN A WHOLE LOT OF-
RESPONSE AND SO LEGISLATION
IDEA CALLS FOR OPT OUT SYSTEM
SO THAT- PEOPLE WILK- WHERE
THEY COUNTIES WILL PROACTIVELY
PUT PEOPLE ON THESE WARNING
SYSTEMS SO THAT. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- PEOPLE WILL
BE WARNED OF THE DANGERS AHEAD
AND SO I THINK- SB A TWENTY ONE
AND THEN S. B. A SEVEN NINETY
FOUR WERE TWO BILLS THAT I THAT
I BROUGHT TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM THEY WORK- ULTIMATELY.
I SHOULD SAY AT EIGHT TWENTY
ONE DID PAST SEVEN NINETY FOR
WAS ALL IN COURT. INTO A AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN THE- BOTH
RELYING ON PROACTIVE EFFORTS ON
THE PART OF OUR COUNTIES AND
OUR TELECOM PROVIDERS TO SHARE
CONTACT INFORMATION SO PEOPLE
CAN BE WARRANT APPROPRIATELY-
AND- YOU KNOW NOT JUST AS THE
AUTHOR THAT LEGISLATION BUT
SOMEONE WHO'S HAD THE
PERSONALLY EVACUATE NUMEROUS
TIMES- I KNOW THAT- MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE WHO ARE HERE
TODAY HAVE SHARED THAT.
DISTINCTION AND- IT'S
HORRIFYING AND IT'S VERY
INTIMIDATING AND- IT'S SCARY IS
PROBABLY JUST A GOOD WORD NOT
KNOWING WHAT TO DO WHERE TO GO
WIDE WHAT WAS GOING ON IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
THE SYSTEMS IN PLACE- AND I AM
VERY INTERESTED TO KNOW THE
STATUS. OF ALL OF OUR COUNTIES
EFFORTS TO EXPAND THEIR
UNIVERSE OF CONTACTS- IT WAS
NOTED TO- THAT TWENTY EIGHT
COUNTIES HAVE. PARTICIPATED IN
ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS WHAT WE
HAVE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WERE
THE OTHER THIRTY COUNTY- IS
CHALO YES AWARE ALL OF OUR- THE
SEVERAL COUNTIES THEIR STATUS
WITH REGARD TO EXPANDING OTHER
CONTACT THIS HI I WOULD LOVE TO
KNOW THAT IT SHOULD- CAL- YES
HAVE A ROLE. IN MONITORINGTHIS
PROCESS SO THAT- POLICYMAKERS
HAVE A CENTRAL SOURCE FOR
ASSESSING THE STATE OF THE ART
COUNTIES EFFORTS.
BUT AND ALSO
THE PUBLIC YOU KNOW IN IN TODAY
YOU KNOW THOSE ARE TO ME AND
DOING THEIR PART TO SIGN UP IS
AN IMPORTANT THING THAT ALL OF
US I THINK IT'S ACT COULD
BENEFIT. FROM PROMOTING AND
ENSURING THAT THAT PEOPLE ARE
AWARE OF THOSE TOOLS BUT IT'S
JUST GOT TO BE ALL THOSE THINGS
WORKING TOGETHER IT'S NEVER
GOING TO BE ONE THING AND THAT
WORKS FOR ALL IT'S GOT TO BE
ALL OF IT WORKING AND IN
CONCERT SO JUST YOUR HELP- WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE TOOLS YOU'VE
ALREADY GIVEN. THE REALLY TO
PROMOTE- BABY THE RESOURCES
THAT WERE TRYING TO MAKE
AVAILABLE AND MAKE IT EASY TO
ACCESS TO NAVIGATE THESE
SYSTEMS AGAIN- IF YOU DON'T USE
SOMETHING ALL THE TIME. IT IS
NOT THE TIME IN THE HEAT OF THE
BATTLE TO BE DOING IT FOR THE
FIRST TIME SO THAT TRAINING
EXERCISE PRACTICE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ALL OF THAT ON THE
FRONT END IS WHAT WE SEE OUR
ROLE TO DO AND WE'RE PREPARED
TO DO CONTINUE TO DO. OKAY
THANK YOU I HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION WHEN YOU MENTION AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR CREATING
A SINGULAR SYSTEM A WARNING
SAYS- CAN TO COUNTIES THAT I
REPRESENT WITH DIRECTLY WITH
THE THOMAS FIRE. EACH COUNTY
HAD A DIFFERENT- DESIGNATION SO
THE PUBLIC VERY CONFUSED AS TO
WHAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO DO
BUT ONE OF THE PROBLEMS TOO
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT CAME TO
THE DEBRIS FLOW IS THAT THE
MAPS THAT THEY WERE USING. WERE
OLDER MAPS AND THEY WERE
INACCURATE AND WE LOST TWENTY
THREE PEOPLE- IN PART BECAUSE
THE WARNINGS THAT WERE GIVEN
WERE BASED UPON INACCURATE IN
OLDER MAPS IS ALWAYS YES DOING
ANYTHING- TO. MAKE SURE THAT
THE INFORMATION THAT WE STAND
GOING OUT WITH THE WARNING
SYSTEMS AND SO FORTH IS
ACCURATE TO ARE YOU DOING ANY
MONITORING AT ANY OVERSEEING OF
THE VARIOUS KINDS OF EMERGENCY-
MAPS AND DATA. THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO ASSURE THAT THEY
ARE GETTING THE RIGHT
INFORMATION AND TRANSMITTING.
THAT PROPERLY TO THE PUBLIC.
AND ABSOLUTELY SO ON. FOR SAID
DIFFERENT. SORT OF PERCENT I'M
SO AS DIFFERENT DIFFERENT TYPES
OF. THAT WE INVOLVED FIRST ON.
OF COURSE WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
THERE'S A GOOD DOES GOING TO
KIRK ON A GIVEN YEAR TO THE
FOLKS FIVE. WATERSHED US. AND
MAPPING IS A REAL TIME FOR.
THAT IS INJURED. INTO A PART OF
OUR RESPONSE STRUCTURE SO
IMMEDIATELY KICKS INTO GEAR WE
PARTNER WITH CAL FIRE. WITH A
GEOLOGIST AND- SASS YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN OUR WILD FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA TEND ABOUT UP
AGAINST- YOU KNOW RAIN SEASON.
AND SO THAT THE MEDIA WORK OUT
TO BE DONE AND WE'RE DOING THAT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS WE
SPEAK TO MATT. AND HUMANITARIAN
AID TO COUNTIES AND COMMUNITIES
WHERE THOSE DEBRIS FLOW RISKS
EXIST I BASED ON THE WILD CARDS
THAT JUST OCCURRED. SO THAT
THEY CAN THEN EMPLOY THAT INTO
THEIR PRE POSITIONING THEIR A
LEARN WARNING. AND SYSTEMS AND-
KIND OF EVACUATION PREPARATIONS
FOR THE PUBLIC SO THAT'S ONE
FACET- FOR THINGS LIKE. TWO
NOMINEES YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S THE RISK IN CALIFORNIA
WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE OUR
GEOGRAPHY. YOU KNOW SORT OF A
WHAT A WORST CASE WOULD PRESENT
WEEDMAPS THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'VE BEEN DOWN OF
THE OF THE COAST. AND THAT'S AN
EFFORT THAT WE PARTNER WITH THE
WITH THE STATE GEOLOGIC SURVEY
ON. AND THAT INFORMATION IMPACT
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WHEN
THAT JAPAN EARTHQUAKE AND
TSUNAMI OCCURRED. AND A COUPLE
OF PLACES- SANTA CRUZ NOTABLY
AND END UP ON THE NORTH COAST
HAD HAD ISSUES HAD HAD TSUNAMI
INUNDATION. THEY ACTUALLY USE
THE TSUNAMI INUNDATION MAPS
THAT WE HAD CREATED TOGETHER.
DO YOU REALLY AREN'T ARC OUT
THERE EVACUATION GUIDANCE OF
COURSE IN THAT CASE. THERE WAS
MANY HOURS OF WARNING A LITTLE
MORE TRYING. TO BE REALLY
PRECISE ON ON INSTRUCTING THE
PUBLIC AND YOU ARE NOT ALWAYS
GOING TO HAVE THAT- AND- I'D
SAY ANOTHER AREA THAT'S KIND OF
RECENT THAT IS HAS AN IMPORTANT
MAPPING COMPONENT THE COW IS
INVOLVED WITH IT IS FOR DAM
SAFETY OF COURSE WE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ORVILLE AS A RESULT
OF THAT. EVENT- THE WHOLE SWEEP
A SET OF CHANGES CAME ABOUT
TERMS. AT THE END. REQUIREMENTS
OF THE WORLD KALAYAAN PLAYS AND
THAT. YOU HAVE TO WORK WITH
EVERY SINGLE JURORS. THAT A IT
COULD BE IMPACTED A- TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE SOME CALLED.
EMERGENCY ACT. PLANS IN PLACE-
AND THERE IS A SERIES OF THAT
TIME FRAMES. WITH THAT HE AP IS
ONE OF THE FUNDING THINGS THAT
THEY CLEAR. IS APPLIED- LEARN
MARNIE THIS IS GONNA LEVELS WHO
ARE THEY GONNA TELL. AND HOW
DOES THAT INFORM. GET FIRST
RESPONDER IN THE- IT'S SET- IN
A BIT. OF PREVENT DAMAGE SENT
THOSE HE HE'S ANOTHER.
COMPONENT OF. YES THEY DO IN A-
MAPS THAT HAS TO BECOME. BY
ENGINEER HAS TO BE SO OFF-
VI<c.cyan> I READ. FOR SAFETY. AND</c>
THEY HAVE TO BE MADE AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC SO THAT'S A BIG
CHANGE AND IT WAS KIND OF ODD
HI. IT CONSISTENT FRAMEWORK FOR
US IS GREAT FOR DAM SAFETY
BEFORE TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN THE
LEGISLATION. AND NOW THAT IS-
IS MORE STANDARDIZED ACROSS THE
STATE SO THOSE ARE JUST SOME
EXAMPLES. OR WORKING ON THE
MAPPING. AREA IN MY LAST-QUESTION IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR-
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS THERE ANY
POLICY ANY DIRECTIVE ANY
LEGISLATION. THAT YOU BELIEVE
WOULD MAKE IT. EASIER AND MORE
EFFECTIVE FOR YOU TO WORK WITH
THE COUNTIES- HAVING PERHAPS IT
IS AN EXAMPLE MORE AUTHORITY-
THE CONTROL- DIRECTIVE OVER-
THE WAY THE COUNTIES THEN.
CONDUCT THEIR EMERGENCY- WORK-
THAT WOULD THAT YOU THINK WOULD
MAKE IT MORE SUCCESSFUL IN
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC- AS WE
FACE. THESE KINDS OF DISASTERS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I MEAN WE
HAVE A GREAT REALLY. WITH OUR
COUNTIES THE SENSE. HAS BEEN
EMPLOYED FOR- WHAT SEEMS LIKE-
FOREVER HERE HELD. AND IT WORKS
AND PER IN OUR TOWN AND LOCAL
DRASTIC. AT THE PARTICIPATION
SYSTEM ENSURES THAT IT WORK IN
SUCH AN EXTENT THAT WE CAN.
JUST ENCOURAGE THAT THEY WE USE
THAT WE ALL KIND OF COME AROUND
THESE THESE COMMON FRAMEWORKS
THAT ALL INTER TIRED THE EACH
OTHER WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
FLOOD RISK. A MINUTE AGO- WE
CAN'T LOSE SIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT WE'RE ALL HAZARDS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SO YOU KNOW I
pDON'T I DON'T I YOU KNOW JUST
JUST TO BE ABLE TO. TO USUALLY
HAVE EFFECTIVELY I THINK CAN GO
A LONG WAY AND IT HAS IN THIS
SPACE BUT WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT
MORE TO DO WE'VE GOT EVALUATE
THESE PAST EVENTS AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S STILL GOING WRONG
AND HOW DO WE- BEST. AND SO-
YOU KNOW SO LIKE I SAID WE
HAVE. WE HAVE NO- SHORTAGE OF-
PARTICIPATION IN COLLABORATION
WITH OUR WITH OUR COUNTIES THEY
HAVE A HUGE JOB- IT ADDED THEN
WE RECOGNIZE THAT AND SO REALLY
OUR CHARGES TO MAKE THAT. IS
EASY AND RELEVANT AND TO THEM
AND- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY WE'VE
GOT TO SEE HOW SOME OF THESE
TOOLS THAT WE DO HAVE THAT HAVE
BEEN DEPLOYED ALL THIS IS ALL
VERY NEW. HOW IS THAT WORKING
AND THEN OF COURSE JUST LIKE
ANYTHING- WE WERE ELECTED TO
ADDRESSED IF NEEDED BUT- BUT WE
DO APPRECIATE. AND ADDS THAT
WORK FOR TOGETHER WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIRE SERVICE ON THE
TENT ON THE TERMINOLOGY. AND
WORK WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH THE
SAM'S COMMITTEE JUST THE FACT
THAT EVERYONE CAME TOGETHER
RECOGNIZED AS WHAT'S GOOD FOR
ONE COMMUNITY SHOULD BE YOU
KNOW KIND OF. CONSISTENT ACROSS
ALL COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
INDIVIDUAL EFFORTS IS HUGE. AND
WE WANT TO SEE MORE OF THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR. SAM NEXT WE HAVE
BY CHAIR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH READING CHAIR UP BE VERY
QUESTIONS UP FOR THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR DEPUTY DIRECTOR GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. JUST TWO ITEMS
NUMBER ONE ON THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR RULE FROM THE PC FOR
WIRELESS I THINK THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE- THE REDUNDANCY IN THE
BACKUP FOR THOSE CELL PHONE
TOWERS WOULD LIKE TO BE TO GET
YOUR TAKE SINCE THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR RULE DIDN'T APPLY TO LAND
LINES I THINK THAT'S JUST IT'S
CRITICAL. ESPECIALLY IN MORE
RURAL AREAS WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
GET THE TAKE FROM- YES AND THEN
ON A SECOND ISSUE IN REGARDS TO
THE ACTUATION ROUTES FOR THE
BILL RIGHT MEANT YOU'RE JUST
ASKING A QUESTION ABOUT TUITION
RATES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MANAGER HI THIS IS WORK THAT AS
CENTER JACKSON HAS BEEN A LOT
OF TIME ON IN HER SENATE BILL
ONE EIGHTY TWO- CAN YOU TALK.
ABOUT DEVELOP I THINK THERE'S
GROWING CONCERN ESPECIALLY IN
HIGH FIRE HAZARD. SEVERITY
ARIES. ABOUT NGUYEN IN IF WE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO BUILD- IN
THOSE AREAS AND IF WE ARE.
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW MANDATED
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AROUND
DEVELOPMENTS. MANDATING NO
LONGER ALLOWING ONE WAY AND ONE
WAY OUT BUT HAVING. TO WAIT FOR
INGRESS AND EGRESS- AND ALSO A
FUNDING MECHANISM FOR THOSE
pEDUCATION MANAGEMENT FIREBREAKS
GOING BUT WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE YOU COME IN MADAM
DEPUTY DIRECTOR IN THE SEVEN TO
OUR ROLE. FROM THE P. C. LAN
LINES AS WELL AS HAVING THOSE
TOUGH CONVERSATIONS WITH NEW
DEVELOPMENT- YEAH ABSOLUTELY ON
THAT SEVENTY TWO HOUR EXPANDING
THAT AND TO ENSURE THAT YOU
KNOW LIKE THERE'S DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT PEOPLE GET
INFORMATION IT'S NOT. JUST
CELLPHONES ALTHOUGH THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE HAVE CELL
PHONES AND- REDUNDANCY ACROSS
ALL THOSE LINES. AND WE FOUND
THAT YOU KNOW IT IT PS PS. AND
FIRES AND OTHER EVENTS- THESE
YOU KNOW POCKETS OF AREAS AND
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE
THERE'S GOING TO BE A DIFFERENT
SORT OF MAJORITY NEEDS A AT
COMMUNICATING WHETHER IT'S
VOICE INTERNET- CELLPHONE. OR
LANDLINE AND THEN ALL OF IT I'M
SHOULD BE SHOULD HAVE HAVE SOME
ABILITY TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
REDUNDANCY OR CARE OF OR SOME
OF THAT RESPONSIBILITY IS ON ON
THE PUBLIC TO KIND OF DO WHAT
THEY CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO INFORMATION BUT
CERTAINLY SOME OF IT. IS ON OUR
COMMUNICATION PROVIDERS AND OUR
REGULATORS WHO THEN- MANDATE
WHAT CHANGE NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN
ORDER SO- SO I DON'T HAVE THE
SPLIT ON EXACTLY- KIND OF LAND
LINE VERSUS CELL PHONE USE AND
THE DIFFERENCE THAT HAS. THIS
HAS MADE IN TERMS OF HAVING
ROLES BUT CERTAINLY WE WOULD BE
IN FAVOR OF. OF REDUNDANCY
ACROSS THE BOARD FOR
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS
PARTICULARLY FOR THIS IMPORTANT
ALERT MORNING IN TERMS OF THE I
CAN SPEAK A LITTLE BIT AND
JANET CHIEF DEPUTY TOLD ME
MIGHT HAVE SOME. INSIGHT AS
WELL BUT WE HAVE A FEW THINGS
ON IN TERMS OF EVACUATION
ROUTES AND RESOURCES THAT MIGHT
BE AVAILABLE FOR THAT. FIRST OF
ALL ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE IN
PLACE A LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN. THEY HAVE TO HAVE THAT IN
ORDER TO ACCESS FEDERAL
DOLLARS. AND POST DISASTER WHEN
THOSE EVENTS OCCUR WHICH HAS
BEEN COMMONPLACE I THINK WE
HAVE SOME TWENTY SEVEN COUNTIES
UNDER A FEDERAL DECLARATION OF
DISASTER RIGHT NOW JUST BE FROM
THAT FOUR MILLION ACRES. OF
WILDFIRES THAT BURNED THAT'S
NOT INCLUDING ALL THE STUFF
THAT PRE EXISTED ALL THE FIRES
AND THE EARTHQUAKE AND- IT IN A
COUPLE SUMMERS AGO. SO EVERYONE
OF THOSE BRINGS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR RISK REDUCTION. FUNDS.
THERE ARE MANY TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT CAN BE DONE THOSE
WERE DOT FINDS FOR AWHILE.
INCLUDING THE ENHANCEMENT OF
EVACUEE. BEEN MANAGEMENT- AB
THAT. THAT ARE FIRE- IF SOMEONE
AND SO THAT'S A BIG PART OF IT
BUT I THINK THAT AND I MEAN
AROUND BUT I THINK THE ONE ITEM
I WOULD SAY WITH THAT IS. THE
CHALLENGE FOR THOSE FUNDS YOU
HAVE TO. BUILD BACK TO WHAT YOU
HAD YOU CAN'T ENHANCE. IN
THAT'S BEEN THE CHALLENGE FOR
MANY COUNTIES AND THIS ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY AND I'VE
GONE THROUGH THAT- ESPECIALLY
WITH LIKE FOR EXAMPLE THE CDBG
DR FUNDS. THAT THERE'S SOME.
CHALLENGES IN SOME
REQUIREMENTS. I THINK GOING
FORWARD. ARE WE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD IN THOSE HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES. IN
IF WE ARE- AND MANY OF THESE
AREAS HAVE BURNED MULTIPLE
TIMES- NEEDING TO LOOK I GUESS
YOU'RE TAKE- YES IS TAKE ON- NO
LONGER ALLOWING FOR ONE WAY AND
ONE WAY OUT THAT'S A- HUGE CHU
POINT WHEN IT COMES TO
EVACUATIONS. NUMBER TWO LOOKING
AT MANDATED FIRE BREAKS IT HAD
TO BE MAINTAINED IN PERPETUITY
AS WE USED TO SEE- IN THE STATE
BUT JUST JUST GETTING TO THOSE
SPECIFIC ITEMS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD A NEW DEVELOPMENT. AS
WE CONTINUE TO BUILD INTO THE
WILL WE CONTINUE TO BUILDING
THOSE HIGH FIVE OR SIX. HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES.
YOUR TAKE ON DO WE NEED TO
UPDATE OUR STANDARDS ONCE
AGAIN- FOR PROTECTION OF THESE
NEW DEVELOPMENTS. WELL I
APPRECIATE WE ARE. THAT THE
COMMUNITY SAY. AND THE FACE OF
WILDFIRE AS ABSOLUTELY ABOUT
MOST IMPORTANT. I'M AND I
APOLOGIZE IF I WASN'T CLEAR- I
WAS TALKING ABOUT FUNDS THAT
CAN BE USED TO ENHANCE
SPECIFICALLY THEIR CALL HAVE A
MEDICATION. THAT IS DIFFERENT
FROM THAT KIND OF RETURN TO ADD
PRE DISASTER STATE- WHICH IS
ANOTHER FEMALE PROGRAM THAT.
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
FAMILIAR WITH- SO THOSE
PARTICULARLY COULD BE USED FOR
THINGS LIKE IMPROVING
EVACUATION SAFETY VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. SO YOU KNOW WHILE
WE AGREE THOSE ARE IMPORTANT.
AND WE HAVE PUT TO GET PUT
FORTH TOOLS AND IMPORTANTLY
LIKE REALLY CRITICAL INCENTIVES
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS WORK
GETS DONE. ACCESSING ANY
FILLERS AFTER DOLLARS REQUIRES
SOME ELEMENT OF PLANNING AND IF
THOSE PLANS ARE ADOPTED INTO
THE GENERAL PEN PLAN GUIDANCE
WHICH BY THE WAY WAS UNITED
BECAUSE WE EVERYONE KNOWS WAS
WERE UPDATED A COUPLE YEARS
AGO- ACROSS THE BOARD. TO
ADDRESS BETTER DISASTER
RESILIENCE THEN THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY TO EXPAND FUNDS
EVEN MORE SO WE ARE YOU KNOW
CONSTANTLY YOU KNOW TRYING TO.
DO A QUICK CALL FORWARD TO
INCENTIVIZE. BETTER
PREPAREDNESS BETTER RESILIENCE
YEAH- YOU KNOW THOSE DOLLARS
ARE AVAILABLE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF. SO MUCH THAT HAS
HAPPENED HERE WE WANT TO
LEVERAGE THOSE DOLLARS TO THE
MAXIMUM BENEFITS TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES. AGAINST WILDFIRES
AND OTHER THREATS THESE ARE
THESE ARE ALL HAZARDS. PROGRAMS
AND WE CAN'T LOSE SIGHT OF.
OTHER THINGS AS WELL THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR PROTECTION AS OF
OUR POPULATION INCLUDING. FLOOD
RISK AS WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER. AND VERY IMPORTANTLY
EARTHQUAKE REST SO THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE AB. AND RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE. FOR
IMPROVEMENTS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I APPRECIATE THAT AND ONE OF
THE ARMS WILL FOLLOW UP WITH-
WITH THE SOUND OF ALL AND
REALLY APPRECIATE HIS WORK RATE
YOU THANK YOU- IS AN ISSUE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IN REGARDS TO
THE FUNDS OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
JUST NOT ENOUGH RIGHT. TO BE
ABLE TO DO BEFORE THAT'S WHY I
WANTED TO GET YOUR YOUR TAKE
ON- UPDATING STANDARDS
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE UPDATED
BUILDING CODES. BUT LOOKING AT
UPDATING POTENTIAL STANDARDS
FOR DEVELOPMENT SPECIALLY IN
THOSE HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES IT SENATE BILL TWENTY TWO
WHICH IS JACKSON'S BILL. WOULD
HAVE. PUT A PAUSE ON THAT KNOW
THAT THERE ARE CONCERNS IN
REGARDS TO THE RENEWED CYCLE ON
HOW THAT WOULD HAVE MESSED UP.
THIS UPCOMING RENEWAL CYCLE AT
THE SAME TIME THOUGH. WE
CONTINUE TO BUILD IN AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN HIT BY WHILE THEM
FIRE. TWO THREE TIMES- AND- IT
IS IT IS IT TIME FOR THE STATE
TO START. IMPLEMENTING A
PROGRAM VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE'VE DONE WITH FLOODING WHERE-
AND IT'S A SENIOR PROGRAMMER WE
BUY OUT THOSE BUILDING RIGHTS.
COMPENSATE THOSE. FOLKS WHO ARE
IN A FLOOD ZONE SO THAT WE
DON'T CONTINUE TO SEE THOSE
INSURANCE LOSSES AND THE PUBLIC
PICKING UP THE TIME TO BE ABLE
TO REBUILD. SO I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE GETTING TO THAT
POINT IN THE STATE ESPECIALLY
AFTER A SEASON THAT WE SEEM TO
FOUR MILLION ACRES I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE CRITICAL DISCUSSION
OF THE LEGISLATURE IS GONNA
HAVE TO HAVE CONTROVERSIAL ONE
TOUGH ONE BUT- ONE THAT I THINK
IT'S GONNA TO HIT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND MAY TAKE UP SO MUCH
TIME MAKING THEM TO BE DIRECTOR
THINKING AFTER. THANK YOU
CENTER- WE HAVE. FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY AND THEN AFTER
THAT- I HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ IN THE QUEUE. WELL
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND I'LL JUST
BE REAL QUICK I HAVE ONE VERY-
IMPORTANT QUESTION TO ME AND I
THINK IT'S ONE OF OUR MORE-
VULNERABLE PARTS OF OUR
POPULATION IS SO EASILY
OVERLOOKED OR PEOPLE THAT HAVE
COMMUNICATION. A DISABILITIES
DO DO WE HAVE ANY SYSTEM IN
PLACE THAT HELPS US IDENTIFY-
WHERE SOME OF THESE PEOPLE MAY
BE RESIDING OR ANY KIND OF A-
SPECIAL WAY TO COMMUNICATE I'M
I'M SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO
VISUALLY IMPAIRED PEOPLE AND
ALSO- HEARING IMPAIRED PEOPLE.
OF THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
ALWAYS FOLLOW THE SAME PATH OF
COMMUNICATION THAT MANY OF US
WHO DON'T SHARE THOSE THOSE
CHALLENGES HAVE. AND I THINK
THEY'VE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS SOME
OF THE TRAGEDIES IN THE PAST
AND HELD THAT THERE WAS REALLY
NO RECOGNITION OR- SPECIAL
PATHWAY TO. REACH OUT AND
IDENTIFY AND I KNOW THAT THIS
WOULD REQUIRE EXTRA COOPERATION
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT I DO
THINK THAT IT IT GETS UNDER
EMPHASIZED I'VE WONDERED. YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. ISSUE WE-
JUST TO KIND OF TRY TO MAKE
ASSISTING TO RESPONSE THE BUT
IT BUT IMPORTANT- TO TALK ABOUT
IS WE DO HAVE AN OFFICE OF
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
HERE AT CALLOW YES FOR THE VERY
PURPOSE. OF ENSURING THAT ARE
PLANNING A RESPONSE OR RECOVERY
IS ALL DONE IN SUCH A WAY. THAT
RECOGNIZING OF THE DIVERSE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA
PARTICULAR THOSE WITH ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS AND THAT
IS- YOU KNOW THEY'RE REALLY
IMPAIRED HEARING IMPAIRED
ELDERLY. YOU KNOW ANYONE THAT-
THAT REQUIRES AND THAT KIND OF
A IT IS A RECOGNITION AND IN
THE PLANNING AND HOW AND HOW WE
DELIVER SERVICES. THE ISSUE OUT
OF IDENTIFYING LOCATION YOU
KNOW REGISTRIES IS A TERM. THAT
CAN BE TRICKY- IT IS- IT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW HOW TO
GET INTO THAT YOU SEE ASPECTS
IT'S A CHALLENGE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO MAINTAIN. AND
THINGS LIKE A LESS HOWEVER
HELLO YES HAS DEPLOYED IN FACT
THERE WAS LEGISLATION REQUIRING
US TO DO SO. GUIDANCE ON A
DISASTER REGISTRIES FOR- ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
POPULATIONS OF A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DOES DO IT THEY DO
IT IN SUCH A WAY THAT ENSURES
SECURITY. ENSURES THAT
COMMITMENT TO MAINTAIN AND- YOU
KNOW IT REALLY PROVIDES A
REALISTIC- AT COMMITMENT TO
THOSE POPULATIONS ABOUT WHAT IT
IS THEY NEED TO DO FOR
THEMSELVES BUT ALSO WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES. ARE PREPARED TO DO
FOR THEM- AND THAT YOU KNOW
THAT'S MANY MANY OTHER-
FUNCTIONS OF THAT OFFICE-
ADVANCE TAYLOR FROM OUR STAFF
WHO JUST WORKS TIRELESSLY.
BUTTERY RESPONSES ASTERS IN
PREPARATION IN CALIFORNIA
REALLY HAS MADE TREMENDOUS
STRIDES I'M ONE OF THE- ANOTHER
RECENT AND- LEARNING LEARNING
SPECIFIC- ED IMPROVEMENT IS AID
TRANSLATION- GUIDE WE HAVE
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES IN
CALIFORNIA. IT HAPPENS- SO. IS
ON OUR WEBSITE THE REFERENCE
CAL START OR- WHERE ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION AND BAD INCLUDE IN
THAT. IS A RESOURCE LIBRARY
THAT A LOT OF GOOD. INFORMATION
AND- TO AND INCLUDE. TRANS YOU
KNOW SAYS MASS. AND THEN TRY.
YOU KNOW ALL THESE THINGS TO
HELP COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL. BE
ABLE TO ADD JUST A BAD THOSE
INTO THEIR SYSTEMS AND THEIR
PLANNING- BUT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING UP THE ISSUE. ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS THAT IS A-
CRITICAL AREA. YEAH I COULD
JUST GIVE YOU A QUICK EXAMPLE
OF BEING A PERSON WHO HAS
ACTUALLY HAD TO EVACUATE FROM
THEIR HOME IT WAS EARLY AM.
NOTIFICATION AND THE WAY I WAS
NOTIFIED WAS THE SHARED DRIVE
THROUGH WITH THEIR PA SYSTEMS
AND THEY TELL EVERYBODY IT'S A
MANDATORY. EVACUATION SYSTEM IF
I WAS A DEAF PERSON THERE IS NO
WAY IN THE WORLD I WOULD HAVE
KNOWN THAT THAT WAS HAPPENING.
AND SO THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO BE AWARE
OF. AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
OVERCOME IN SOME WAY. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ WITH A
QUESTION. THANK YOU CHAIR RIVAS
AND THANK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING ALSO A REAL QUICK
QUESTION I KNOW THE BEGINNING
OF THE DISCUSSION WE TALKED
ABOUT COMMUNICATING WITH THE
THAT COMMUNITIES ARE THAT ARE
BE IMPACTED FROM THE FIRES SO-
I KNOW WE TALKED A BIT ABOUT
THE USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA APPS-
THAT FOLKS CAN RELATE TO AND
GET INFORMATION. AND DO WE SEE
MAYBE IN THE NEAR FUTURE OR DO
WE HAVE A TIME LINE WHEN WE MAY
LOOK AT A TYPE OF- WARNING
SYSTEM FOR FIRES LIKE WE DO FOR
EARTHQUAKES I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF WAYS WE CAN COMMUNICATE
BUT IT'LL BE NICE TO HAVE SOME
TYPE OF FAMILIAR TOOLS OR APP.
LIKE WE DO WHAT THE EARTHQUAKE
WARNING SYSTEMS AND JUST
CURIOUS IF WE ARE LOOKING AT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT DO WE HAVE
LIKE A YEAR TO YOUR TIMELINE ON
WE WILL SEE IT. W. IMPLEMENTED-
HI THIS IS TINA AND AGAIN IF
CHIEF DEBBIE TOLD ME WANTS TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS ONE TO ONE OF
THAT ONE OF THE RECENT ACTIONS
THAT. TOOK PLACE IS THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A WILDFIRE
INTEGRATION CENTER AND THAT'S
REALLY. THAT BAD AND I WAKE NEW
CONSOLIDATE THERE'S WEATHER
WARNINGS THERE'S YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT ENTITIES LIKE OUR
UTILITIES THAT ARE ALL
PROCESSING. A LOT OF DATA AND A
LOT OF INFORMATION AND THAT.
THE I THINK EVERYONE'S GOAL IS
TO. BE MORE REFINERIES REFINED
AS POSSIBLE ON WILDFIRE THREAT.
WHICH IN TURN CAN. PARLAY INTO
BETTER ALERTS AND WARNINGS
ACROSS THE BOARD SO I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT AND THAT THAT IS
EIGHT. EIGHT SOMETHING THAT'S
UNDER DEVELOPMENT AND IN THE
PROCESS OF STANDING UP IT'S A
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL FIRE. AND
THAT'S MORE- YOU KNOW NOT
SPECIFICALLY WHAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING THAT REALLY TO
IMPROVE. THE WAY THAT WE
COORDINATE AND PROCESS THE
DATA. THAT IS HEN- KIND OF
TRANSLATED INTO. OUR WARNINGS
THAT ARE APPROPRIATE OUT FOR
WILDFIRES YOU KNOW WHETHER
THAT'S A GRADUATION WARNINGS
OR- RED FLAG WARNINGS OF
TERRORIST SO THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU'LL BE SEEING MORE AT
AS WE- AS WE- GO DOWN THE PATH
TO. IMPLEMENT THAT- BUT IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW EVEN MORE AT
TOOLS FOR THE PUBLIC ABSOLUTELY
WE KNOW THERE'S ADVANTAGES TO-
TO SIMPLIFYING THAT AGAINST.
ALL HAZARDS STATE SO WE'RE
ALWAYS MINDFUL OF. YOU KNOW
DOES NOT HAVE A TOO MANY
THINGS- IN AND TRY TO PACKAGE
AS MUCH AS WE CAN AND
CONSOLIDATE AND COORDINATE
WORK. WHERE WHERE IT'S POSSIBLE
IN ORDER TO SIMPLIFY AND
STREAMLINE. THE IT ULTIMATELY
HOW WE RELATE AND AGAIN.
REDUNDANCY YOU KNOW THE
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM. HAS REDUNDANT PATHWAYS
AND THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT-
SHOULD WE- ENTER INTO ANY TYPE
OF NEW. TECHNOLOGY. FOR AWHILE
FOR WORDS. AND THIS IS TOLD ME
OUT I WILL TOUCH ON JUST A
LITTLE BIT THAT- AS GW DIRECTOR
COURAGE WE ARE WORK. IN A- WILL
BRINGING LOT OF DATA ASK THE IN
THE PLACE YOU. EXPEDITE OF THAT
INFORMATION- BOTH TO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS. STATE
PARTNERS AS WELL AS TO THE
PUBLIC THEMSELVES. AND ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES OBVIOUSLY WITH
WILD FIRES EARTHQUAKES AS WE
NEVER KNOW WHERE THAT FIRE IS
GOING TO START. AND SO WILL
CONTINUE TO FOR FOCUSED ON- THE
PREVENTIVE INFORMATION-
FOCUSING ON THE FAR HIGHER
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES- THE
INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN THOSE
AREAS CHANGES WITH IN. A
WEATHER SYSTEMS THAT ARE COMING
IN THE INFORMATION FROM THE
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE TRYING
TO THEIR FIRE WEATHER WATCHES.
THE RED FLAG WARNING AND THEN
THE OUTPUT FROM OUR OWN
PREDICTIVE SERVICES WHERE WE
CAN REALLY FOCUS IN MORE
SPECIFIC ON AN AREA. OF BASED
ON THE INDIVIDUAL FUEL
CONDITIONS WITHIN A GIVEN YEAR-
WHAT HEAT STRESS THEY'VE BEEN
UNDER THE LIFE FEEL MORE
SECURE. AND BEING ABLE TO FOCUS
IN ON SPECIFIC INFORMATION. BUT
NOT. IN MY MIND AT THE MOMENT
DO WE HAVE THE CAPABILITY. OF
FOR A PREVENTIVE MESSAGE AT THE
CIVIC TOOK FROM A POTENTIAL
START. OTHER THAN THE
PREPARATION. IF I START WERE TO
OCCUR. OKAY THANK YOU- I HAVE A
QUESTION- FOR CHIEF BOB TOLD
ME. OF SINCE WE HAVE YOU ON THE
LINE. DO YOU THINK THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ADOPT A
DIFFERENT CLASSIFICATION SYSTEM
FOR FIRES RIGHT NOW RED FLAG
WARNINGS ARE NOT VERY DISTRICT.
DESCRIPTIVE TO THE PUBLIC
SHOULD WE HAVE ADDITIONAL TERMS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
CHAIR AT MY INITIAL INSTINCT IS
THE- IF WE TAKE FOR INSTANCE
THE HURRICANE WARNING SYSTEM
THAT WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH
THAT THE SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN
DEVELOPED OVER DECADES- FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE ON LIKE FIRES
WORKING THERE ARE FAIRLY STATIC
LOW MOVIE PROCESS. WHERE WE'VE
GOT- ABUNDANT NUMBER OF- MODELS
THAT. THAT HAVE OR THAT
HURRICANE A WELL IN IT- I. THE
OF HURT. REPORT EVERTON LAND
MAKES LANDFALL. IN AND RE- HAS
PLENTY OF PREPARATION TIME AND
CASES. IF WE LOOK AT THAT A
WILD. AWHILE ARE VERY DYNAMIC
AND DID THEY CAN CHANGE VERY
QUICKLY BASED ON CHANGES IN
WIND PATTERNS THAT ARE
IMPACTING THE FIRE- MOVEMENTS
ON THE PART THREE THE PUBLIC
YOURSELF GOING FROM A FLAT
GROUND TO A STEEP SLOPE THAT
WILL RADICALLY CHANGE THE
BEHAVIOR OF THAT FIRE- AND WE
ARE YOU SEE CHALLENGES. WITH
THE PUBLIC THEMSELVES ON
UNDERSTANDING EVACUATION
WARNINGS EVACUATION ORDERS FIRE
WEATHER WATCHES- RED FLAG
WARNINGS- ME THAT THE MORE
IMPORTANT WE CAN KEEP THE
SYSTEM. WHERE WE CAN READILY
COMMUNICATE- TO THE PUBLIC
ESPECIALLY WITHOUT CAUSING
INCREASED CONFUSION IS A BATTLE
BETTER MODEL IN MY MIND AT THIS
POINT- WE ARE SEEING ADVANCES
WITH THE- FIRES AND LYFT
INFORMATION AND MODELS THAT ARE
OUT THERE WE'VE MADE. GREAT
PROGRESS WITHIN CAL FIRE WITH
OUR OUR FIRE CAST IN A FIRE
STEMS- PRODUCTS THAT WE'VE
STARTED UTILIZED IN THIS YEAR
WERE BETTER ABLE TO FORECAST. A
MOVEMENT OF A FIRE ONCE IT
STARTS. LET ALLOWS US TO WORK
BETTER WITH THOSE LOW
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT CAN BETTER-
PREDICT AND EMPLOYMENT
EVACUATIONS. NUMBER RIGHT NOW
I'D STILL RECOMMEND WE STAY
WITH WITH THOSE ITEMS THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE FOR WARNING. IN
BATTERY FINALS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- I AM AND MY FINAL IS FOR-
WE ASK. I DO YOU THINK THAT
HEALTH. SHOULD HAVE A STATE
WIDE ALERTING SYSTEM- LIKE THE
STATE OF FLORIDA CURRENTLY DOES
THAT IS CAPABLE OF BACKING UP
LOCAL EMERGENCY ALERTING
SYSTEMS. BUT WE HAVE THAT NOW
AND I PROBABLY FAILED TO
MENTION THE CALLOW YESES AND
ALERTING AUTHORITY AND- IN SOME
CASES- I COUPLE YEARS AGO- I
DON'T KNOW THE EXACT DATE- WE
ACTUALLY DID ISSUE- WIRELESS
EMERGENCY ALERT AND THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA FOR
CRITICAL WEATHER ALL OF IT
POINTED- IN IF WE WERE TO DO
THAT AGAIN THE FUTURE WOULD
POINT. TO LOCAL AUTHORITIES
LOCAL INSTRUCTIONS AND REALLY-
AMPLIFY THAT MESSAGE WHERE
NEEDED BUT THAT THOSE ARE
DECISIONS THAT WE WOULD TALK
THERE IN REAL TIME BUT WE
ABSOLUTELY ARE AVAILABLE AS A
BACK UP WE SEE OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE WARNING CENTER AS- AN-
AMONG THE FRAMEWORK OF THAT OR
THE FACT THAT I HAVE THAT
ALERTING AUTHORITIES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THAT VERY
REASON. THE TALK ABOUT
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING A FEW
TIMES THAT IS A VENTURE THAT
THE STATE TOOK ON- A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT- YOU KNOW I'M LIKE
FIRES THAT ARE UNPREDICTABLE WE
KNOW KIND OF WHERE THAT
EARTHQUAKE RISKS EXIST IN THE
WAY THAT SYSTEM WORKS IT'S A
LITTLE BIT PREDICTABLE IN TERMS
OF. WORD EVER WHERE TO LINE UP
THE CENTER NETWORK OF
ULTIMATELY FEED INTO THOSE INTO
THOSE AND NO NOTICE EVENTS- SO
YOU KNOW WE DEFINITELY SEE
OURSELVES AS A- A PARTNER WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ABSOLUTELY
ABLE TO ACT IN REAL TIME. AND
TO PROVIDE THAT AT THE STATE
LEVEL- FOR A MURDER MORNING AND
SHOULD. SHOULD THE NEED ARISE.
THANK YOU MS CURRIE AND- THIS
CONCLUDE THE FIRST PANEL I
WANNA THING- HELLO YES HELLO
BUYER. DID SOMEONE HAVE A
QUESTION I THOUGHT I HEARD
SOMETHING I'M SORRY SO THANK
YOU FOR TO BUY SO I SORT OF HAD
TO GET UP TO SENATOR DODD- I'M
SORRY SENATOR DODD. OKAY SURE
IT WILL END UP STARTED PROLONG
THIS MEETING. JUST WITH YOU
KNOW I THINK I HAD SOME TOP
TECH COLD. EARLIER AND- I
DIDN'T HEAR THAT MAYBE THE
ANSWER COURTS CENTER REQUIRES
QUESTION I REMAIN VERY VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT. YOUR BATTERY
BACK UP FOR THESE CELL SITES
THAT THEY CAN SOMETHING NOW IN
THE THIRD MAJOR FIRE THAT- HAS
BE SET MY DISTRICT OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS IT IS STILL
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT JUST IS
LOOMING. LARGE I'M WONDERING IF
WE CAN GET SOME HELP FROM- YES
PERHAPS LOOKING AT THE
LEGISLATION THAT STELLAR
MCGUIRE AYE SENATE MCGUIRE
AUTHORED AYE COOPER LAST YEAR.
TO MAYBE HAVE THOSE. THAT DO IT
MORE A- YEAH BABY- EVEN EVEN AS
BY MANNER THAT'S YOU'RE- GET US
TO THE- LAND SOON. THANK YOU
DODD- YEAH CERTAINLY YOU KNOW
WE'RE WELL AWARE WORK WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE CQC- WHICH IS
THE YOU KNOW ENTITY CHARGED
WITH REGULATING UTILITIES AND
IMPLEMENTING THAT PARTICULAR
CHANGE- AND CERTAINLY- I AGREE
REDUNDANCY IS CRITICAL WERE
GRATEFUL- FOR THAT- THAT THAT
THAT TOOL IS IN PLACE. TO
ENSURE DOOR TO GIVE US BETTER
ASSURANCE EVER DONE SEEN WILL
CERTAINLY BE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH CQC ON AVELING UP ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ACTION AND IF
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR DON I
APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING YOU- NEXT
OKAY THANK OF SO THANK YOU
AGAIN TO THIS FIRST- SET OF
PANELISTS FOR JOINING US TODAY
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND YOUR
PRESENTATIONS TO US THANK YOU
HELLO YES IN CAL FIRE OF OUR
NEXT PANEL- IS ON FIRE WE'LL
HEAR FROM DIFFERENT- MEMBERS OF
FIRE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT- OF
YOUR JONES THIS YEAR- BOTH FIRE
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE DONE A
STELLAR JOB. OF FIGHTING THE
FOUR MILLION ACRES OF FIRES IN
KEEPING US SAFE- DURING THE
FIRE SEASON THAT INCLUDED A
PANDEMIC THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE VERY EXCITED TO HAVE
ALL OF YOU HERE TODAY- NEED OF
A MESSAGE FOR EACH ONE OF USED
TO PLEASE TELL YOUR MEMBERS
THAT WERE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THEIR SERVICE ESPECIALLY THIS
YEAR I'M SO NEXT WE WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR. FROM CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS WE HAVE FRANK- REVOLVED
THE FIRE CHIEF OF MAMMOTH LAKES
FIRE DISTRICT AND MICHAEL
MCLAUGHLIN FIRE CHIEF OF.
KONSUM NESS FIRE DEPARTMENT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM YEAH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SENT MONEY
IS MICHAEL. I'M- THAT THE
DISTINCT HONOR OF BEING A
DIRECTOR FOR CAL FIRES AND SO.
AND THE FIRE TEAM FOR MISFIRE
IN IN L. GROW- FIRST I WANT TO
START BY SAYING IT'S BEEN MY
PLEASURE TO TEST FOR COMMITTEE
A NUMBER OF TIMES OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS REGRETTABLY WE'RE
DOING IT FROM A DISTANCE EACH
YEAR BUT IT HAS- I GUESS MANY
NEW NORMS ARE IN OUR LIVES NOW.
I DON'T THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY IT DOES IT DOES
BEING ABLE TO PRESENT AND
DISCUSS SOME OF THE WORK TO BE
DONE IN THE PAST AND LEANING
FORWARD ON A PATH TO HOPEFULLY
BUILD. A STRONGER AND BRIGHTER
FUTURES MOVED FORWARD YOU THE
WORKING TOGETHER WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED A LOT IN RECENT
YEARS THAT MEMBERS OF BOTH
HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR- TOOK A VOTE OF FAITH
IN APPROVED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PRE POSITIONING OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT RESOURCES IN
THE ADVANCE OF- WHETHER OR
OTHER TYPES OF. RED FLAG OR
WILD FIRES OR ANY OTHER
CONDITIONS WERE WE CAN PREDICT
IT IN ADVANCE IT TOOK A COUPLE
YEARS FOR THE PROGRAM TO FULLY
HIT ITS STRIDE BUT I WANT TO
SAY THIS PAST YEAR- WE SAW
REMARKABLE MOVEMENT UP AND DOWN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEING
ABLE TO PLACE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE RESOURCES- BETWEEN.
AREAS THAT THAT WE FELT WE'RE
GOING TO BE IN JEOPARDY AS A
RESULT OF A RED FLAG
CONDITIONS- THEY HAD NOTABLE
IMPACTS ON THE ADDITIONAL
PHASES OF THE INITIAL TACK OF
SOME MAJOR INCIDENTS AND IN
MANY CASES. HELP KEEP AN
INCIDENT TO AN INITIAL ATTACK
INCIDENT AND ONE THAT EVER
REALLY MADE THE NEWS SO THE
GOOD NEWS ON SOME OF THIS IS
THAT THE INCIDENTS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN GREATLY SUCCESSFUL PRE
POSITIONING AREN'T THE ONES.
THAT MAKE THE NEWS BUT- WITH
THAT IT ALSO MAKES A LITTLE
MORE DIFFICULT TO TRACK ANY.
ARTICULATE FOR YOU. ALSO WE'VE
SEEN IN THE PAST AND THE
DISASTER FOR READY HIS. FIRST
NAME FOR SAME PER COMMAND THAT
CALL OF ALL THE- FIRE SERVICE.
UP AND DOWN THE AND CAL WORK
TOGETHER TO HELP DEVELOP. IT'S
A STRATEGIES AND WORK FOR YEARS
TO. IN THE- TO CONTINUE TO GO
ON IS A CENTER IS CONTINUE TO
MOVE. I WANT TO THANK YOU
INCLUDING US IN A- FIRE CHIEF
ASSOCIATION THE RED ALL FIRING
UP AND DOWN THE OF. AND BE ABLE
TO INCLUDE PORN ALSO LONG GUY
PARTNER- THAT YOU KNOW CAL FIRE
AND CAL YEAH R. OR- DUE TO. JOB
BILL IN AND DAY OUT BUT THEY
CANNOT DO A LOT OF THE TIME
REALLY WE'RE TO TRY TO MANAGE.
EMERGENCIES AND DOES. IN REALLY
TAKE A VILLAGE YEAH. VERY FEW
ANY OF TYPES OF ITS OCCUR OR
DIRECTLY IN. A LOCAL GUY
COMMUTER AND MOST MORE TO THAT
KIND OF MOMENTS- TO THE KEY TO
A IS THAT WE MUST BE AT THE
TIME. AND WE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SIT AT THE TABLE. TODAY WELL
WE'VE MADE GREAT. OER THE PAST
COUPLE OF. AS AS WE ABOUT- AS
WE ALSO STAR WITH THE TWO.
EARLY UNDER STILL WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE- NATIONAL
LEVEL THERE'S A NATIONAL
COHESIVE WILDFIRE MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY THAT'S BEEN ADOPTED
EMPLOYED. WELL IT CERTAINLY HAS
SOME AREAS THAT ARE RELEVANT
WITHIN THE SENIOR CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME UNIQUE
PRINCIPLES THAT EXIST. THAT'S A
HARD WORK THE MIX IS DOCUMENTS
MAYBE NOT AS STRONG AS WE WOULD
IDEALLY LIKE BUT CERTAINLY A
GOOD START. MOVING FORWARD. WE
DO THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSIONS
MOST RECENTLY. YOU KNOW AFTER
THE FIRE SEASON IS A BIT TWO
THOUSAND. AND WE CONTINUE TO
BUMP IT UP. THE CHALLENGE WE
RUN INTO IS THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THESE TYPES OF COMMITTEES
DON'T END UP PAYING. BEING
DROPPED INTO A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY TO BE ABLE TO MOVE US
FORWARD. AND WHY IS A STRATEGY
IMPORTANT. FOR FROM INCIDENT
MANAGE FIRST IT DOESN'T MATTER
IF WE'RE RESPOND. TO A NEED. AT
HOME WITH A BROKEN ARM OR A
MASSIVE WILDFIRE ORDER AS WE'RE
CALLING THEM NOW WILL MAKE A
FIRE IN TATING CALIFORNIA. IT
ALL BEGINS WITH THIS DISCOUNT
WISHING A SET OF COMMON- WIDELY
KNOWN OBJECTIVES THEY WERE
WORKING TO TRY TO ACHIEVE TO
MITIGATE THE EMERGENCY. FROM
THOSE OBJECTIVES WE MOVE INTO
PUT IT DEVELOPING STRATEGIES TO
ACCOMPLISH THE OBJECTIVES NOT
BREAKING IT DOWN INTO SPECIFIC
TASKS- JUST BEEN ARE PAIRED IN.
OUR OPINION AND EXPERIENCE AS
WE AS WE'VE DONE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK OVER THIS PAST
FEW OF YEARS FROM.
COMMUNICATIONS AND ALERTING AND
FUEL MANAGEMENT AND- BUT JUST A
TREMENDOUS TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
WORK YOU KNOW THE CHAMPIONSHIP
THAT'S BEEN DONE WITH SENATOR
JACKSON OF THE WORK SHE'S DONE
SENATE MCGUIRE. AND REALLY BOTH
HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
ALL OF THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE- WE'D LIKE TO. PROPOSE AND
PUT ON THE TABLE CONSIDERATION
OF ADOPTING OR HIM. OR
LEGISLATING THAT WE WORK
TOWARDS BUILDING A
COMPREHENSIVE A COHESIVE
OVERARCHING STRATEGY. SO THAT
SOME OF THE CONVERSATIONS ARE
HAVING TODAY WHETHER IT'S WE-SHOULD HAVE ONE COMMUNICATION.
SYSTEM STATEWIDE ORDERED SHOULD
BE TO CENTRALIZED IN THE
COUNTIES OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. WERE THAT
CONVERSATION WOULD BE POINTED
BACK TO YOU ONE OF THE COMMON
OBJECTIVES WHAT IS THE
OBJECTIVE WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE. DOES IT MATTER IF EACH
SYSTEM IN EACH COUNTY IS ON A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM AND CAN'T
NECESSARILY OVERLAP WANTED
EITHER. OR WOULD BE BETTER OFF
HAVING WON STATEWIDE SYSTEM.
SOME OF THE ELEMENTS IN MY
OPINION IN OUR OPINION THAT
NEED TO BE INCLUDED LOOKING AT.
AND KNOW WE MADE SOME STRIDES
IN STARTING WITH SOMEBODY JUST
LIKE XINLAST YEAR MAYBE AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY FOUR. AND
THAT'S MOVING FROM THE HAZARD
BASED OR THE HAZARDS OWN
MODELING TO A RISK BASED
MODELING APPROACH. THIS IS
TAKING. TAKING A PER. OF QUERY
GLOW. IN WHICH- HAZARDS VERY
ARE EXIT. BUT DOESN'T TAKE IN
ACCOUNT ANYTHING BEEN DONE THE
STRUCTURE TO MAKE MEMORIES. TO
BE ABLE TO. A WILDFIRE. IT
DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
ROADWAYS OR THE WITH THE- WHEN
THERE'S NO WAYS IN MORE WAYS
OUT ITS WAY THE- IS CHEN LOW.
IN WALL. IT MAKES SENSE THOUGH
USE THAT. PRO BECAUSE HAZARD
FAIRLY STATIC IT DOESN'T CHANGE
RIDLEY I'M A RISK IS FAR MORE
DYNAMIC SOMEBODY COULD NOT
HIRE. FOLKS TO COME OUT AND
CLEAN THEIR PARCEL OFTEN IT CAN
CHANGE FROM ONE DAY TO THE NEXT
SO CAN BECOME VERY. DYNAMIC BUT
I ALSO BELIEVE IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. WE NEED TO PUT
GREATER EMPHASIS ON THE NUMBER
REASONS OF STRUCTURES WE'VE
MADE GREAT STRIDES WITH THE
WILDFIRE CODE IN THE STATE BUT
THERE'S STILL MORE WORK NEEDS
TO BE DONE IN THIS PARTICULAR
AREA. AS WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE
WITH THE WESTERN FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WILDFIRE POLICY
COMMITTEES IDENTIFIED. TWELVE
VULNERABILITIES THAT EXISTED
ALL STRUCTURES IS THE CONTINUE
TO EXIST. IN THAT WE TALKED
ALSO ABOUT THE- PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
FROM FROM RISK MODELING TO
ACTUARIAL WORK BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS THE I. B. H. S. WHICH IS
THE INSURANCE INSTITUTE FOR
BUSINESS AND HOME SAFETY. WHERE
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IS
EIGHT NEW CHURCH INDUSTRY
ALONE. TESTING LABORATORY WHO
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPING
THE ROOF TIES FOR HURRICANE
PRONE AREAS BECAUSE THEY
IDENTIFIED THAT WANTS A
STRUCTURED LOSES ITS ROOF. THE
STRUCTURE WILL BE BOUND TO
COLLAPSE AS A RESULT OF THE
HEAVY WINDS IN HURRICANE PRONE
AREAS. BUILDING THE ROOF TILES
GREATLY REDUCE THE RISK AND IT
ALSO BILL A BRIDGE BUILD UP THE
RESILIENCE. OF THESE HOMES
YEAH. HOW DO YOU JUST SEND SOME
OF THE WORK WE'VE DONE WITH THE
RESEARCH. HAS OPENED SOME OF
THE STORES BUT WE BELIEVE
THERE'S MORE TO BE DONE TO AND
SOME OF THESE PARTNERSHIPS.
WELL PARTNERINGWITH THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY MAY NOT BE
INTUITIVE ON MANY FRONTS WE
CAN'T DO ONE WITHOUT THE OTHER
BECAUSE EVERY HOME IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS INSURED. SO
HOW DO WE WORK TOGETHER TO
ACHIEVE A COMMON GOAL OF RISK
MANAGEMENT OUR COMMUNITIES. WE
TALKED A LOT OVER THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS OF FORCED HELPING
FUEL MEDICATION BUT REALLY WHAT
IS OUR OVERARCHING STRATEGY
WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
THE UTILITIES THE HARDENING AND
THE RESILIENCE YOU DON'T DO WE
INVEST UP FRONT IT TO
UNDERGROUND ALL UTILITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WOULD
NOT BE AT ALL COMMITTED TO
ACTIVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
WORKING TOWARD SOMETHING THAT I
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT AN AND TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION. WE'VE TALKED A
LOT TODAY ABOUT COMMUNITY READY
TO SET A LEARNING BUT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE. AS SOME OF THIS IS
BEING DECENTRALIZED SOME LOCAL
COMMITTEE. THAT ONLY TO EIGHT
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES THE
STATE OF. ARE CURRENTLY IN. IN
A PROBE IS SET JACK POINTED OUT
CHAU THAT WE HAVE A TO DO. WHAT
IS OUR OVER. OF IN THIS. AREA
AND WE ARE SOME OF THE STRESS.
WE CAN WORK TO MOVING OUR-
FORWARD. AND LASTLY I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGIES ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT IT FROM. THE ALERTING TO
USING SOCIAL MEDIA AND
INFORMING. WELL AS IT STANDS
CURRENTLY EVEN FOR OUR FIRST
RESPONDING ENTITIES RESPONDING
TO SOME OF THESE MEGA FIRES.
THAT OUR FIRST RESPONDERS NEED
TO RELY ON SOCIAL MEDIA BLOGS
TO BE ABLE TO READ RECEIVE WHAT
WE'LL CALL REAL TIME
INTELLIGENCE AS THEY RESPOND TO
THESE INCIDENTS BECAUSE THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE. TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESPONDING. HOW DO WE IMPROVE
UPON THIS HOW DO WE BUILD UPON
THIS. I WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSE.
THAT WE YOU KNOW AS WE MOVE FOR
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO CREATE A
CALIFORNIA COMPREHENSIVE A
COHESIVE. WILDFIRE STRATEGY.
BAG OUR VENTURE TO SAY THAT WE
COULD EVEN GO BEYOND CALLING
THIS A WILDFIRE STRATEGY AND
PRODDED INTO AN ALL HAZARD ALL
RISK APPROACH. BECAUSE FRANKLY
THE WAY WE MANAGE THESE
INCIDENTS IN THE STATE. WE
WE'VE BEEN A LEADER FOR DECADES
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME A LEADER
ONCE AGAIN. AND. CHAMPION AND
MOVE FORWARD. WE ALSO LIKE. I
GUESS FOR. TO THE COMMITTEE IN
A- OF THIS YEAR AND BECAUSE-
FIRE CHIEFS. PRESENT EVER UP.
SUBMITTED A LOT TO COMMIT.
REQUESTING SEVENTEEN MILLION.
IN TO HELP MAKE SURE THE
TECHNOLOGY WAS IN PLACE TO HELP
US TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THE
WORK THAT NEEDED TO BE DONE.
FIRST AND FOREMOST WAS MAKING
SURE THAT EVERY PIECE OF FIRE
APPARATUS IN STEVIE CALIFORNIA
HAD BACKED UP REALLY TO BE
TRACKED THROUGH AUTOMATIC
VEHICLE LOCATING DEVICES- THIS
INVESTMENT. WAS PART OF THE
DEAREST PROPOSAL IT WAS PART OF
THAT THE- THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. ASSOCIATED FOR. PRE
POSITIONING IN MONEY THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY SET. ASIDE FOR
INVESTING IN TECHNOLOGY. WE
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO. THAT YEAH.
FOR CONSIDER. IT IS IT'S- THE
PRE POSITION REQUEST FROM JUST
FIRE AGENTS TO HELPING US TO UP
STAFF THE NEXT DEBT EXPANDED
STATURE CAPABILITIES AND PRE
POSITIONED DISPATCHERS IN AREAS
THAT WE EXPECT TO BE HERE. S.
NINE ONE ONE CALLS MOVED TO OUR
PEACE ABSENT SECONDARY P. SAPS
AND MAKING SURE THAT NO CENTERS
HAVE THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
HANDLE. WHAT WE PROJECT TO BE
INCREASED CALL VOLUME. NEXT
WHILE THE STATE IS ADOPTED AND
IT AKA DOCTOR REDUCE MOVING IN.
THE FIRST THAT PLATFORM THEY
WILL PER. YEAH CLICK SAFETY
NETWORK IT GIVES- PUBLIC C.
REESE PREEMPTORY ACCESS WHEN
WILL NOT BE CA WITH THE
CONSUMER SELLER NET- DIPLOMA OF
IS SLOW AND- SB CHALLENGE
MOSCOW IS ONE OF THE LAST WEEK
SO I DIDN'T YEAH WE DID YEAH TO
IS ALL VINCE TO MOVE FOR BUT WE
ALSO HAVE A MASSIVE STATE
INSURANCE FOR SOME FISH SERVICE
TO BE TO MOVE FORWARD CAN GROW
AND HELL. COMMUNICATION BUT
MANY THESE COMING THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT BEING TO PUSH FROM
OUT TO RESPONSE. THANK YES
MAINTENANCE- EXIST FOR CAN TO
WHETHER IT'S A FIRST NAME
HELPING TO MANAGE PRE
POSITIONING OF DISPATCH AMONG
OTHERS RECKON THAT CAN MANAGED
MADE WILL REQUIRE IT RE AS WELL
THESE LOCAL
WELL THERE'S A TON OF GREAT
WORK HE CONTINUES TO MOVE ON-
I'M JUST SO VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY I'M SO
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE SUPPORT
THAT YOU'VE SHOWN IN RECENT
YEARS AND I'M SURPRISED BE.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU CHIEF.
I DO WE HAVE A FREE- FREE WALL
FROM. FIRE CHIEF FOR MAMMOTH
LAKES. YES MANAGER OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR LETTING US
COME BEFORE YOU TODAY- MY NAME
IS FRANK FREE MULTI IN THE
FIRST YEAR YOU FROM M. S. LIKES
FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT AND
I'M HERE REPRESENTING- A
CALIFORNIA THIRTY CESSATION.
MADAM CHAIR VICE CHAIR MCGUIRE.
D. ONE OF THE OVER ARCHING
THINGS THAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT WITH. IS
LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT YEAH WELL
I'M GONNA CALL THE
IMPLEMENTATION LEVEL OF POLICY
INFORMATION. M. AS WAS WAS-
MENTIONED- SENATE JACKSON-
ANECHOIC SENATOR DODD. WE WE'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY AND
FORTUNATELY MOST OF US TO BE IN
A POSITION WHERE WE HAD TO BE
EVACUATED BECOMES VERY PERSONAL
IT'S VERY LOCAL. AND WE
UNDERSTAND FIRSTHAND AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL- OPPORTUNITIES-
WHAT COMMUNITIES HAVE A NEW.
YOUR DEGREE SIMILAR. IN
BEHAVIOR WELL WE ALL KNOW THE
THAT THEY DO HAVE- LOCAL I.
STRING AND WEAKNESSES- AND SO
AS WE'RE LOOKING. AT AT MERGING
SEE MANAGEMENT POLICY AND- NEW
DIRECTIONS OUT WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND LOOKING FOR
CONTINUED SUPPORT TO INCLUDE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND- REALLY
ANY I'M A CURRENT YEAR- C.
LEVEL EVENT. THEY GENERALLY
START LOCALLY AND THEY
GENERALLY AND LOCALLY. AN
EXPANDED- AS A- CO AUTHOR
MENTIONED DEPENDING ON HOW
QUICKLY WE CAN GET TO A
RESPONSE AND- MINIMIZE THINGS-
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH HOW LARGE
THEY GROW. BUT THE TYPICALLY
SHARP LOCAL MONEY TYPICALLY AND
LOCAL INS WERE SORT OF THAT TOP
FIRST AND LAST MILE IF YOU WILL
DELIVERY OVERSEE MANAGEMENT. I
CAN JUST GIVE YOU A COUPLE.
EXAMPLES ARE READY FOR SOME
FORTUNE THE TRANSPLANT EMIC-
NEARLY ALL COUNTIES ALL CITIES
CURRENTLY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EITHER HAVE DIRECTLY
ACTIVATED EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER ARE THERE PARTICIPATING
IN A- JOINT MERCY OPERATIONS
CENTER. I KNOW CENTERS ARE
ISSUING- DAILY SOMETIMES
MULTIPLE TIMES A DAY- WHAT WE'D
CALL- TWO NINE A SITUATION
REPORT AND THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER. AND HELPS PROVIDE AN
AMAZING LEVEL OF SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO
TURN US TO MAKE- THIS AT THE
STATE LEVEL ABOUT PRIORITIZING.
AND WHERE WE WHERE WE SPREAD
OUT THE SCARCE RESOURCES. IN
THE STATE AND WHAT THE LOCAL
SITUATION AS- AND FOR US TO DO
THAT EFFECTIVELY- THIS IS WHERE
YOU KNOW THAT IS. OFTEN
MENTIONED- CALORIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN GREAT
PARTNERS- HAVE BEEN WILL
CONTINUE TO BE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. COM NO I WOULD
REFERENCE THE UC CREDENTIALING
WHICH IS A RELATIVELY NEW THE
CALLOW YES. BUT IT'S TRAINING
ON MY COUNTIES TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF AND WE ARE REAPING THE
BENEFITS CARLY. THEY WERE ABLE
TO COME ON SITE. TO OUR COUNTY
IT'S REMOTE. IT'S A LOT EASIER
TO BRING THAT TRAINING AND
DRILLS TEAR LOCALIZE SETTING
THAT IS TO DO IT SO. YOU KNOW
TO DO IT NECESSARILY DISTANCE
YOU'RE SENDING YOUR PEOPLE OFF.
NOT AS A TEAM IN A COHORT THE
BILL THAT THEY DON'T GET A BILL
THAT SEARCHING MARC WE NEED SO
MUCH NOW. I'M ANOTHER EXAMPLE-
THERE WITH. IS THAT- IF YOU
LOOK ACROSS AND WE YOU KNOW WE
ALL GO TO THE STATE WEBSITE FOR
INFORMATION ON KOBE NINETEEN
IT'S- IT'S AMAZING COURT GET
INFORMATION. YOU'LL IT NEARLY
COUNT- AND A LOT OF CITIES THE
LARGER. HAVE THE- A LOOK. WE'RE
LOOKING NATION IT'S BECAUSE-
I'M WE TO LOOK LEVEL TO BEST A
SIMILAR CAN. OUT TO ESSENTIALLY
ARE SAID- THE SENATOR. IN. YOU
KNOW WE UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW
SPECIAL POPULAR ARE OR SPECIAL
COMMUNICATE. OR IN SOME OF THE
BILL TO- STAKING ME COMMUTER.
ARMS TO STAY CONNECTED THROUGH
COMMITTEE WITH OUR COMMUNITIES
WAYS THAT FAMILIAR WITH-
FAMILIAR WEBSITES IF THEY MAKE
TO A WEEKLY BASIS IT BASIS. SO
FIRST REAL TO OPEN A THOSE
INCOME OR- ESPECIALLY THE BACK
YOU WISH. YOU KNOW OUR TO MEET
AS WITH MANY THIS YEAR HAD TO
AT ABOUT TO- THAT WAS TO MEET
ANY COVERT. WE WERE ABLE USE
THE SAME. THAT WE WERE MAN THE
APP AND DEMOCRATS TO. GIVE
PEOPLE MONEY AWARENESS AND
DIRECTION IN THE ABOUT THAT WE
HAD TO THANK GOODNESS WE DIDN'T.
ANOTHER PART OF A COUNTY WITH
HAVE TO BACK TO RAPID- HOMES
WHAT AND FOR PEOPLE. SURE I
REALLY WANT THAT WHILE. IT'S HE
STATE AND WE'VE WE'VE PAN ON.
ON SO- CAL YES- IN CALIFORNIA.
AS HAS HUGE FOR MULTIPLIERS FOR
A- THE TYPE INTEL THAT I'VE
BEEN FROM DAY- FIRE SEASON- YOU
HIS VERY VERY HOT FOR US. I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE AS WE GO
THESE THINGS- PLEASE TO HAVE A
CERTAIN TABLE POLICY FOR LOW.
BECAUSE A THESE THING. TEND
LOCAL. THE TENDER AND IN LOCAL.
AND WHAT THOUGHT. PUT OUT IS
THAT- RIGHT. NOW THE FIRST FOR
NELSON SEVENTY NINE AND A COME
TO REAL THAT IT'S GONNA TAKE
FOR THINGS US TO AND- CHANGE.
AN OUTCOME OF ANY OF. AND WELL
FOR TAKE THE TENT RIGHT NOW-
WEEKS SO. THE GEOGRAPHY
CALIFORNIA GUARANTEED ORGANIZE.
A NEED ALL RESPONSE ON FOREVER
IN A FEW- IT'S WHETHER IT'S YOU
KNOW HUNDRED WHILE FLOODS
MONTHS- CATION TOO MUCH SNOW
HERE ON FLOODING. WE HAVE TO BE
READY FOR ALL THE FOR ALL OF
THOSE. IT WILL TAKE FORCING FOR
US INTENT PROVE THE OF AN
EMERGENCY IT'S GOING TO TAKE
ENOUGH FIRST- AT POINT. THE
ANSWER WE'RE GONNA NEED RIGHT.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED EITHER A
TRAINING. AND WE ABSOLUTELY
ALWAYS THAT WAY TIME OTHERS.
IT'S BEEN MY EXPERIENCE YOU
TAKE AWAY ANYONE THOSE FOR. YOU
REALLY DRASTIC LEISURE BILLION
CHANGE OUTCOMES WILL WILL SPEND
THE TIME AND EFFORT THE LEFT
THE OTHER THREE WILL LOSE THE-
TO CHANGE OUTCOMES M. IN TERMS
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. LOCAL
FIRE SERVICES THE CITY COUNTY
SPECIAL DISTRICT LEVEL. FROM
WORK TO SPEEDING HEAVILY
NUMBERS YOU MANAGEMENT. ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT SORT OF AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE FROM
WILD FOR MANAGEMENT IS
SEARCHING COUGHLIN MENTIONED. I
IF YOU TOOK A POLL YOU FIND AT
A SURPRISING NUMBER OF THE-
VERSUS OPERATIONS CENTERS. HOW
FAR PERSONNEL AND KEY POSITIONS
LIKE- PLANNING AND LOGISTICS
BECAUSE THE EXERCISE THOSE VERY
SPECIALIZED AND VERY PERSONABLE
SKILLS ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
WELFARE MANAGEMENT. AND THEY'RE
PROVING EXTRAORDINARILY
EFFECTIVE NOW- DURING A
PANDEMIC WERE TRYING TO PUSH
OUT. MILLIONS OF MASKS HAND
SANITIZER OTHER PPP- SUPPORT TO
OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS THE PEOPLE
IN QUARANTINE AT SETRA. AND SO-
I'LL JUST CLOSE HERE- I KNOW
WE'LL GET A LOT OF GROUND TO
COVER- PLEASE KEEP. YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT WHICH WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE. PLEASE KEEP
US INVOLVED AT THE TIME TO CALL
THE IMPLEMENTATION LEVEL
INCLUSION. FOR EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT POLICY FORMATION.
WE'RE ALL THE CURRENT LOCAL AND
LOCAL THANK YOU MANAGER AND
I'LL BE GLAD ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS I CAN. THANK CHIEF
I'M NEXT. THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE TOM WELCH DEPUTY FIRE
CHIEF OF THE SUB SOUTHERN MARIN
FIRE DISTRICT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS YOU SENATORS I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY A
PRIVILEGE TO SPEAK TO YOU ON
BEHALF. OF THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AFTER
WE APPRECIATE BEING A PART OF
THIS IMPORTANT AND ESSENTIAL
CONVERSATION. MY NAME IS TOM
WATER SERVICES DEPUTY CHIEF OF
OPERATIONS A TRANSIT SOUTHERN
PROTECTION DISTRICT IN THE MILL
VALLEY FIRE DEPARTMENT. WE'RE
LOOKING IN THE SOUTHERN PORT OF
CENTER. DISTRICT TODAY I AM
PROVIDING A LOCAL. THE BEST
PRACTICE IS CURRENTLY UNDERWAY
IN PROPOSED LEARNING IN TIME
FINALLY MAKE IT MASS DIFFERENCE
IN OUR SUCCESSES AND FAILURES
REGARDING COMMUNITY. I ALSO-
INTENDED ON LOCAL ISSUES
SURROUNDING ALERTS WARNINGS AND
EVACUATIONS THREE BASIC
ARCHITECTS. WAS BACK IT'S
INCLUDES EDUCATION OUTREACH
MITIGATION EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AND EDUCATION. BUT FIRST I MUST
BRIEFLY EXPLAIN THE FIVE PHASES
EVACUATION FOR HOLISTIC CONTEXT
WITH A FINER POINT OF FOCUS SO
WHEN WE SEEK TO REFORM
EVACUATION CONCEPTS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
PHASES OF THE OCCUPATION ARE WE
ARE STREAMLINING. I'M USING A
PRACTICAL NARRATIVE TO MAKE A
POINT MRS SMITH CALLS NINE ONE
ONE. OR THE FIRE ON THE HILL IN
YOUR BACKYARD. SHE IS A
PROVIDED IMMEDIATE INSTRUCTIONS
FROM THE DISPATCHER I TO TAKE
PROTECTIVE ACTIONS SO THE FIRST
PHASE INCIDENT DETECTION AND
RESPONSE CHRIS. ARE THESE DAYS
I CAN WORK QUITE WELL IN THE
SUBURBAN OR URBAN AREAS WHERE
WE HAVE AN INTERCONNECTED.
THREE AND A QUICK NOTIFICATION
CAN HAPPEN BUT IN THE RURAL
AREAS THIS CAN BE MORE
CHALLENGING. BUT WE PLACE
STRATEGIC CAMERAS CALIFORNIA.
I'M WEATHER STATIONS OUT IN THE
AREA TO HOW US. WITH IDEA.
PROJECT I DECISION TIME SO
FIRST OFF RESP UNDER WAY.
ORANGE WILL LOSE YOUR THINGS OF
THAT SO. SHINS AND THE EXTENT
OF POSSIBLE CONDITIONS THE
FUTURE BASED ON WHETHER YOU
WANT TO POVERTY. AT THIS TIME
TO MAKE A DECISION ON WHO IS AT
RISK AND- WHO NEEDS TO BE
NOTIFIED FIRST THIS USUALLY
HAPPENS WITH ALI BOB COURSE. IN
FIRE DEPARTMENT PARTNERSHIP
KNOWN AS UNIFIED COMMAND IT
TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO
MAKE THIS DECISION UNDERSTAND
SO. THE WARNING TIME PHASE
INFORMATION IS PASSED OFF TO
OUR DISPATCHERS ARE OFFICE
WORKS YOU SERVICES- WHERE THEY
DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE
NOTIFICATION LEVEL PLATFORM
NECESSARY WILL USE NEXT ALL
VERSES REVERSE NINE ONE ONE
VERSES WE AT. VERSES THE
EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM TO MAKE
THE NOTIFICATION. OF THIS TAKES
A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO
UNDERSTAND MINUTES AND SECONDS
AND TO GET THAT INFORMATION OUT.
ON THE NEXT PHASE IS OPERATION
TIME FACE THIS IS ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY IS THE COMMUNITY
READY TO GO. PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES TAKEN THE TIME TO
COMMUNICATE RISKS AND
EXPECTATIONS THE COMMUNITY YOU
HAVE A PLAN THEY UNDERSTAND THE
PLAN TO DO STAND THEIR ROLE. IN
THE PLAN. ARE YOU CAN DO
EVERYTHING RIGHT IN INCIDENTS
JACKSON DECISION TIME WARNING
TIME. BUT IF THE COMMUNITY IS
NOT PREPARED TO GO YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE CHALLENGES. FINALLY IS
NETWORK CLEARING TIME HOW LONG
DOES IT TAKE TO CLEAR UP A
PARTICULAR NEIGHBORHOOD. OR
PARTICULAR AREA GENERALLY THIS
IS THE RANGE. THERE'S A MILLION
WAYS TO FELLOW DOCUMENTATION. I
WHETHER IT'S. A CAR CRASH OR-
ALL ON BOARD FALLING ACROSS
YOUR- AND SO ON. THE RANGER OF
TIME. IS THE SAME. IF YOU ARE
IN ALL OF FACE ARE WHICH ALL
COULD YOU SOME. SOME FOR. ON
THIS IS YOUR EVACUATION TIME
AND- IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
COMMUNITIES TO UNDERSTAND AT
LEAST HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING. SO WE'RE
FOCUSED ON AREAS THAT ENHANCE
AND STREAMLINE EACH PHASE OF
THE EVACUATION OF THE SPEECH
FROM. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PERSPECTIVE HERE ON THE FIRST
MARKET THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT
COMMUNITY EDUCATION NOT REACH
RELATING TO THAT QUESTIONS. I
JUST SAID WE STRUGGLE TO REACH
ALL POPULATION SEGMENTS THREE
MULTI MODAL APPROACH USING
TECHNOLOGY AND LAST SECOND
TECHNOLOGICAL METHODS. IF WE
COULD IMPROVE THIS WE WOULD
FACILITATE COMMUNITY PROPER
TAXES. SO THE QUESTION IS DOES
THE COMMUNITY IT DOES THE
COMMUNITY KERR IS THE COMMUNITY
SIGNED UP FOR ALERTS WARNINGS
DO THEY UNDERSTAND THE RISKS
COMPLAINING RESPONSIBILITIES
DURING EVACUATION. I BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE ONLY PENETRATING
APPROXIMATELY 25% ALTHOUGH WHEN
THERE SEEMS TO BE SMOKE IN THE
AIR WE PENETRATE. FAR MORE.
PRINT OUT PREVENTATIVE
COMMUNICATIONS BEFORE
EVACUATION ASCENTIAL CANNOT
UNDERESTIMATE THE VALUE OF
STRUCTURAL HARDENING THAT
STATION MANAGEMENT. RAN THROUGH
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS WOULD
FACILITATE COMMUNITY PRACTICES
AND OUR CURRENT. IF THE
STRUCTURES ARE BURNING IT IS
AND- DEFINITE EXPERIENCE
EVACUATING IN THE MIDST OF A
FIRE I WHEN THEY ARE BURNING IT
IS A FAR MORE DANGEROUS. WE
FUNDING TO ASSIST WITH
EDUCATION AND CAN ACTUALLY AND-
OUR COMMUNITY EVACUATION PLANS
SUCH AS MAILERS APPS AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES THIS FACILITATES
COMMUNITY PROPER NETWORKS
DURING PHASES IN THE SOUTHERN
NEVADA AREA WE'VE IDENTIFIED
MALE SWITCHED TO DISTRACTIONS
ANYMORE. ENGINE FIVE THE
PRIMARY AND SECONDARY
EVACUATION ROUTES FOR EACH
REGION OF OUR COMMUNITY WE'VE
IDENTIFIED COMMUNITY RUSSIAN
JOURNALISTS WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO
AS AN AREA OF LAST RESORT AND-
HUNKER DOWN UNTIL THE SITUATION
IMPROVES AND- I'LL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TELLS THEM THAT
SAFETY LEADS. WE ALSO BELIEVE
IN INTER CONNECTING OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS TO ENHANCE THE
SURVIVABILITY ALL RESIDENTS
CONDUCTING COMMUNITY EVACUATION
DRILLS FORMING NEIGHBORHOOD
RESPONSE GROUPS IF YOU DON'T
PRACTICE I MIGHT NOT BE
SUCCESSFUL ON GAME DAY. THESE
ACTIVITIES FACILITATE THE
WARNING TIME THE SOLDIER
COMMUNITY PREPARATION FAST AND
NETWORK CLEARING TIME CASES
THEY MAKE EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
OUR HAVE. EVERYBODY UNDERSTAND
SLAP. NEXT MITIGATION. WHEN
FOCUS ON FUEL REDUCTION THIS
ARE. ACTION WORKS LOOSEN THIS
OUT TO FIVE SO NETWORK CLEARING
A RISK AND AS WELL AS I DID IT.
DETECTION TIME PHASES SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WE'RE REDUCING
FUELS ALONG PRIMARY AND
SECONDARY EVACUATION ROUTES
THIS REDUCES THE INTENSITY OF
FIRE AS RESIDENTS ARE MAKING
THEIR WAY OUT WE'RE REDUCING
FUELS AROUND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE RESIDENTIAL
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS WE ARE
CHASING STRATEGIC FUEL RACKS
THAT SERVICE AFTER THE FDA FOR
SUPPRESSION EFFORTS WHAT CAN I
JUST COMMUNITY FACILITIES AT
OTHER TIMES HIKING TRAILS
BIKING TRAILS. THAT THE
MITIGATION ON TAX THIS ONE.
MEMBERS RESPONSE IN THE WE NEED
FIND TO LIVE REAL. DATA
HELLFIRE COMMUNICATIONS MAPPING
SUCH AS WAZE WILL NOT ANOTHER
SO AFRAID ARE NETWORK LEARNING-
UNDER. WE NEED TO BUILD OUT. TO
PROVIDE FOR AUTOMATIC VEHICLE
LOCATION OUR FIRE ENGINES
POLICE CARS SYSTEMS FOR
IMPROVED BETTER ORGANIZED
RESPONSE IS ENHANCES OUR
INCIDENT DETECTION RESPONSE
UNDERSTANDING. WE NEED FUNDING
FOR UP STAFFING AND PRE
POSITIONING OUR DISPATCHERS
DURING HIGH FIRE DANGER PERIOD
DISTANT HOUSES INCIDENT
DETECTION RESPONSE SPACE. OTHER
EVACUATION TECHNOLOGIES
UTILIZED IN NEED A CURRENTLY IN
THE SOUTHERN. OUR USED THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE LONG RANGE
ACOUSTICAL DEVICE BY GENESIS
CORPORATION THIS IS AN OUTDOOR
LEARNING SYSTEM THAT ADDS
REDUNDANCY TO OUR OUR AREA
PROVIDES REAL TIME
INSTRUCTIONS. CREATED SO THAT.
WORKS WITH A SATELLITE DOWNLINK
AND BATTERY BACKUPS FOR
RESILIENCE YOUR JUDGMENTS. WE
WORKING THROUGH PROGRAM OF THE
NEW RADIO LOOKS- THIS SYSTEM IS
TEMPORARILY- IS USED IN TORNADO
ALLEY IN HURRICANE AREAS
THROUGHOUT AMERICA WE'RE TRYING
TO SEE IF IT WORKS FOR US DOWN
HERE. WE ARE DOING AND NEED
FUNDING FOR EVACUATION MODELING
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND TRAFFIC
CHOKEPOINTS OPPORTUNITIES AFTER
CONTRAFLOW ANOTHER TRAFFIC
MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES TO
CONSIDER HUMAN BEHAVIOR ARE
UNDER STRESS THIS WILL STRESS
WITH OUR NETWORK CLEARING TIME
UNDERSTAND. SO GOALS FOR
SYSTEMS AS YOU CONSIDER POLICY
DEVELOP LEGISLATION FINALIZE
BUDGETS ARE WE ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING BUILD
SYSTEMS THAT OFFER REDUNDANCY
EDUCATION COMMUNICATION
RESPONSIBLE PERSON OF CATIA.
BUILDER ONE RULES RESILIENT
SYSTEMS FOR ALL RISKS NO SIMPLE
SYSTEMS THAT WORK FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND OVERSEE RESPOND
OR SPEAK. LET'S THEIR SCALABLE
USABLE. AT THE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL LEVEL BILL SYSTEMS FOR
INTER OPERABILITY STUDENT.
THANKS FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY TO OFFER A LITTLE
PERSPECTIVE ON ISSUES ENSURE
WHAT YOU SHARE WITH YOU WHAT WE
ARE UP TO. I REGARDING ALERTS
WARNINGS AND EVACUATIONS AND
ALL STAMPED WITH MY PEERS IN
THE PAST IT'S- THANK YOU I'M
NEXT WE HAVE BRIAN RICE-
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
MANAGER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
INTO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME SPREAD RIGHT AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. I
SPENT MY FIRE SERVICE CAREER IT
IS SACRAMENTO METROPOLITAN FIRE
DEPARTMENT IN AND SOMEWHAT
UNIQUE TO LABOR BECAUSE I
RETIRED OUT IN MANAGEMENT
POSITION AS A DEPUTY CHIEF OF
OPERATIONS. AND I'M GONNA TOUCH
ON A COUPLE OF BULLETS THAT I
WAS ASKED. YOU KNOW TO BE
PREPARED FOR AND- I'M IN WOULD
BE THE LAST FIRE SEASON UNDER
MUTUAL AID INCIDENTS- AND HOW
KOBE- INTERACTED OR DIDN'T
INTERACT WITH SOME OF OUR MAJOR
RESPONSES AND I CAN SAY THAT
INITIALLY- AS WE WATCHED IN
CALIFORNIA PUT- AND- YES PUT A
NUMBER. OF SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE
FROM THE BASIC HYGIENE RULES
THAT WE ALL FOLLOW AND I THINK
A COUPLE THINGS HAPPEN IN OUR
FAVOR THAT- WE FOLLOWED A
HYGIENE PROTOCOLS AND WE GOT
LUCKY- THAT- COULD REALLY
DIDN'T PAY- BIG PART. IN THE
MUTUALLY CRISP AND THAT A VERY
THING. AND I KNOW THIS BILL ASK
CAL OR TO- REFER- WHAT WE BEEN
DOING IT WHAT WE DO. AND NOW
WILL DO RESULTS. I DO WANT TO
COME BACK TO THE COLD MAKE
PEACE AS I WRAP UP- SOME OF THE
OTHER DISCUSSION THAT I WAS
ASKED TO COMMENT ON WOULD WOULD
BE A NEW SYSTEM THAT
CATEGORIZES FIRED- FIRES BY
DANGER OR BY EXPOSURE. IN CHIEF
CURRY. WAS EXACTLY RIGHT ON
POINT WITH THE NEW ORDERS THE
EVACUATION ORDER EVACUATION.
WARNING AND THE SHELTER IN
PLACE- AND I WAS REALLY
THINKING ABOUT THIS AND- CHIEF
MCLAUGHLIN- THREE VOTES
EVERYBODY KIND OF TOUCHED ON
IT. AND IS THERE A WAY TO K. A
WILDFIRE IN THE DANGER THE
COMMUNITY THAT THE COMMUNITY-
WHAT HE DID. AND UNDERSTAND IT
AND ACT APPROPRIATELY. I THINK
THAT THERE IS I DON'T THINK
THAT- IT'S GOING TO BE- A- AN
INSTANT FIX BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK
AT THE NATIONAL CONVERSATION.
WE'VE BEEN HAVING IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS MOST OF THE
GENERAL PUBLIC NOW IS- IT'S
GEARED TO THAT QUOTE UNQUOTE
THE FAKE NEWS OR THE CONSPIRACY
THEORY SO I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
VERY VERY MEASURED. AND REALLY-
INTERACT WITH THEIR COMMUNITIES
AS WE DEVELOP THAT AND THEN
MAKE IT- THE METRICS ARE
WARNING SYSTEM DAY THAT- ONE
MEMBER OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC A
MEMBER IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
YOU. CAN ACTUALLY APPLY TO
THEMSELVES IT MEANS SOMETHING
AND SIMPLE IS GOING TO BE.
BETTER IN IN THAT. ARENA AND-
JUST GIVE GOING TO BE A ONE
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND FIRE SEASONS
WILL YOU KNOW AND WE'VE HEARD
MAKE A FIRE WE'VE HEARD ALL OF
IT AND THE ONE THING THAT WE
WILL ALL AGREE UPON. IS THAT
WE'RE SEEN FIRE BEHAVIOR NEVER
SEEN BEFORE. AND IT AND WE'VE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
IT BUT COMMUNICATED IN A WAY
THAT THE PUBLICDOES NOT GET
NUMB TO IT AND THAT'S GOING TO
BE THE TRICK TO IT. AND I THINK
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF THAT-
SMART PEOPLE IN IT SHE TOLD ME-
AND I THINK I PUT THIS TWENTY
QUOTES PUBLIC CONFUSION-
THERE'S JUST SOME THINGS THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO PAY ATTENTION
TO IS WE DEVELOP BETTER TO GIVE
THE PUBLIC. REAL TRYING USABLE
INFORMATION BECAUSE WE CAN
ALWAYS GO BACK TO. KNOWLEDGE IS
POWER IF THEY HAVE GOOD
KNOWLEDGE OF THE SITUATION AND
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS PEOPLE
CAN MAKE GOOD DECISIONS- WHAT
THE OTHER ONES THAT ASKED TO
TOUCH ON WAS- EVACUATE. IN THE
FIRE CHIEF SHOULD REALLY
TOUCHED ON THAT. IN THE NEED
FOR MORE THAN ONE WAY ONE WAY
INGRESS EGRESS- PROPER WARNING
SYSTEMS. AND I'LL TELL YOU I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU A BOOTS ON THE
GROUND THEY SPENT SIXTEEN YEARS
AS A FIRE CAPTAIN. ON THE FIRE
COMPANY AND ALL THE FIRE CHIEFS
ON THIS CALL WILL WILL BACK
THIS UP. WHEN WE GO TO AN
INCIDENT. IT DOESN'T MATTER IF
IT'S- LARGE OR SMALL OUR NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY IS LIFE SAFETY.
AND SAVING LIVES. AND IN THE
INCIDENTS THAT WE'VE HAD
WEATHER WAS THE CAR FIRE THE
CAMPFIRE THE THOMAS FIRE AND
THE ATLAS TUBBS UP IN SANTA
ROSA- WE COULD HAVE HAD. AS ONE
PERSON PUT IT TAKE THE CAMPFIRE
YOU COULD PUT A THOUSAND
ENGINES ON AVERAGE. AND THEY
WEREN'T GOING TO BE ABLE TO
STOP THAT WE'RE GOING TO VENT
SOMETIMES- JUST GETTING PEOPLE
OUT OF HARM'S WAY IS WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO FOR THE FIRST TEN OR
TWELVE HOURS BECAUSE IF YOU
DON'T GET- OUR COMMUNITIES OUT
OF HARM'S WAY. THE INCIDENT
JUST MAGNIFIES GREATLY AND I
THINK THAT'S GONNA BE OUR
CHALLENGE INTO THE FUTURE AND
WHAT'S GOING TO PLAY A PART OF
THAT WE JUST TALKED ABOUT IT-
PRIOR TO THIS WAS THE METRICS
DAY- WELL THE COMMUNITY CAN USE
TO JUDGE WHAT THEIR SAFETY IS
GOING TO BE THE AND WHEN THEY
EAT TO GET OUT. IT'S ALL OLD
BATHROOMS IN TOGETHER AND- IT
IS SO CRITICAL THAT WE DO IT
RIGHT FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
YES TO CAL FIRE THAT WE DEVELOP
AND BEEN WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONCERNS THE OTHER PART OF
ANYTHING- CHIEF IDEAS ON HERE-
FOR THE MOST PART PORTION
ISSUES WHOSE GO TO CARRY OUT
THIS. YOU WOULD BE A- PART OF
THE- AND- THAT IS GOING TO
EIGHTEEN EFFORT AND TEAM
COMMITTEE. AND THAT SHOULD BE.
DONE ON THE TOP FIVE OF LIST OF
OUR THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO.
THE OTHER ONE AND I'LL NEVER
FORGET THIS I WAS AT THE CAMP
FIRE WITH- GOVERNOR NEWSOM-
ACTUALLY WAS GOVERNOR ELECT HE
HAD NOT TAKEN OFFICE YET AND-
WE TOOK THE GOVERNOR AT THEIR
ANYONE DID SEE A COUPLE OF
THINGS YOU WANT TO SEE THE
FRONT LINE. YOU WANT TO SEE
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE LINE AND HE
WANTED TO VISIT IN EVACUATION
CENTER AND I WILL NEVER FORGET
THIS IT WAS BURNED INTO MY
HEAD- WE RIPPED ONE OF THE
EARLY EVACUATION CENTERS IN
CHICO I BELIEVE IT WAS A
CHURCH. AND THE GOVERNOR WAS
SPEAKING TO SOME OF THE
EVACUEES ANY ANY BASICALLY NOTE
BY A LADY AN ELDERLY LADY THAT
WAS- SHE WAS STRIPPED COVER.
USE THAT HOSPITAL BED SHE HAD
CATHOLIC- FORGET THIS SHE SAID
TO HIM- WE DIDN'T KNOW WE
DIDN'T KNOW WE HAD TO LEAVE WE
DIDN'T KNOW THERE WAS A FIRE
AND HE TURNED IT IN I DON'T
KNOW I FELT LIKE IT WAS TO ME
BUT- HE TURNED IN AND- AS SHE
WAS SAYING WE DIDN'T KNOW WE
DIDN'T KNOW AND HE SAID. THAT'S
NEVER GONNA HAPPEN AGAIN. AND
SO AS WE TALK ABOUT EMERGENCY-
EVACUATION ORDERS IN I MEAN
CHIEF MCLAUGHLIN EVERYBODY
CITY- ALL FORMS OF SOCIAL
MEDIA- RADIO TV FACEBOOK
INSTAGRAM- YOU KNOW MAYBE WE
NEED TO ALSO LOOK AT SOME OF
THESE PLACES. THAT ARE IN THE
DANGER ZONE I YOU KNOW I'M I
LIVE UP IN PLUMAS COUNTY INTO
THE SECURITY AREA AND MAYBE
SOMETIMES THE OLD FASHIONED.
CIVIL DEFENSE. CAN BE. THAT
ISN'T ALERT TO GET PEOPLE TO
LOOK AT- WHETHER IT'S THEIR TV
OR THE RADIO. DON'T FORGET THAT
SOMETIMES JUST THE SIMPLEST
THINGS CAN WORK VERY VERY WELL
WHEN IT COMES TO- INFORMING
INFORMING PEOPLE THAT THE
DANGER THE OTHER ONE AND THIS
ONE IT WAS INTERESTING TO
LISTEN TO THE DISCUSSION ON
THIS- AKTIV THERE IT. FOR LOCAL
ALERTS YOU KNOW WE CAN GO FROM
12220% OF THE- COMMUNITY WHILE
OPTED TO PARTICIPATE IN LOCAL
ALERTS I THINK THE DAY IN AGE
OF OPTING IN. WHEN IT COMES TO-
A DISASTER OR NATURAL DISASTER
IN CALIFORNIA OVER. THERE'S
THERE SHOULD BE NO WHAT DID YOU
EAT IT SHOULD BE AUTOMATIC
RADIO TV CELLPHONE LANDLINE-
YOU LIVE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
EARTHQUAKES FROM I FORGOT ABOUT
TSUNAMI TRONG OF MUDSLIDES
AFTER FIRES FIRES CIVIL UNREST
THERE SHOULD BE NO OPT IN OPT
OUT YOU. CAN WE AS S.
CALIFORNIANS WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE
CALIFORNIA'S CITIZENS AND THAT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ME IS. MY
NEIGHBOR BOB HIS WIFE ACROSS
THE STREET WHO ARE EIGHTY YEARS
OLD IF SOMETHING HAPPENS ELLEN
AND I KNOW THAT I CAN HANDLE MY
OWN BUSINESS I NEED TO CHECK ON
MY NEIGHBORS YOU NEED TO BE
RESPONSIBLE CALIFORNIA. AND
THERE ARE SOME OF THESE AREAS
THAT- OPT IN AND OPT OUT THAT
SHOULD BE PART OF OUR
VOCABULARY YOU LIVE HERE YOUR
RESIDENT HERE YOU'RE IN THIS
SYSTEM IT'S FOR THE BETTERMENT
OF THE COMMUNITY IT'S FOR THE
BETTER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE OTHER ONE I
DON'T WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
CODED RESPONSE- BECAUSE WE ARE
OVERLOOKING THIS RIGHT NOW
ESSENTIALLY IT'S SOME IT'S
HEATING UP WE'RE IN A MASSIVE-
MUTUALLY INCIDENT RIGHT NOW IT
IT'S. A MEDICAL NATURE AND-
I'LL TELL YOU BECAUSE I DID
SOME CHECK IS WE'RE ON THE
PHONE. I KNEW YESTERDAY I WORK
RIGHT SACRAMENTO METROPOLITAN
FIRE DEPARTMENT RIGHT THERE IN
IN SACRAMENTO. YOU HAD OVER
FORTY MEMBERS OUT YESTERDAY AND
TODAY WITH COLD THEY WERE
CLOSELY RELATED CONTACT RACING
WE ARE FORGETTING WHAT WE'RE
FACING HERE YOU KNOW THE FIRE
SEASON. KNOCK ON WOOD I HOPE
THAT WE GET THROUGH THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PART OF THE
SEASON. BUT THE COLD THE PIECE
OF THIS IS TURNING CRITICAL
AGAIN. FOR ALL OF US AND ONE OF
THE THINGS AND I'M JUST NEVER
GOING TO NOT TAKE THE TIME OR
THE ABILITY TO DO THIS.
FIREFIGHTERS AND FIREFIGHTER
PARAMEDICS WERE NOT CONSIDERED
IN THE FIRST YEAR. OF
FRONTLINE. WORKERS WE WERE
ACTUALLY IN THE SECOND OR THIRD.
AND MAYBE EVEN THE FOURTH TIER.
AFTER NURSES. I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT WHEN PEOPLE GET TO THE
HOSPITAL. WITH SEVERE SYMPTOMS
OF KOBE DIFFERENT TAKES ON YOUR
FIREFIGHTERS IN YOUR
FIREFIGHTER MEDICS WE NEED TO
BE IN THAT FIRST YEAR AND THE
OTHER PIECE ON THAT ON THE KOBE
ALSO THE- RESPONSE. LEADING
PIECE FOR TOO LONG THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE WOULD LOVE TO
TALK ABOUT EFFICIENCIES IN THIS
IS A BOOTS ON THE GROUND
PLEASE- DEFICIENCY USUALLY
MEANS THE MINIMUM. NUMBER OF
FIREFIGHTERS OR POLICE OFFICERS
ON THE SCENE TO HANDLE AN
INCIDENT. AND YOU KNOW IN
PUBLIC SAFETY IF OUR RESPONSE
IS GOING TO BE A MINIMAL
RESPONSE. THAT'S THAT IT'S
PATHETIC IN THAT IT HAS BECOME
THE NORM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE NATIONAL
STANDARD. IT'S FOR PEOPLE ON AN
ENGINE COMPANY FOR THE TRUCK IN
MOST AREAS AND DID YOU KNOW
THAT MOST FIRE DEPARTMENTS IN
THE STATE- CAL FORTY WHEN THEY
RESPOND. YES CALL WHEN THE
STAFF WITH THE STAFF WITH FOR
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT IT'S THE
WAY TO GO BUT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE- USING
THAT SYSTEM. THE STAFF LAST
WEEK THE CITY OF HAVE- THE
STAFF THAN THE MOST WITH LESSEN
MEMBERS- AT HOME WHETHER IT'S
STATUS MONEY TO MAKE MONEY I
DON'T KNOW BUT I THINK. THE
MITCHELL LAKE SYSTEM NEEDS TO
BE AUDITED AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT- YOU KNOW. WE
ACTUALLY ACCEPT A MINIMUM OF
THREE THAT STANDARD NEEDS TO
CHANGE IT NEEDS TO BE FOR
PERSON ON ALL YES RESPONSES.
AND YOU KNOW WE IN THE FIRE
SERVICE YOU KNOW- THE FIRE
CHIEF TO MYSELF I WILL DO SAID
BELIEVE WE ALL AGREE ON THIS-
STAFFING IS CRITICAL STAFFING
IS WHAT LETS US DO OUR JOB
BETTER TO ACCOMPLISH MORE TASKS
TO BE IN A BETTER POSITION TO
SAVE LIFE AND PROPERTY INTO
MANY TIMES- WE HAVE COME DOWN
TO WHAT'S THE MINIMUM STANDARD
AND FOR ME AS A LABOR LEADER IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S VERY
FRUSTRATING- TO SEE THAT IT'S
VERY FRUSTRATING TO SEE THE
FIREFIGHTERS AND PARAMEDICS ARE
PUSHED TO THE FRONT OF CALL THE
TESTING HER BORDER. WELL
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BE CONSIDERED
IN THE FRONT- FOR VACCINE
BECAUSE WE ARE THE ONES THAT
TAKE CARE OF OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S WHEN WE
NEED TO LOOK AT IN ALL OF THIS
RESPONSE WHETHER IT'S WILDFIRE-
SINABI MUD SLIDE. THE MINIMUM
THAT ARE. THAT'S TO GET THE JOB
DONE EVERYTHING ELSE IS VERY
HELPFUL WHETHER IT'S- THEIR
SUPPORT- BULLDOZERS MECHANICAL
BUT IT IS YOU'LL NEVER REPLACE
THE MEN AND WOMEN AND WE NEED
TO GET OUT OF TE MINDSET. THIS
IS WHAT WE CAN USE IT A MINIMUM
WE DON'T EVEN HIT THE C.
STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO FIRE
RESPONSE PROBABLY IN 90% OF THE
STATE. AND- THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY THE BULLETS THAT
I GET ON IT WAS ASKED TO HIT ON
I WOULD. CERTAINLY TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS EVERYTHING THAT YOU
HEARD CHIEF MCLAUGHLIN- CHIEF
REVOKES- CHIEF WELCH- CURRY
COMMENT. ALL THE THERE ARE
NUGGETS OF INFORMATION ON EVERY
PIECE OF THIS A REDUNDANT RADIO
SYSTEM THAT MAY NOT BE PART OF
HER EIGHT HUNDRED SYSTEM IT
COULD BE A HIGH FREQUENCY
SYSTEM. THAT IS YOU KNOW HAS A
DIFFERENT SET OF THE FAIL SAFES
WE CAN MAKE OUR COMMUNICATION
BETTER. AND I'LL LEAVE YOU WITH
THIS- YESS IN CALIFORNIA WE
REALLY AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE
REALLY BEEN LOOKING AT-
MODERNIZING. OUR RESPONSE IN
OUR MUTUAL AID RESPONSE THIS IS
ONE I THINK WE NEED TO DO IN
SACRAMENTO YEARS AGO WE DID
WHAT WE CALL A BOUNDARY DROP.
THERE ARE NO BOUNDARIES FOR
FIRE RESPONSE IN IN THE COUNTY
OF SACRAMENTO. I LIVE IN THE
COUNTY AND I COULD END UP WITH
THREE CITY APPARATUS THERE AND
ONE METRO FIRE CHIEF WE NEED TO
DO THE SAME THING ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE NEED. TO
SEND THE QUOTE CLOSEST
RESOURCES AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
AND THEN OUT OF FIVE AFTER THAT
IN ONE OF THE WAYS IT IS GOING
TO HELP AND I BELIEVE IT WAS-
CHIEF WE GO OFTEN BROUGHT THIS
UP. THAT AUTOMATIC FUEL BIGELOW
CATERS SHOULD BE THE STANDARD
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND SHE THREE BOLTS UP AND-
MAMMOTH LAKES SOMEBODY IN THE
COMMAND CENTER IN HIS REGION.
IF HE'S REPORTING A FIRE THAT
HAS THE GROWTH POTENTIAL TWO
THOUSAND ACRES IN AN HOUR
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
TELL HIM CHIEF. WE'VE GOT
THIRTY TWO ENGINES WITHIN.
SIXTY MILES THERE ALL IN ROUTE
TO YOU. IN A MOVE NOT
NECESSARILY WE HAVE THAT KEEP.
AND WILL NEED TO BE A TO THAT.
THE END. THAT WOULD BE. WHAT IT
WHAT IT THE BIG POINTS FOR ME.
WHICH WE NEED TO DO ABOUT GREEN
DROP. AND WE NEED TO SEND THE
CLOSEST RESOURCES INITIALLY AND
THEN MAKE OUR ADJUSTMENTS AFTER
THAT I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
SOME OF THE FIRES IN LAKE
COUNTY. INDIANA THE BAY AREA I
THINK OUR LAG TIME BETWEEN
REQUEST. WE GOT THERE WE-
EXCUSE ME WAS TOO GREAT AND WE
CAN DO BETTER THAN THAT
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
BAY AREA OR AROUND SACRAMENTO
OR THE LA BASIN. WE CAN GET THE
RESOURCES THERE QUICKER IN AND
THAT'S OUR LIFE'S BLOOD WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. AND I HOPE ALL OF
YOU HAVE A- GOOD HOLIDAY SEASON
AND SENATOR JACKSON YOU WILL BE
MISSED. THANK YOU PRESIDENT
RICE- OUR LAST PANELISTS IN THE
FIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT PANEL- WE
HAVE A KORY HONEA. BUTTE COUNTY
SHERIFF REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION. HIS THE SHERIFF
AVAILABLE.
OKAY OF THE SHERIFF
IS NOT ONLINE- SO WE WILL- YOU
KNOW BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
MEMBER QUESTIONS- I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
PANELISTS FOR BRINGING YOUR ON
THE GROUND AND LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE TO THIS HEARING IT
IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK AS
LEGISLATORS WE SHOULD ALWAYS
HAVE YOUR PERSPECTIVES WHEN
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT SOLUTIONS-
TO EMERGENCY ALERTS AND
IMPROVING- EMERGENCY
EVACUATIONS- AS WE HEARD FROM
YOU YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE AREAS WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE MANY TYPES OF EMERGENCIES-
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE-
ARE. ALWAYS FOCUS ON THE
COMMUNITY BE PREPARED TO
EVACUATE AND READY TO GO LIKE
MANY OF YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR
OWN STORIES IN YOUR OWN
EXPERIENCES- I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT WE NEED TO STOP OPT IN IN-
TO THESE ALERTS AND YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S AT A DIFFERENT
LEVEL NOW IN TERMS OF
EMERGENCIES- AND WITH YOU KNOW
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE AND EXTREME
HEAT OF WE WILL CONTINUE TO PUT
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES- IN THIS
ONGOING BATTLE WITH EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT- AND SO. ON YOU
BROUGHT UP SOME GREAT TOPICS
AND NOW WE'RE READY FOR-
QUESTIONS- IS THE SHERIFF
AVAILABLE OKAY SO NOW WE DO
HAVE THE SHERIFF ONLINE SO I
WILL- LET HIM- PRESENT TO US
AND THEN WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
MEMBER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
SIR SHERIFF THANK. THANK YOU
VENTURA COLLEGE EYES I WAS
HAVING MY COMPUTER FROZE UP ON
ME- THE WORLD WE LIVE IN TODAY
IS A PRONE TO THAT KIND OF
THING SO I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. ADDRESS THIS
COMMITTEE- WELL I HAVE LISTENED
TO THE ENTIRE. HEARING 
ECHO MANY OF THE COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUES MAY KNOW SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I WOULD SAY- WILL
SOMBER FAMILIAR TO YOU I THINK
THAT THEY'RE WORTHY OF
EMPHASIZING AND SO IN
PARTICULAR I'M GONNA EMPHASIZE
SOME OF THINGS THAT CHIEF WELCH
SAID AS WELL AS SOME THINGS
THAT PRESIDENT ARE RISING SENT.
ALERT AND WARNING AND
EVACUATION COORDINATION IS A
VERY VERY COMPLEX OPERATION IT
IS SOMETHING THAT I'VE HAD A
GOOD EXPERIENCE WITH- AS THE
SHERIFF OF THE COUNTY HAVING
SUFFERED. THROUGH A NUMBER OF
MAJOR DISASTERS AND- AS A
MEMBER OF THE SICILIAN AND
REPRESENTS AS A CITY TODAY.
I'VE HAVE YET TO SPEAK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ROTH STATE YOU. GET
THEIR PERSPECTIVE ON THESE
KINDS OF THINGS AS WELL- WHAT I
CAN TELL YOU IS THAT. THE
COMPLEXITY THAT WE DEAL WITH
WHEN IT COMES TO ALERT AND
WARNING IS REALLY NOT
UNDERSTOOD. BY MANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY IT'S OFTEN NOT
UNDERSTOOD BY THE PEOPLE
OUTSIDE OF. THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT ROUND YEAH I THINK
THAT LENDS TO. INCREASE
DIFFICULTY IN TERMS OF GETTING
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY. EVEN
BEFORE THE ALERT AND WARNING-
IS REQUIRED. THE FACT MATTERS
THIS IF WE'RE AT A POINT WHERE
WE HAVE TO ISSUE AN ALERT AND
WARNING BECAUSE OF OPINION A
DISASTER HAZARD OR CRISIS. WELL
WE ARE ALREADY BEHIND THE CURVE
IF YOU WILL. BUT THE FACT IS
UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES NO
MATTER WHAT KIND OF PREPARATION
WE HAVE DONE AHEAD OF TIME WHAT
KIND OF SYSTEMS WE HAVE IN
PLACE WITH REGARD TO ALERT AND
WARNING. THERE IS NO WAY TO
GUARANTEE 1100% SATURATION OF
YOUR MESSAGE AND THERE'S NO WAY
TO GUARANTEE THAT PEOPLE WILL
DO WHAT YOU ASK THEM TO DO. AND
SO TO EXPECT A PERFECT OUTCOME.
IS IN MY VIEW- PROBABLY- AN
EXPECTATION THAT ISN'T
REALISTIC SO THAT'S WHY I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO FOCUS
ON THE FRONT END OF PREVENTION
AND- INSURING THAT WE'RE A
BETTER POSITION TO PREVENT
THESE KINDS OF. INCIDENTS IN
CRISIS TO FROM CURRENT FIRST
PLACE OR THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
BE CONTROLLED. MUCH MUCH
QUICKER IN IN IN A BETTER
FASHION. AND THAT REQUIRES A
LEVEL OF PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE PART OF
MEMBERS MARCH MEDIAN THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT SEEMS TO BE LOST
IN A LOT OF THESE DISCUSSIONS
IS. ALWAYS ABOUT WHAT IS- YES
DOING WORK FOR THE COUNTY IS
DOING WHAT IS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND WHAT AS FAR DOING. BUT PART
OF THIS EQUATION IS WHAT ARE
THE MEMBERS OF YOUR COMMUNITY
DOING TO. BE PREPARED AND TO BE
TUNED IN TO WHAT'S GOING ON IF
YOU WILLING TO. DO WHAT THEY'RE
BEING ASKED TO DO BY THOSE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE BEST
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
THREAT YES. I'LL REITERATE
SHORT. WHAT OF WHAT THAT'LL- IS
JUST BECAUSE I THINK SUPPORT
FOR YOUR STAND THAT. IS YOU
HEARD FROM CHIEF WELCH THE
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS THAT. WE
HAVE TO COME TO KNOW ABOUT THE
THREAT AND THAT REQUIRES US TO
BUT IN IN IN IN BOTH FIRES FAR
SIDE AS WELL AS LONG FOR
SOCIETY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
THREAT IS. FIRE OR FLOOD OR
POTENTIAL OF. REACH A DAM OR
TSUNAMI OR TORNADO OR WHATEVER
THAT WHATEVER THE SITUATION WE
MIGHT BEGIN WITH THERE'S THIS
PERIOD OF TIME WHERE YOU HAVE
TO. COME TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
THREAT IS AND THEN WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSES AND THAT
TAKES TIME. BEYOND THAT THERE
IS THE COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
VARIOUS A PUBLIC SAFETY
CEASEFIRE LAW AND MEDICAL AS
WELL AS THE EXTENDED- COUNTY
RESPONSE WHICH INCLUDES.
SETTING UP SHELTERS AND DEALING
WITH. IT EVACUEES AND ALL OF
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
COME. TO ISSUE THE WARNING
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
COORDINATION- IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF THAT AND THEN FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF DEVELOPING A
CLEAR MESSAGE AS TO WHAT THE
THREAT IS. HONESTLY BOOKS. THAT
IS EASIER SAID THAN DONE
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
CONVEY. WHAT THE THREAT IS AND
WHAT THE RESPONSE SHOULD BE IN
THE LIMITATIONS THAT ACROSS BY
THE VERY SYSTEMS THAT WE USE TO
COMMUNICATE THAT IT ISN'T
ALWAYS AS EASY OR AS QUICK AS
YOU WORK AS ONE MIGHT THINK NOW
WE'VE DONE SOME THINGS LOCALLY
TO TRY TO. SHORTEN THAT WINDOW
OF A TIME WE CAN'T MESSAGES
THAT WE CAN USE AND MODIFY AND
ALTER BUT ULTIMATELY EVERY
SINGLE. THREAT COMES WITH
DIFFERENT CHARACTERISTICS
DIFFERENT VARIABLES THAT HAVE
TO BE COMMUNICATED AND AGAIN
PUTTING THAT IN A SUCCINCT
MESSAGE THAT. THE VAST MAJORITY
PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND AND THEN
ADVISING THEM WHAT THE
RESPONSES IN THE VERY VERY
CHALLENGING. NOW YOU HEARD
ABOUT HOW POOR IT IS WITH
MESSAGE ACROSS MULTIPLE
PLATFORMS THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THAT NO ONE LISTENS.
NO ONE LISTENS TO A SINGLE
SOURCE. EVERYBODY IS TUNED INTO
VARIOUS. FORMS OF COMMUNICATION
I WILL TELL YOU THAT THERE HAS
BEEN A MOVEMENT A DEPENDENCY
UPON CELLPHONES. WELL THAT I
ITS CONCERNS ABOUT BECAUSE
QUITE FRANKLY I THINK. NOT ONLY
DOES THE GOVERNMENT BUT DID THE
PUBLIC ALSO BECOMES OVER
RELIANT UPON RECEIVING
INFORMATION FROM THEIR CELL
PHONES AND WE'VE SEEN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN. BUT THAT DOESN'T
ALWAYS WORK THE SYSTEMS GO DOWN
BUT IT BECOME OVERLOADED AND WE
LOSE OUR ABILITY COMMUNICATE.
BUT ULTIMATELY YOU NEED TO BE
ABLE TO PUSH YOUR MESSAGE
ACROSS MULTIPLE PLATFORMS IT
AFTER TO GET MAXIMUM
DISTRIBUTION. THAT INCLUDES.
THE ALERT AND WARNING SYSTEMS
THAT MANY COUNTIES HAVE THEIR
DIFFERENT VENDORS THAT PROVIDE
THAT IT. MAYBE IT'S WORTH WHILE
TALKING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT.
THERE SHOULD BE A STATE WIDE
OUR SYSTEM SO THERE'S A
CONTINUITY THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE. BUT IT'S THROUGH
THOSE SYSTEMS THAT WE ALL
ACCESS I POINTS WHICH IS THE-
ALERT AND WARNING SYSTEM- THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE WIRELESS
ALERT SYSTEM ANY MERCY. ALERT
SYSTEM. OUR GRASS. MESSAGES
THAT MOVE. THROUGH THOSE
PLATFORMS BUT HAS EXPECTATIONS
THERE ARE CHARACTER LIMITATIONS
THAT- CREATE A PROBLEM FOR US
IN TERMS OF AGAIN ARTICULATED
WITH THE THREAT IS AND ADVISING
WHAT THE RESPONSE SHOULD BE. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT IN ADDITION TO
UTILIZING THE MERCY
NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS WHICH AS
YOU POINTED OUT ARE OFTEN. OF
ACCESSING HIGH COSTS WHICH- ARE
NOT ADOPTED SYSTEM BUT WE CAN
PUSH THAT OUT THROUGH THE- WE
ARE IN THE A. F. SYSTEM. BUT AS
I SAID THERE ARE LIMITATIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH ALL THAT. WE
FOUND WE NEED TO SET UP CALL
CENTRES. IN CONJUNCTION WITH
PUSHING MESSAGES OUT THROUGH I
PAUSE AND WE HAVE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
BECAUSE EITHER THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS PUT OUT OR
WE WORRY WILL PROVIDE ALL OF
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED
GIVEN THE LIMITATIONS- IN THE
FORMAT OR LIMITATIONS IN IN
THE- IN THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE'RE USING. YEAH THAT IS ONE
OF THE WAYS THAT WE HAVE TO
HELP MITIGATE THE BURDEN UPON
OUR NINE ONE ONE DISPATCHERS.
WELL THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE USE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA AND TRADITIONAL
MEDIA I'LL TALK ABOUT SOCIAL
MEDIA REAL QUICKLY THE FACT IS
IT IS PART OF OUR LANDSCAPE IS
PART OF OUR ENVIRONMENT. BUT
YOU HAVE TO MESSAGE ON SOCIAL
MEDIA BOTH FACEBOOK AND TWITTER
AND NOW INSTAGRAM SOME THOSE
OTHERS. IF YOU DON'T PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY WILL TAKE IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO TAKE YOUR MESSAGE
AND IN SOME CASES THEY DON'T
TAKE IT ACCURATELY AND THEY
BEGIN TO PUSH IT OUT SO YOU
HAVE TO OPERATE WITHIN THAT
ENVIRONMENT AS WELL. BUT THAT
APARTMENT IS OF COURSE PRONE TO
A LOT OF A RUMOR A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION AND ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY. YOU HAVE TO WORK
TO COMBAT THE- BUTTE COUNTY
WE'VE UP. THE SIMPSONS RADIO.
UTILIZING HIM. AGREED YOU ARE.
IN EFFORT TO. BROADEN OURS. IN
OUR REGION- AND I'LL TALK TO
ABOUT WHY THAT'S IMPORTANT
RURAL AREAS. AND THEN OF COURSE-
WE UTILIZE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO GO IN THE IMPACT
THERE IS. AFTER THE OROVILLE
DAM SPILLWAY INCIDENT OF THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS CAME TO
BE COUNTY. AND TALKED ABOUT THE
BACK WHICH THEY DID ONE OF THE
THINGS THEY- ARE POINTED OUT
SOME SOME STUDIES THEY HAVE
DONE IS THAT THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY. TO GET PEOPLE TO EVACUATE.
THIS FOR A LONG FORCING OFFICER
IN UNIFORM TO GO TO THEIR DOOR.
TELL THEM OF THE THREAT AND
TELL THEM WHAT THE RESPONSE.
YOU'RE MORE APT TO GET THEM TO
DO WHAT YOU NEED YOU ARE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. BUT THE FACT THE
MATTER IS. THAT'S NOT PRACTICAL
ESPECIALLY IN THESE. RAPIDLY
EVOLVING SITUATIONS LIKE THE
COUNSELOR ON PRESIDENT OF RICE
MADE THIS COMMENT IN FACT IS I
MADE THIS CALM AS WELL DURING
THE CAMPFIRE THERE WERE NOT
ENOUGH FIRE ENGINES AND THERE
WERE NOT ENOUGH **** IN A
PROBABLY THE STATE CALIFORNIA
TO PREVENT THAT FIRE FROM
MOVING THROUGH AND FOR US TO
GET TO EVERY SINGLE. HOUSE AND
NOTIFY PEOPLE WHAT WAS GOING ON
AND THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WE ARE FACING HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. BUT TO MITIGATE.
B. FACT THAT THERE'S NO WAY FOR
US TO GO DOOR TO DOOR KNOCK IN
A RUN STORE. A WE IMPLEMENTED
THE HIGH LOW SIREN AS MUCH AS
YOU CAME THROUGH- THIS YEAR.
AUTHORIZED LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU
THAT I THINK THAT'S A- A GREAT
PROGRAM THAT WE CAN ALSO BUILD
ON- YOU THAT BECAUSE I WANT YOU
TO STAND. HOW MUCH EFFORT GOES
INTO ALERTING PEOPLE AND NOTIFY
THEM. OF WHAT THE THREAT IS.
AND THEN FROM THERE EVACUATING
NOW TRYING TO GET THEM THERE
AND THAT BRINGS WITH IT A WHOLE
HOST OF COMPLEXITY- FIRST OFF
YOU HAVE TO HELP. LOCATIONS FOR
PEOPLE TO GO YOU HAVE TO
RESOURCE FOR THEM WHEN THEY GET
THERE. AND WHAT I FIND IS THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFTENTIMES. ARE
REQUIRED TO SPEND. MORE TIME
ASSISTING PEOPLE WITH ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS. AS WELL
AS PEOPLE WITH ANIMALS. ANIMALS
BECOME A VERY VERY PROBLEMATIC
SITUATION FORCE OFTENTIMES
PEOPLE WILL NOT THAT EVACATE.
THEIR HOME IF THEY DON'T HAVE A
WAY TO TAKE. A PATH. AND SO-
THIS IDEA OR NOTION OF BEING
ABLE TO GO DOOR TO DOOR AND
NOTIFY EVERYBODY IS FURTHER
EXACERBATED BY THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO SPEND OUR TIME.
ASSISTING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AGAIN WOULD ASK IS IMPARTIAL
NEEDS ASSISTING THOSE
INDIVIDUAL ANIMALS SO THEY CAN
ULTIMATELY- GET OUT OF THAT
AREA WAS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
BUT THE ONE VARIABLE HERE THAT
IS SO DIFFICULT TO CONTROL. OR
PEOPLE. IN THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THIS. MANY PEOPLE NO
THE THREAT IS COMING. THEY ARE
CURRENT EITHER THROUGH AN
OFFICIAL SOURCE OR THROUGH A
RELIABLE SOURCE OF THAT THE
THREAT IS COMING BUT THEY
CHOOSE NOT TO FOLLOW THE
DIRECTIONS WE CHOOSE NOT TO
HEED THE ADVICE I CAN'T TELL
YOU. THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
I. BIRD TELL ME VERY A
HARROWING STORIES ABOUT
ESCAPING THE FLAMES AND
CAMPFIRE AND THEN MOST RECENTLY
HERE IN INDICATING THE VERIFIER-
ALL OF THAT BEGIN WITH WELL WE
WEREN'T SURE IF WE SHOULD
EVACUATE WE WANTED TO WAIT TO
SEE IF THE FIRE WAS COMING- WE
ARE ULTIMATELY DID EVACUATE
UNTIL WE SAW THE FLAMES AND-
FRANKLY UP BY THAT POINT IT'S
TOO LATE. AND REGRETTABLY A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE PERISHED IN
THAT FIRE FAMILY MEMBERS TOLD
US THE SAME KIND OF THING
DEBATE THE NEW THE THREAT WAS
COMING BUT THEY CHOSE NOT TO
EVACUATE. ON FOR NUMBER OF
REASONS. ALL OFTENTIMES WILL
NOT DO NOT WANT TO LEAVE THEIR%
HOME. AND IT BECOMES A VERY
VERY DIFFICULT PROPOSITION FOR
US DEAL. NOW THERE WAS THERE
WAS A- SOME SOME COMMENTS
EARLY- OR WHAT JOBS EMAILED ME
WITH REGARD TO THAT AND THE
FACT MATTERS I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE YOU'RE GONNA CHANGE THAT
FOLKS. ON YOU. YOU CAN ISSUE AN
ORDER. AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER. IF A PERSON REFUSES TO
OBEY THE ORDER IN ONE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE YOU BELIEVE
THE VIOLATION OF THE LAW IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR CRIME BUT IN A
PRACTICAL SENSE YOU CAN'T GO
ABOUT ARRESTING PEOPLE IN
TRANSPORTING THEM TO JAIL
BECAUSE THEY REFUSED TO LEAVE
COLLEGE OPTICAL SERVICES TO GET
THEIR KIDS CALLING ANIMAL
CONTROL TO GET THEIR OWN
BECAUSE- WHILE YOU'RE DOING
THAT. YOU'RE MISSING OUT ON THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ALERT AND HELP
EVACUATE MANY OTHER PEOPLE I
DON'T THINK THAT'S ULTIMATELY
THE ANSWER THE QUESTION. WHAT I
DO THINK IS A BETTER USE OF OUR
TIME AND RESOURCES IS ONE. WE
NEED TO REALLY INVEST IN
PREVENTING THESE THINGS FROM
OCCURRING IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND THAT MEANS- DEALING WITH UN.
THE FUEL LOADS THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH IN IN. THE RURAL
AREAS AND THE FIRES MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS DEFENSIBLE SPACE
AND MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS A
ROBUST ROBUST A CHAMP PAYNE A
TO GET PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE. OF PREPARING HAVE
YOUR PLAN IN PLACE TUNING IN TO
THE VARIOUS METHODS IN WHICH WE
COMMUNICATE AND BE READY TO GO
AND GOING HOME WE ASK THEM TO I
THINK ULTIMATELY GAINING THAT
KIND OF COMPLIANCE FOR MANY
FROM OUT IN FIRST PLACE AGAIN
THAT COMPLIANCE IS GOING TO BE
A MUCH MUCH BETTER A SOLUTION
TO THE PROBLEM. THE LAST THING
THAT I WANT TO JUST BRING TO
YOUR ATTENTION BECAUSE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT. I BECAME MORE
AND MORE FAMILIAR WITH IN THE
LAST PART OF THE BILL THAT AND
THAT IS THE IMPACT OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS
ON SOME OF OUR VERY RURAL
COMMUNITY. NOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME TALK ABOUT THE NEED TO
HAVE A SEVENTY TWO HOUR-
GENERATORS ARE BACKUP
GENERATORS WERE CELL SITES AND
THAT'S GREAT AS LONG AS YOU'VE
GOT CELL SERVICE. BUT THERE ARE
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. IN AND RUN
REMOTE CAL. WHERE THEY HAVE
CELLS. AND SO WHAT THEY RELY
UPON. IS CONNECTING THEIR CELL
PHONE TO THEIR INTERNET
PROVIDER IN UTILIZING THEIR
INTERNET PROVIDER OR VOICE OVER
INTERNET PROTOCOL PHONE SERVICE
TO HAVE COMMUNICATION WITH THE
OUTSIDE WORLD. ONCE THE POWER
IS TURNED OFF THEY LOSE THE
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY AND AS
SUCH THEY LOSE THAT CELLPHONE
AND THAT VOICE OR IN A PROTOCOL
FONG AND AS YOU KNOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE ARE STARTING TO GO
AWAY FROM LANDLINE PHONES AND
SO IN THOSE CASES- SOMETIMES
THE ONLY THING YOU HAVE LEFT.
IS THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE
THAT WRAPS YOU'RE ONE OF THE
OTHER- MECHANISMS OFFERED BY I
PAUSE THE MERCY ALERT SYSTEM WE
HAVE SOME RADIO OUR SYSTEM AND
SO I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE. A
STATE WIDE. PLAN AROUND-
GETTING PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT. THEY HAVE A- RESPONSE.
THEY HAVE TO TAKE PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEMSELVES
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES FOR THEIR
NEIGHBORS AS A GROUP BECAUSE IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE
IF THEY DON'T TAKE THAT TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY IF THEY'RE JUST
WAITING FOR THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO TELL THEM WHEN
AND WHERE AND WHAT TO DO AND
THEN THEY'LL MAKE A DECISION AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE GOING
TO. LISTEN TO BE LOCAL
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL THE FACT IS
TO IT. WE REALLY HAVE TO IT HAS
TO BE PART OF THE OVERALL
EQUATION AND IF IT'S NOT I JUST
DON'T KNOW THAT WE'RE GONNA
BUILD A GUARANTEE- SIGNIFICANT
OVERWHELMING SUCCESS ACROSS THE
BOARD IT TAKES THE PUBLIC TO BE
PART OF THIS EQUATION AND NOT
ONLY IN TERMS OF PREPAREDNESS
BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF PREVENTION
AND WITH THAT I'LL CONCLUDE MY
COMMENTS AND ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SHARE. I SO NOW WE
WILL MOVE ON- TWO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE I WANT TO
START WITH. A QUESTION FROM
SENATOR JACKSON. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WAS A VERY
INTERESTING PANEL AND I WANT TO
SAY IT'S A- PLEASURE AND A
PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH SO MANY
OF YOU OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
BRIAN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR GREAT
EFFORT AND- IT'S VERY
INTERESTING TO ME TO HEAR THE
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES HERE
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MORE RURAL AREAS WHERE THERE
ARE CERTAINLY REAL CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH JUST SIMPLE
ACCESS TO. TO THE WARNING
SYSTEMS THAT EXIST IN SOME
CERTAIN THINGS- BUT BUT I
THINK- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
REDUNDANCY I THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO HAVE AVAILABLE TO US ALL. OF
THE TECHNOLOGIES AND I CAN TELL
YOU ARE SURE PHONE A- I HAD
MORE THAN ONE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER KNOCK AT MY BACK DOOR
AND TELL ME IT WAS TIME TO GO-
IN PART BECAUSE THE A LARGE
DON'T WORKABLE. ARE IT'S
UNCLEARWHAT THEY WHO THEY'RE
TELLING TO EVACUATE WHAT THE
CHALLENGES ARE SO- AND I'M NOT
QUITE THAT SAME RURAL AREA I'M
IN A SORT OF A- MOVIE BUT NOT
QUITE OUT THERE IN THE-
EXTREMES. SO I APPRECIATE ALL
YOU DO AND I REALLY DO- I THINK
WE OWE YOU ALL A DEBT OF
GRATITUDE THERE ARE SO MANY.
QUESTIONS I HAVE I'M GONNA TRY
TO NARROW IT DOWN JUST TO A
COUPLE- IN FOCUS ON. SOME OF
THE LEGISLATION THAT I'VE DONE
YOU YOU'VE ALL MENTIONED SOME
OF THESE AREAS FROM PREVENTION
AND THINNING OF- YOU KNOW WE I
I'VE DONE LEGISLATION ON
CONTROLLED BURNS SO THAT WE CAN
DO MORE OF THAT WE BRING IN
CALLAWAY YES AND THE FIRE-
AGENCIES AND AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL PEOPLE. AND I THINK
WE'VE REALLY CREATED A GOOD
SYSTEM- I WON'T BE HERE TO
IMPROVE UPON IT I'M SURE THERE
IS A LOT TO IMPROVE UPON AND I
WANT TO INVITE YOU ALL TO WORK
WITH. MY COLLEAGUES WHO. SHARE
THIS AREA OF CONCERN. IT WHEN
AND IF YOU IDENTIFY PLACES
WHERE MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
DO A BETTERJOB I DO A LOT OF
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS SORT OF AN
INITIAL START WHEN IT COMES TO
WILDFIRES- BUT- I'M- I'M ALSO
CONCERNED THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE AN OPT IN AND
OPT OUT WE SHOULD JUST DO IT-
AND- NOT THAT I DISAGREE- BUT-
I THINK THAT WE DO HAVE TO BE
REALISTIC THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
THAT JUST DON'T. WANT US
TELLING THEM WHAT TO DO. AND
THEY'RE NOT GONNA LEAVE NO
MATTER WHAT WE TELL THEM- AND
THAT'S JUST A FACT- BUT I DO DO
LEGISLATION THAT REQUIRES OR I
SHOULD SAY THAT ENCOURAGED
RISKY UNIVERSITIES. TO CREATE
AN OPT OUT SYSTEM. THAT MEANS
THAT MOST PEOPLE. WILL BE IN
THE SYSTEM DOWN GET NOTIFIED.
THEY'LL BE. AND HOW. THEY'LL
MAKE. THE BEST DECISION FOR
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES. BUT MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE ARE NOT
SEEING- COMMUNITIES A- COUNTIES
REALLY. PROMOTING THIS PROCESS
OF IT IS THAT WE LEFT IT UP TO
EVERY COUNTY BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WHILE THERE IS A
LOT WE CAN DO STATEWIDE IMPACT
PROBABLY SHOULD BE DOING MORE.
OUT WE DO NEED TO RECOGNIZE
EVERY COUNTY HAS ITS DIFFERENT-
ISSUES CONCERNS GEOGRAPHY
EXPERIENCE WHATEVER. AND THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE IN PORT AS
WELL FROM FROM THOSE AREAS
SKINNER WE HAVE DIFFERENT-
FIRED WE HAVE FOUR SHOP IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE- WE
HAVE DIFFERENT- YOU KNOW. TYPES
OF FUELS IN THE SOUTHERN PART
OF THE STATE AND I HAVE TO
ADDRESS THEM DIFFERENTLY THERE
IS NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL. BUT I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO SHARE WITH
ME- AND WHOEVER WANTS TO TRY TO
ANSWER THIS. WHY WE AREN'T
GETTING GREATER PARTICIPATION
IN OUR OPT OUT NOTIFICATION
PROGRAMS- THIS CONCERNS ME
BECAUSE- YOU GOT TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AND- I WE HAVE A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
MECHANISMS- SOMEBODY HAD
MENTIONED LIKE WE HAD THE OLD
CONRAD SYSTEM FOR ANY OF YOU
OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER- THAT
CRISIS BACK WHEN WE THOUGHT WE
WERE GOING TO BE IN A NUCLEAR.
GOD HELP US- THE NUCLEAR
DISASTER WE HAD THIS WARNING
SYSTEM WE DON'T HAVE IT
ANYMORE- WE USED TO BACK IN THE
OLD DAYS HAVE THECHURCH BELLS
WE DON'T HAVE THOSE EITHER. SO
BUT WE DO HAVE TECHNOLOGY WE
HAVE SOME EXTRAORDINARY
POSSIBILITIES WHY ARE WE NOT.
SEEING IT BEING USED MORE.
THANK YOU. BRING RACE. JUST I
THINK ON MY END. GET IT LIVING
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY- I'M GOING
BACK IN MY MEMORY YOU CAN EVEN
TRYING TO REMEMBER- THE LAST
TIME THE COUNTY MAY HAVE PUT A
NOTICE ON TWITTER IS THAT YOU
SEE ON TELEVISION OR RADIO ON
SOCIAL MEDIA ABOUT THE SYSTEM
AND- JOINING IN I THINK I THINK
PART OF IT IS SAFE ANY THINK WE
DO IF WHAT IS AFTER
COMMUNICATION WE'RE PROBABLY
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THE
ENTIRE EVENT AND IF WE DON'T
YEAH THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS THAT
WOULD BE KIND OF ONE OF MY- MY
BIGGEST ONE I DON'T THINK A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THE COUNTIES ARE
REALLY AWARE AND IT'S PROBABLY-
AS- AS A- A COUNTY RESIDENT WE
COULD PROBABLY DO BETTER. FOR
AT LEAST MAYBE ONCE OR TWICE A
YEAR TO RENEW THAT WITH THE
RESIDENTS THAT HEY THIS IS
SOMETHING WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION. TO LIVE IN COUPLES
YEAH. I COULD NOT DO THAT COM
SO. WE ARE EXPERIENCING THE
ACCOUNTING HAS. IT REALLY BEGAN
YOUR BILL DANCE INSTEAD WHEN WE-
ADOPTED THE USE OF A MERCY
MASTERPIECES CALLED COBRA THERE
OTHER VENDORS OUT THERE I'M NOT
AND I'M NOT SAYING ONE IS
BETTER THE OTHER BUT THAT'S
WHAT WE WILL. BE COUNTY AND IN
THAT REGARD OTHER FEATURES OF
IT THAT ARE OFTEN. IF WE
UTILIZE THE I BECAUSE OF COURSE
WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THAT WE CAN DO THAT BUT WE'RE
LIMITED TERMS DROP. LIKE WHAT
WE FOUND IS YOU AFTER. ON THE-
TRYING TO GET THE WORD OUT
THROUGH VARIOUS MECHANISMS
SOCIAL MEDIA CAMPAIGNS ARE.
GOING ON LOCAL NEWS STATIONS
TALKING THE LOCAL NEWSPAPERS ON.
THE PEOPLE IN THEIR DAILY LIVES
JUST DON'T LIKE TO THINK ABOUT.
DID YOU CRISIS THEY DON'T LIKE
TO THINK ABOUT A POTENTIAL
CATASTROPHE AND SO OUR EFFORT
TO GET PEOPLE TO SIGN UP
DESPITE OUR PUBLIC RELATIONS
CAMPAIGN. WAS MOM- MEDIOCRE AT
BEST UNTIL. A CRISIS HAPPENS
AND WHAT WE FIND IS THAT. IN
THE- WHEN THE FIRE IS BEARING
DOWN UPON PEOPLE WHEN THE WHEN
THERE'S THE POTENTIAL FOR THE
DAM BEEN EVERYBODY STARTS
PAYING ATTENTION AND THAT'S
WHEN WE HAD SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE ULTIMATELY SIGNED UP.
THERE HAD TO BE THAT REP MOONEY
FOR THEM TO BE MOTIVATED ENOUGH
TO GO ON AND SIGN UP FOR THE
ALERTS. BUT THAT'S ANOTHER
REASON WE ALTERNATELY REALIZE
WE HAD A MESSAGE ACROSS
MULTIPLE PLATFORMS IS A BIT
ALSO REFER CODE RED PERHAPS WE
CAN GET HIM THROUGH FACEBOOK
TWITTER SIGN. INFORMATION
CENTER OF THAT'S I DO THE LEDGE.
I DID THE CREATES AN OP OUT SO
THAT EVERYBODY GETS PUT IN THE
SYSTEM AUTOMATICALLY YOU DON'T
HAVE TO GET THEIR PERMISSION-
BUT THEY DO HAVE THE RIGHT IF
THEY DON'T WANT TO PARTICIPATE
THEY CAN OPT OUT- YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE WAY THAT- ALL OF THE-
PLATFORMS ON THE INTERNET.
YOU'RE IN THE SYSTEM UNLESS YOU%
SAY NO I DON'T WANT TO BE- I
THOUGHT THAT HEY WE'VE GOT A
PROCESS HERE WHERE WE CAN KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE. I CREATING AN OPT
OUT SYSTEM BUT I BELIEVE I
HEARD THAT ONLY TWENTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ARE REALLY ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN THAT- AND I'M JUST
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET IS A
SENSE OF WHY WE ARE HAVING SUCH
DIFFICULTY WITH THIS OPT OUT
PROGRAM WHERE. LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAN AND IS ABLE TO REACH OUT TO
VARIOUS- PROVIDERS TO GET THE
INFORMATION PUT IT IN THEIR
SYSTEM SO THAT WHEN THERE IS AN
EMERGENCY. THAT GOES OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY- THEY THEY HAVEN'T
OPTED IN THEY HAVEN'T HAD TO
OFTEN THEY HAVE AN AT THE THINK
ABOUT IT. IT'S THERE THAT'S THE
REASON WE TRIED AN OPT OUT AND
YET I'M CONCERNED THAT IT
DOESN'T SEEM. TO BE HAVING THE
EFFECT THAT WE WERE HOPING
WHICH IS THAT EVERYONE WE GET
NOTIFIED BECAUSE WHEN THERE IS
AN EMERGENCY. THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW ABOUT IT. I
UNDERSTAND A NUMBER GONNA BRING
YOU IN TERMS OF LEGISLATION
ALSO MADE I THINK WAS THAT
THAT'S A GOOD APPROACH NOW.
RECOGNIZE THAT NOT EVERY COUNTY
NOT EVERY COUNTY. HAS THE SAME
RESOURCES AND CAPACITY TO.
BRING SYSTEMS ON SO THAT MIGHT
ACCOUNT FOR. WHY THERE'S BEEN A
LACK ULTIMATELY NOT BUT IT ALSO
BRINGS ME TO ANOTHER POINT
WHICH I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IS. THERE IS AN OVER
RELIANCE UPON TECHNOLOGY
ESPECIALLY CELL PHONES. AND IF
THE MAJORITY OF OUR EFFORTS TO
COMMUNICATE THROUGH A CELL
PHONE PEOPLE I HAVE CONCERNS
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN THE NETWORKS
GO DOWN OR THE NETWORKS GET
JAMMED WITH TRAFFIC DURING
THESE A MAJOR. EVENTS AND-
ALTERNATELY THE CELLPHONE
DOESN'T BECOME A RELIABLE
SOURCE IN THE MIDST OF ALL THIS
AND THAT'S WHY THE NEED FOR-
MESSAGING ACROSS MULTIPLE
PLATFORMS AND IT COMES BACK
YOU'VE GOT TO BE TO GET OUT
LEVEL PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY
IN ALL OF THIS TO ENSURE THE
YOU'RE TUNED INTO DIFFERENT
ASPECTS BUT ALSO- YOU'RE
WILLING TO DO WHAT. NEEDS TO BE
DONE KEEPS. THANK YOU IT WAS
ELSE DID ANYONE FACT FINANCE I
FOR ME ON THE- OKAY I HAVE ONE
LAST QUESTION. AND IT HAS TO
DEAL WITH I DON'T RECALL WHICH
REVIEW OF FOLKS MENTIONED IT.
BUT CREATE WE DO HAVE NETWORKS
NOW- AND I THINK IT PERHAPS IT
WAS. BRIAN WHO MENTIONED THAT
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THE WHOLE PROCESS OF
DISSEMINATING PPVS. DURING
COVERT WE ARE ABOUT TO HAVE A
VACCINE. I AM ONE OF THE BIG
CHALLENGES IS GOING TO BE HOW
DO WE DISPENSE AND QUICKLY
ENOUGH AND EFFECTIVELY ENOUGH
I'M WONDERING IF- YOU FOLKS AND
I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH- WE
ANSWER ANY FOR ANY GROUPS TO
TRY TO BECOME THAT AYE WHAT
WHAT MAY BE SORT OF THE LOGICAL
NETWORK. TO BE GAINED HAD
DISTRIBUTION PROCESS SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE SURE. EVERYONE I CAN
GET THAT VACCINE OF COURSE I
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO DO IT IN
DIFFERENT LEVELS ARE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND OUR- MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND SO
FORTH BUT ARE YOU PART OF THE
EFFORT- TO CREATE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S GOING TO
GET THAT VACCINE OUT AS QUICKLY
AND EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
SHOULD YOU BE ARE AND WHAT IS
BEING DONE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
IF YOU BELIEVE THAT YOU SHOULD
BE INCLUDED IN THAT GIVEN THE
WORK ALREADY BEEN DOING ON PPC
SO FORTH AND JUST. YOU KNOW IN
GENERAL. THE WORK THAT YOU DO%
WITH THEM- USE AND FIGHTING
FIRES AND DISASTERS AS YOU DO.
YOU SENATOR JACK. IN INTERNET.
MAKE EASIER THE SIMPLE ANSWER
IS DO I BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE A
PART OF IT YES- THAT'S THE EASY
SIMPLE ANSWER- WE STARTED HAVE
STARTED DOWN A PATHWAY- THE
COMMUNITY PARAMEDICINE IN AB
WORK LIST SECRETARY- DOCTOR
GALLEY AND- DICK DUNCAN
ANSWERED DIRECTOR I THINK THAT
I'M PERMITS AND FIREFIGHTER
PARAMEDIC SHOULD BE PART OF
THAT DISCUSSION ON THE
COMMUNITY DELIVERY- I DON'T
KNOW THE LEVEL IN THE GAPS THAT
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING BUT I DO
KNOW THAT MANY DEPARTMENTS- IN
CALIFORNIA'S METRO FIRE IS AN
EXAMPLE- TESTING UNIT IN
SERVICE. AND THE MOBILE TESTING
THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY SO I
CREEK THAT. IF THAT WAS CASH
AND IS NOT BEING AT THAT LEVEL
IT REALLY NEEDS TO BE BECAUSE
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT- WE'RE
LOCATED IN ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
COMMUNITY AND IF YOU'RE IN
SACRAMENTO. RIGHT IN A FIRE
STATION A FIRE ENGINE CAN GET
TO YOUR HOME AND IN FIVE
MINUTES OR LESS I THINK THAT
WERE ONE OF THE VEHICLES ALONG
WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD AND
SOME OF THE OTHER- LARGE SCALE.
YOU KNOW THAT EVEN AGAINST THE
LOGISTICS OF IT. IN THE SHORT
ANSWER IS YES WE SHOULD BE A
PART OF THAT AND YOU KNOW THAT
WOULD DEFINITELY BE A
DISCUSSION WITH NOT ONLY THE
GOVERNOR AND- YES BUT- DR MARK
GALLI YEAH ARE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SECRETARY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO THE OTHER
GENTLEMAN- CHIEF WELCH- TO
ACHIEVE FREE LONDON AND- SURE
PHONY YOU DO AGREE I MEAN ARE
YOU. ARE YOU- SET UP TO DO THIS
ARE YOU READY TO GO SHOULD THE
GOVERNOR BE LOOKING YOU SHOULD
ALWAYS YES BE LOOKING TO YOU
SHOULD WE BE LOOKING TO YOU- TO
DO THIS I MEAN WE- THIS IS
GOING TO BE SOMETHING WE ALL
WANT TO GET OUT OF OUR HOMES
AND- I WANT TO SEE MY GRANDKIDS
AND I BET EVERYBODY HAS THE
THINGS THEY WANT TO DO. YOU
KNOW I'M NOT GETTING ANY
YOUNGER AND THEY'RE GROWING UP
WITHOUT ME AND I DON'T WANT
THAT. AND I SUSPECT WE ALL HAVE
SIMILAR FEELINGS WELL SOME
PEOPLE WITH A DESPERATE TO GET
THEIR KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL WE
WANT TO GET THROUGH THIS THING
AND IF INDEED WE HAVE THAT
VACCINE WE'VE GOT TO DISTRIBUTE
IT ARE YOU. THE PLACE WE SHOULD
BE GOING TO HELP DISTRIBUTE.
SENATOR THIS IS CHEAPER WALTER
IT'S AN ACTUAL AND FOR QUESTION.
V. ALL REFERENCE WHAT HE SAID-
EARLIER ABOUT THE- SHASTA
EMERGENCY CENTER- AT. THE CITY
LEVEL COUNTY OR I'M I CAN'T
SPEAK OBVIOUSLY EACH OF ARE ALL
BUT WE DIFFERENTLY BUT
ESSENTIALLY WE'RE SUPPORTING.
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH MISSION- I
WOULD SAY SOMETHING UNIQUE
ABOUT THIS INSTANCE THE FIRST
TIME IN MY LIFE SET UP AN
OPERATION ST STE. WELL THE
RESPONSE. IS IT JUST EQUAL. R.
FOR PART OF AT THE PUMP CAN
FROM PART WHERE ESSENTIALLY TO
INFLUENCE THE- TO DO THAT
THEY'RE JUST NOT NORMAL. YOU
KNOW NORMALLY GONNA DO. AND SO
THE I THINK THE STRONG SUPPORT-
AND RICE. I WANTED RIGHT TO OWN
ONE OF THOSE THINGS TO MAKE
SURE THAT ON EMERGENCY SIDE WE
CAN LEVERAGE- THOSE FIELD
RESOURCES THAT WE ALREADY HAVE-
TO ASSIST WITH ACTUALLY HE. I
BELIEVE THE- STOCK. RUMORS
OPERATE CENTERS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THE SAME WAY YOU WOULD
PROBABLY FIND IT- OKAY IS
HELPED WITH- LET'S SEE
DISTRIBUTION. PERSPECTIVE A
QUICK. OR BASS SUPPORTS OF A
COUPLE WITH REQUIREMENTS FOR RE
OPENING- I SUSPECT ANYONE MY
COUNTY WILL BE USING THE SAME
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE. TO
PREPARE FOR THE NATION.
DISTRIBUTION AND YOU KNOW HE'S
GOING TO BE. I'M NOT SURE FOR
SEVERAL AND SOME OF THOSE WHO
SHOT SERIES THERE'S QUITE A BIT
OF CRYPTOGRAPHY THAT'S GOING TO
QUAN WITH THAT AND I KNOW WE'VE
ALREADY STARTED THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. I THINK THE KEY TO
THAT LAST PIECE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS GOING TO REST.
REPRIEVES EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU HAVE
THERE NOW. THE LIST CAN BE
MINIMIZED. THIS PRESENT RICE
SAID- WAS CLOSE COORDINATION
WITH. STATE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES. AND ENQUIRING ABOUT-
ANYTHING. SHE WAS DOWN THERE
SEVEN OR- AND THEN BEYOND THAT
ALSO THE WHICH SUPPORT-
DISTRIBUTION FROM THE MAIN
AREAS SO THAT I WOULD SAY AGAIN
THAT LAST MILE I THINK THOSE
ARE GOING TO BE THE CASE THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION CURRENT.
THANK YOU- I WILL GO TO HELL
ARE YOU. NO NO I'M I'M ALL DONE
THANK YOU AND I AND I WILL MY
ONLY COMMENT WAS GOING TO BE
WELL LET'S GET ON IT. AND DO.
SO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR JACKSON I WANT TO
MOVE ON TO OUR OUR FINAL PANEL-
YOU KNOW IF THE INTEREST OF
TIME IN. AND THE PANELISTS HAVE
BEEN GENEROUS ENOUGH TO-
PARTICIPATE. IN WHEN TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THEY'RE ABLE TO-
SEND OUT OUR FINAL PANEL IS ON.
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT WILL GIVE US
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT PERSPECTIVE
TO EMERGENCY ALERTS AND
EVACUATIONS- WE HAVE FIRST. UP
REVA FELDMAN- FROM THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES. I'M CITY
MANAGER FOR. THE CITY OF MALIBU
AND THE HEAD OF THE LEAGUE. OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES CITY MANAGERS
DEPARTMENT. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ASKING ME
TO PARTICIPATE YEAH AND THEN- I
REALLY APPRECIATE. HE
OPPORTUNITY AFTER ALL OF THE
OTHERS SPEAKERS AND BE ABLE TO
SHARE. MY EXPERIENCE AND I AM
AND AS YOU SAID IN THE- YES AS
OR THIS WEEK AT CDC MANAGER.
AND I HAVE THE HONOR OF SERVING
ON THE LEAGUE OF CITIES BOARD
OF DIRECTORS. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE CITY OF MALIBU
EXPERIENCE THE HOLES HE FIRED-
WHICH AT THE TIME WAS THE
LARGEST. DISASTER ACT BURKE
WHICH HIT LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ARE WE LOST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WERE EVACUATED FROM
SIXTY THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS IN
LESS THAN TWENTY FOUR HOURS- IT
WAS UNIQUE IN THAT IT WAS THE
THIRD MAJOR FIRING CALIFORNIA.
THAT DANNY. THE WHOLE FIRE IN.
FIRE YEAH FOR INTEREST WE READ
LAST GET RE IN. OUR WHICH
GREATLY IMPACT THE OF. AND ALSO
THAT WE HAVE ENTERED HIS. OF
SOME OF THE THING THAT WE- OUT
THERE WENT WRONG EVEN HAVE NOW.
I USED AS A LEARNING TOOL
IMPORT INTO ARE ALWAYS FOR ON
THE ARE THINGS OBVIOUSLY AT
RISK HAVE UPON- THE LAW. OF
POWER OUT OUT ABOUT YEAR POWER
IN THE AREA. WHICH I SEE.
SICKENING IMPACT. SOUTH ALSO Y.
STILL TRADITIONAL WAYS PEOPLE
GET NASTY. OUT GRAY AND- THAT
ALSO IMPACT ALL OF ACTION.
ROUTE I MALIBU IF YOU ARE WITH
OUR HAS. EACH MAJOR IN GRAY IN
AND EGRESS ROUTE. HI WE'RE ARE
WERE SIGNAL AND TRAFFIC SIGNALS
UP AND DOWN THE HIGHWAY- ALL OF
THEM STICK WHEN DARK DURING
THIS I. FIRE A WE HAD A REAL
ESTATE. SYSTEM WE HIT OUR. NINE
ONE ONE. AND WE HAVE LOTS OF
DIFFERENT WAYS OF CAN. WITH HER
CAN- BUT UNFORTUNATELY YOU LOSE
POWER AND SELL A COMMUNICATIONS
ALL OF THIS TRADITIONAL WAYS
I'LL GO OUT THE DOOR AND SO
WHAT WE TRY TO DO LAST SINCE
THE WILL SEEK. IS INTERESTED
ISSUES- WITH LOTS OF DIFFERENT
TOOLS ME AS AFTER SPEAKERS HAVE
TOUCHED UPON THERE ISN'T ONE.
SOLUTION GOING TO BE MULTIPLE
SOLUTIONS AND IT NEEDS TO BE
BETTER I'M HI TECH AND LOW TECH
SOLUTIONS- SO WE HAVE SINCE THE
WORLD HIGHER I'M- CAUGHT ME AND
THE LADY ISSUE YES AB. CITY
WHICH IS AND- I WE ALSO USE A
REVERSE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM
PURCHASE CELLPHONES SAID THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO GET RID ON-
RESIDENTS. IN FOR THAT IN FOR.
I AND WE'RE LOOKING AT A
DIFFERENT OTHER THINGS I WE
ALSO. BACK SHINS DOWN. I
DEVELOPED A BACK ROUTES THAT
INCLUDE STATE REFUGE. AND I'M
WITH THE AT ALL TYPE AT
TECHNOLOGY CHIU IN. OUR FIRE
MAPPING SERVICE THAT CAN TAKE A
GI MAP AND- ROUTE. I'M. FIRST
RESPONDERS I CAN ACTUALLY GET
MAPS YOU AREAS THEY WANT TO
KNOW YOUR WITH ONE
COMMUNICATIONS ARE PACKED AT-
AND WE GET YOU BEEN DONE THINGS
SUCH AS PURCHASING. ARMS IT CAN
BE USED ON CITY STAFF TO EUGENE
EVACUATIONS. AND PREVIOUS
SPEAKER HAD MENTIONED THAT ARE
LOCAL. HI SIRENS WHICH ARE
TERRIFIC ASSET GESTION HOWEVER
THOSE RELY ON TOPICS EFFICIENT
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO GO THROUGH
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND AS WE
EXPERIENCE AND WILSHIRE- WHEN
YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH ACTUAL
BODIES. THAT SOLUTION DOESN'T
ACTUALLY STYLE. I'M NOTIFYING
PEOPLE AND SO. WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING. INSTALLING A CPU OUT
SORRY WARNINGS. I'M NOT
SOMETHING THAT I WAS LOOKING
FOR AT THIS. I TO REALLY LOOK
AT IT FOR CAN YOU PROJECT THOSE.
THAT ARE TO FIRE. I'M I'M VERY.
FOR THAT BUT- THAT I BEEN ABLE
TO STOP WHICH WOULD AND THERE
WILL TO RIGHT WITH CITIES NOT
JUST WITH- BECAUSE WHAT THE-
ACTION WOULD BE MONEY IS
CRUCIAL DURING. GOOD TIMES AND
BLUE SKY AND DURING HIS. ON THE
ALSO A CRITICAL NOW I THINK
NEEDS TO HAPPEN BETWEEN. EIGHTY
I'M SORRY COURAGE- AND THIS ON
A CLEAR. IN FOR COMING OUT
DURING THIS. THAT WE CAN ALL
MESS ALEX STATE- TIME- AND
MOVING TO OF THE THINGS WE FEEL
ARE IMPORTANT OUR AND EMPHASIS
ON TO. HIGHER C. COMMUNITIES
FIRE. MAKING RESIDENTS AWAY OF
THE SITUATION AND WHERE THE
LIVE HOW SEXUAL EIGHT SITUATION
AWARE. DURING TIMES OF HIGH
FIRE DANGER. ON WE JACKSON. ASK
AN INCREASE IN HAVING FIRST AND
BEING LOOKED STATEWIDE AFTER
READ TIMES I MEAN SOMETHING
THAT WE REALLY THE PRICE FOR
NOT. AN ONLINE COURSE.
FIREFIGHTERS I'M REALLY. TO
WHAT WENT WRONG IN THE FIRE ON
AN CERTAINLY OTHER SPEAKERS
ATTACHED THE EACH YEAR UNDER. A
WIRES YEAH WELL KNOW THAT A
LONG TERM PROJECT THINGS THAT
WOULD BE. USEFUL DURING YES
JEWISH. OR RENTAL I'M
SITUATIONS IT'S THAT POWER.
IGRICE UNDATED TO PROVIDE.
POWER YOU HEAR TRACK- I TRAFFIC
SIGNALS WE'RE AND WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PLACE OR- I FELT.
IN LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS OUR
BACKUP ON CELL TOWERS THAT'S IN
PLACE. ALL OUT OF HOURS SO
THERE CERTAINLY COULD BE TO
SEPARATE SOUTH. IN COLD ARE CAL
I YES YES THAT'S TO KEEP THIS.
OUR USED AND ACTIVE NOT TO
COMMUNICATE WITH RESIDENTS BUT
TO. OUR FOREIGN FIRST RESPOND.
I'M AND THEN LET I THINK IT'S A
CREDIT AND FOR AN EMPHASIS TO
BE MADE ON THE USED OF
TECHNOLOGY. YEAH ARE WE
CERTAINLY INCREASED OUR WAY
COMMUNICATION AND REPEATERS OUR
COMMUNITY I'M ALSO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PAST. BACK IS GIVEN TO
NEWS YEAH LOCAL GREAT. H.
CLEARLY CONCISELY THAT INTO.
DEAR REYES. SURE THAT WE
EMPHASIZE THAT I'M SO I'M
CERTAINLY AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE
MORE INFORMATION AND GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THINGS THAT
WE IN OUR DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU- NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM AB JAMES GORE-
SO NO MY COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. GET
YOUR WOMAN RIVAS- APPRECIATE A
TIME TO BE WITH YOU ALL I'M
GONNA MAKE SURE THAT I- THAT I-JUMP IN AND- THE PLEASANTRIES
WILL COME BACK AROUND LATER
BUT- I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR DOING THIS- I REPRESENT
A DISTRICT IN A COUNTY WHERE
WE'VE HAD I BELIEVE HE DECLARED
DISASTERS IN THE LAST SIX YEARS
SO- EXPERIENCE NOT ONLY IN
TAKING IT ON THE CHIN BUT ALSO
EXPERIENCED AND TURNING. THAT
FROM BEING A MONIKER AFTER
DISASTER OF SONOMA STRONG OVER
INTO SOME KNOW SOMETHING THAT
WE CALL SONOMA READY. AND WITH
DEEPER LEVELS OF RESILIENCE I
WOULD CALL SONOMA SAFE SO- YOU
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT- WHAT WE CAN
DO- TO MAKE SURE THAT THE GIVE
AND TAKE OF THE STATE LOCALS.
IS IS AN APPROPRIATE PUSHED IN
A WAY I THINK ABOUT IT IS A
GROUND SWELL. THAT'S COMING UP
FROM OUR COUNTIES WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO. MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE DO HOW WE HOW WE
EXCHANGE IS BEST PRACTICES. I
DON'T GET THEMONEY GOING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION HOW DO WE
DO THE RIGHT KIND OF TESTING
ALERT- THE BIT AT THE OTHER
TIME WE DEFINITELY NEED YEAH.
AND THE STATE ESPECIALLY IN
TERMS OF- CONTINUITY OF
DEFINITIONS- HOW WE USE ALL
THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT OUR OUR
OUR OUR DIFFERENT JARGON- IN
FOR ALERT WARNING SYSTEMS.
OFTEN OPT OUT REDUNDANCY
SYSTEMS- I WILL GO THROUGH A
COUPLE OF THOSE BUT I'LL WAIT
FOR QUESTIONS- SENSE WERE.
PASSED WITH TIME A LITTLE BIT-
SO IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN CINEMA COUNTY WAS
CAUGHT ON HIS HEELS. WE HAD- OF
THE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE THAT
CAME INTO OUR COMMUNITY-
DESTROYED FIFTY THREE HOT
HOMES. WELL WE DID NOT. THREE
EVACUATE ANYBODY WE HAD
SIGNIFICANT. CHAOTIC
EVACUATIONS DURING THAT EVENT
WHICH WAS A MAKE A FIRE. AND WE
AND AS I MENTIONED WE LOST
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED HOMES AND
EVEN WORSE WE LOST TWENTY FOUR.
OF OUR NEIGHBORS FAMILY MEMBERS
AND FRIENDS IN OUR COMMUNITY-
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WERE AFTERWARDS WE
SAID NEVER AGAIN. WOULD BE
CAUGHT ON OUR HEELS. AND WHAT
WE'VE GONE THROUGH IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN WITH THE
CAN KATE FIRE- TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY WITH BOTH THE- LIGHTNING
COMPLEX THE WALLBRIDGE IN THE
MEYERS FIRE ON ONE SIDE. AND
THE GLASS FAR ON THE OTHER. IS
SUSTAINED AND SIGNIFICANT-
DANGER FROM SIMILAR EVENTS AND
FROM CLIMATIC. SITUATION
CHANGING. SO I WILL NOT GO INTO
THE DEEPER LEVELS OF RESILIENCE
WHICH IS A DIFFERENT COMMITTEE
HERE AND I THINK YOU KNOW-
WORKING WITH COMMITTED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION OUT OF A
SETTLEMENT WE HAVE WITH P.
JEANNIE TO GO AS A BASE LEVEL
OF FUNDING. FOR DEEP VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT- SECURING FIRE
ACCESS ROADS- SECURING FIRE
BREAKS AND OTHER THINGS OF THE
OF THE LIKE. BUT WHAT I DO WANT
TO TALK ABOUT IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN. WHAT I CALL THE TABLE
TO FIRES AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TO TWENTY- AS I. WE FIFTY
HUNDRED HOMES- WE WERE
EVACUATING IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
FIRE STORM. AND WE HAD TWENTY
FOUR OF OUR- OF OUR RESIDENTS
PASSED AWAY IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WE EVACUATED A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS DURING THE COURSE
OF THE CAN K. FIRE. WELL WE HAD
ZERO DEATHS AND ZERO- EXCUSE
ME- MAJOR INJURIES- WE DID I
IRONICALLY IN THAT SAME YEAR. I
THANK YOU OR OR NOT EVACUATE
BUT HAD UPWARDS OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WITHOUT
POWER. ON DIFFERENT SITUATIONS
FROM THE POWER SHUT DOWNS- WITH
PG&E. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY WE EVACUATED
CUMULATIVELY THIS YEAR- EIGHTY
SIX TO NINETY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
AND THOSE EVACUATIONS WHILE I
DON'T WANT TO GO INTO- WHAT DAY
BECAUSE- I THINK YOU CAN ALL
JOIN ME IN UNDERSTANDING THAT-
EVACUATIONS ALSO HAVE AN IMPACT
AS WELL- DISPLACING PEOPLE-
DISPLACING THE ECONOMY. MOVING
EVERYTHING- SPECIALLY DURING
COVERT THE SITUATION WE HAD A
SPIKE IN OUR CODE NUMBERS. A
POST OUR VALUATIONS BUT THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY A HUGE IMPACT OF
EVACUATING 4260% OF YOUR
COMMUNITY DIFFERENT TIMES. EVEN
IF IT'S TWENTY OR THIRTY
THOUSAND. PEOPLE THAT STILL A
LOT BUT WE ALL KNOW THAT HAS-
SENATOR JACKSON SAID THE NUMBER
PRIVATE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS SAFETY. AND
AS SOMEBODY WHO'S NOT ONLY
COUNTY SUPERVISOR BUT ALSO-
CHAIR BEEN THE CHAIR OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. AND FOUNDER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES RESILIENT COUNTIES
INITIATIVES WHICH IS DIVING IN.
SO YOUKNOW IT'S WHAT WE DID
IMMEDIATELY AFTER FIRES IS WE
GOT THE BEST PEOPLE IN FRONT OF
US. WE HOSTED HEARINGS WE
CREATED AND PUT MONEY INTO THE
CREATION OF AN OFFICE OF
RECOVERY RESILIENCY. WE TRIPLED
THE MONEY GOING INTO OUR
DEPARTMENT OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. AND- HIRED TWO
POSITIONS SPECIFICALLY AND THIS
DIRECT FOR A LOWER WARNING- WE
IN THE YEAR FOLLOWING OUR FIRE
WE TESTED WITH A LIVE FEED OUR
ALERT WARNING SYSTEM-
EFFECTIVELY CHANGING WHAT I
WOULD CALL THE BLACK AISLADOS
IS THE COUNTY GOVERNMENT. OF
FOR NOT- DO USING UTILIZING
EVACUATIONS ARE NOT BEING
TRAINED AND EVEN PREPARE TO USE
THOSE SYSTEMS. TO NOW BEING THE
POINT OF THE SPEAR IN TERMS OF
FIGURING IT OUT THIS IS ONE
THING I WOULD RECOMMEND FOR
THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHERS TO
LOOK AT. IS AND NOT JUST THE
IDEA THAT PEOPLE LOCALS HAVE TO
HAVE LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION
PLANS- TO BE ABLE TO QUALIFY
FOR FUNDING BUT ALSO. ACTIVE
TESTING ACTIVE EXERCISES
DEPLOYMENT IN YOUR COMMUNITY-
QUITE HONESTLY THERE IS NO
REPLACEMENT FOR IT- I COULD GO
THROUGH A LITANY OF OTHER
THINGS THAT WE DID TO PREPARE
COMMUNITY BUT SENTENCES ABOUT
ALERT. AND NOTIFICATION I JUST
WANT TO HIT A FEW WHICH IS- YOU
KNOW- WE'VE WE'VE DONE THINGS
LIKE CINEMA READY DAY WERE
pSHOW UP AND WE'VE GIVEN OUR GO
BAGS. WELL WE'VE REDEPLOYED
FROM ONE THING I THINK YOU GUYS
SHOULD CONSIDER FROM A NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM- WHICH CAN NOT
HANDLE ALL OF THE PHONE CALLS
FROM PEOPLE BEING EVACUATED.
INTO THAT MUCH MORE OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SOMETHING FROM
SAN DIEGO IN ANOTHER SYSTEM RUN
OUT OF ENSURE A WHICH IS TWO
ONE ONE. WHICH IS A VITAL
ELEMENT. INSTEAD OF. IT GETTING
OUT. ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT- I
WOULD SAY THE MOST AND- THING
WHEN WE TALK YOU. IS THAT YOU
HAVE TO GO AFTER WHERE PEOPLE
GET COMMUNICATION- YOU HAVE TO
GO AFTER SOCIAL MEDIA YOU HAVE
TO GO AFTER EMAILS YOU HAVE TO
GO AFTER PRINT MEDIA RADIO
OTHERWISE. BUT AT THE SAME
POINT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
LANDING PAGE YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
PLACE WHERE PEOPLE COME BACK
TO- THAT WAS SOMETHING WE
CREATE A CULTURE SO CALL
EMERGENCY DOT ORG. AND AND
ALTERNATELY YOU KNOW HAVEN'T
BEEN A PERSON WHO'S DONE
EVACUATION- EXERCISES A SAD
JOINTLY WITH SHERIFF'S OFFICERS
AND HI LO SIRENS ON MONDAY. OR
SKEWS ME ON SATURDAY MORNINGS
AND DRIVEN THROUGH- CRAZY
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND DONE THE
HIGH LOW SIRENS AND DONE THE WE
ALERTS. AND DONE ALSO THE NOAA
WEATHER ALERTS AND DONE ALL
KINDS OF REDUNDANCY TESTS ONE
THING I WANT YOU ALL TO KNOW
AND- IS THAT. BASICALLY IT'S A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE PEOPLE
ON THE GROUND AND THOSE IN
CHARGE- I THINK THE BIGGEST
THINGS THAT YOU'RE FACED WITH
LOOKING OUT JUST LIKE WE ARE.
IS- HOW DO WE EFFECTIVELY
COMMUNICATE WITH NEW TECH AND
ALL TECH- I FOR ONE IN THE BIG
FAN OF GETTING SIRENS BACK OUT
THERE IN HARD TO REACH AREAS-
YOU CAN EXPECT THAT EVERYBODY
CAN WORK I KNOW THE WEATHER
RADIO- OR THAT OUR SYSTEM WILL
WORK PERFECTLY WHEN YOU HAVE
CANYONS IN DIFFICULT AREAS WITH
CELLPHONE. I ALSO FULLY SUPPORT
OPT OUT PROGRAMS BECAUSE-
PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS SAYING THAT
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH- BUT YET
THEY DON'T SIGN UP FOR OFTEN
PROGRAMS- I'M A HUGE FAN OF- OF
THE STATE HELPING US WITH-
DEFINITIONS AND JARGON- AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE STILL EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE CONSIDERED ONE OF
THE TOP IN THE CLASS AN ALERT
WARNING. WE STILL HAVE HUGE
ISSUES WITH DIFFERENCES IN.
DISTRICTS WITH A FIRE
DISTRICTS- SHERIFF'S- COUNTY-
CITY IS. AN OTHERS OVERLAPPING
IN TERMS OF HOW THEY DO L.
THERE- YOUR NOTIFICATION AND I
DIDN'T. YOU THINGS. DO YOU CALL
IN ALL CLEAR ON YOU'VE DONE IT
DO YOU ANNOUNCES THIS BUT NOW
THIS- CREATES LOT OF CONFUSION
IN THE COMMUNITY AND THE
EXPECTATIONS COULD NEVER BE
HIGHER OF OUR CONSTITUENTS GIVE
US THIS VITAL INFORMATION- AND
AS I SAID BEFORE. IS NOT JUST
THIS IDEA OF. CREATING
REDUNDANT SYSTEMS IN PLACES
THAT CAN TAKE THE HUGE. LOAD OF
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS LIKE
SOMETHING LIKE A TWO ONE ONE
RATHER THAN THE NINE ONE ONE
THAT GETS OVERWHELMED. WITH A
FEW. THOUSAND CALLS BUT ALSO-
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE HEAVILY.
AS MUCH AS WITH OUR EVACUATIONS
OF OUR INCIDENTS BUT WITH OUR
POWER SHUT DOWNS FOR OUR ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS COMMUNITY.
SO I'LL I'LL I'LL LEAVE IT IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS I'D
APPRECIATE MY COMMENTS BECAUSE
OF- TIMELINESS. I JUST
APPRECIATE YOU ALL- THERE IS A
HUGE ROLE FOR THE STATE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH US AND SEE
SECOND I PERSONALLY STAND READY
TO. HELP YOU IN ANY WAY SHAPE
OR FORM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SUPERVISOR GORE OUR FINAL
PANELIST FOR THE HEARING- IS A
PAUL CUMMINS. NEVADA COUNTY
EMERGENCY SERVICES PROGRAM%
MANAGER REPRESENTING THE RURAL
COUNTY. REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. YEAH MADAM CHAIR
AND DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME'S PAUL CUMMINGS
AND I'M GONNA DIE COUNTY.
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
PROGRAM MANAGER. I'M ALSO
RETIRED AIR FORCE OFFICER IN
AND OUT OF COUNTY RESIDENT. I'M
HERE TODAY TO SHARE THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FACED BY A RURAL
COMMUNITY AS THEY RELATE TO
EMERGENCY DISASTER RESPONSE
SPECIFICALLY EMERGENCY ALERTS
AND EVACUATIONS. NEVADA COUNTY
IS NESTLED IN THE FOOTHILLS OF
THE SIERRA NEVADA ABOUT AN HOUR
NORTHEAST OF SACRAMENTO AND AN
HOUR WEST OF LAKE TAHOE. THE
RUGGED LANDSCAPE THE RICH
PRECOLONIAL GOLD RUSH HISTORY.
YUBA RIVER WHICH FANS ARE
COUNTY AS WELL AS HUNDREDS OF
MILES OF DESOLATE HIKING BIKING
AND EQUESTRIAN TRAILS BRINGS
THOUSANDS OF TOURISTS WERE
GREAT COMMUNITY EVERY YEAR. IT
IS THE SAME RUGGED LANDSCAPE
WITH STEEP GAINS AND THICK
FORESTS THE DRIVES ARE VAST
WILDFIRE RISK THREATENS P.
GENIES INFRASTRUCTURE ON RED
FLAG DAYS DRIVING FREQUENT
WIDESPREAD PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTIALS. 92% OF NEVADA COUNTY
RESIDENTS LIVE IN A HIGH OR
VERY HIGH WILDFIRE SEVERITY
ZONE LOOKING AT CAL FIRE'S RISK
MAP FOR ACCOUNTING. WILDFIRE IS
THE NUMBER ONE THREAT A
RESIDENT'S FACE. OUR COMMUNITY
IS ENGAGED AND LEANING INTO
REDUCING THIS THREAT TO HAZARD
EDUCATION MITIGATION AND
READINESS PLAN. ON AUGUST
SEVENTEENTH OF THIS YEAR OUR
RESIDENTS WERE PUT TO THE TEST
WHEN REGIONAL WEATHER SYSTEM
CREATING NUMEROUS LIGHTNING
STRIKES SPARKED EARLY MORNING
FIRES ACROSS THE ACCOUNTING.
THIS SAME SYSTEM WREAKED HAVOC
ACROSS A LARGE SWATH OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. ONE OF
THOSE FIRES WAS THE JONES FIRE
WHICH IGNITED IN THE YUBA RIVER
CANYON NOT FAR FROM THE CITY
AND THE COUNTY SEAT. THIS FIRE
BURNED SEVEN HUNDRED FIVE ACRES
OVER TWELVE DAYS. IN TOTAL OVER
FOUR THOUSAND RESIDENTS WERE
EVACUATED AND ULTIMATELY TWENTY
ONE STRUCTURES WERE DESTROYED.
THANKS TO THE HARD WORK OF OUR
LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS ALONG WITH
CAL FIRE MANY MORE WERE SAVED
AND NO LIES NO LIVES WERE LOST.
THE NEVADA COUNTY JONES FOR WAS
AN EXAMPLE OF EVERYTHING GOING
RIGHT- COUNTY ISSUED MULTIPLE
CODE RED AND WE ARE MESSAGES TO
OUR RESIDENTS WERE READY TO
EVACUATE WITH GO BAGS PACKED.
WE HAVE A LARGE SEGMENT OF OUR
RESIDENTS SIGNED UP FOR OPT IN
SYSTEM AND THOSE NUMBERS ARE
GROWING. MITCHELL EIGHT FOR
FIRE SUPPRESSION AND EVACUATION
WAS SWIFT AND EFFECTIVE. IN OUR
MEDIA PARTNERS IN COUNTY
OFFICES COLLABORATED TO PUSH
TIMELY UPDATES TO THE PUBLIC
AROUND THE FIRE STATUS.
EVACUATION AREAS. MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR LANDLINE AND
CELLPHONE INFRASTRUCTURE REMAIN
INTACT SO THE RESIDENTS CAN
RECEIVE CRITICAL EVACUATION
WARNING IN ORDER NOTICES. NOW
LET'S IMAGINE THAT THE JONES
FIRE PLAYING OUT DURING A
COUNTY WIDE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF. IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
I COUNTY RESIDENTS INJURED FOR
PS PS EVENTS IN SEPTEMBER AND
OCTOBER WITH JIM OF OUTAGES
SPANNING EIGHT DAYS. WHERE AT
ITS PEAK 40% OF NEVADA COUNTY
WAS WITHOUT POWER. RESIDENTS
OUTSIDE OUR TOWN AND CITY
CENTRESSTRUGGLE WITH
COMMUNICATIONS ON A GOOD DAY.
SOME COMMUNITIES ARE COUNTY
DON'T HAVE CELL PHONE COVERAGE
AT ALL AND RELY ON LAND LINE
SERVICE FROM ONE PROVIDER. I
LINES ARE SUPPOSED TO REMAIN UP
AND RUNNING SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
CALL NINE ONE ONE OR RECEIVE
ALERT AND WARNING CALLS.
HOWEVER THIS SERVICE HAS NOT
REMAINED OPERATIONAL IN OUR
POWER SHUT OFFS THIS LEAVES OUR
RESIDENTS EXPOSED AND
VULNERABLE. AS YOU MIGHT
IMAGINE AN OVERNIGHT POWER
OUTAGE WITH THE EARLY MORNING
WILDFIRE WOULD MAKE ALERT AND
WARNING OF THESE RESIDENTS VERY
CHALLENGING. THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF WHICH RESULTS IN
THE LOSS OF A SINGLE CELL PHONE
TOWER OR A NON OPERATIONAL
LANDLINE CAN ISOLATE LARGE
SWATHS OF OUR RESIDENTS. THIS
INTERRUPTION OF SERVICE ISN'T
THE SAME AS A CELLPHONE TOWER
GOING DOWN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO. ONCE OUR WERE NON
OPERATIONAL AND LINE HAS
LITERALLY BECOME A SINGLE POINT
OF FAILURE IN OUR NOTIFICATION
SYSTEM. WIRELESS EMERGENCY
ALERTS ARE A VERY EFFECTIVE
SYSTEM DOES NOT REQUIRE AN
OFTEN BUT ARE NOT AN OPTION
WHEN ARE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS ARE NOW. WE HAVE NEVADA
COUNTY RESIDENTS HANGING ONTO A
PRECIOUS FEW LIFELINES OF
COMMUNICATION AMONG THOSE GO
DOWN THEY ARE FLOATING ON THEIR
OWN. WE'RE CLOSELY FOLLOWING
TWO PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT
WILL HELP US BOLSTER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. ONE OF SENATE BILL
SIX SEVENTY WHICH PASSED LAST
YEAR REQUIRES TELECOMS AND
STATE- YES TO PASS OUTAGE
INFORMATION TO COUNTY- YES.
JOHNNY SHERIFF AND NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHERS. THUS FAR WHAT WE
KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN OUTAGES IN
OUR COUNTY. OUR OFFICE HAS NOT
RECEIVED ANY NOTIFICATION. THE
SECOND IS SENATE BILL FOR
THIRTY ONE THAT IF PASSED WILL
REQUIRE THE PROVISION OF BACKUP
POWER WHERE FEASIBLE. TO
MAINTAIN MINIMUM CELL SERVICE
FOR AT LEAST SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
AS HAS BEEN ALREADY STATED MANY
RESIDENTS HAVE FOR GONNA
TRADITIONAL LANDLINE AND NOW
RELY ON VOICE OVER IP PHONE. AS
THEIR SOLE SOURCE OF
COMMUNICATION. WHICH REQUIRES
AN ATTACK INTERNET ACCESS WHICH
DURING PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL
SO OFTEN TIMES IS UNAVAILABLE.
OUR OFFICE AS WELL AS OUR
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
HAVE RECEIVED NUMEROUS EMAILS
AND PHONE CALLS FROM CONCERNED
RESIDENTS OF LOS ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE WHEN THEY NEED TO
THE MONTHS. DURING A HIGH FIRE
DANGER RED FLAG DAY. WE ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE PASSAGE OF
SENATE BILL FOR THIRTY ONE
WHICH WILL CREATE REDUNDANCIES
AND CELLPHONE NETWORKS AND
ALLOW THEM TO OPERATE FOR UP TO
THREE DAYS INDEPENDENT OF
COMMERCIAL POWER. THIS WILL
ENSURE RESIDENTS HAVE RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS DURING YES YES.
PG'S CURRENT DOWN IT'S GREAT TO
PROTECT IT FROM THE FIRE FROM
THE HIGH FIRE DANGER PRODUCED
BY RED FLAG CONDITIONS IN THE
SAME CONDITIONS ARE THREATENING
OUR COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO ASK
THAT ACTION BE TAKEN WHEN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS DO
NOT DELIVER LANDLINE SERVICES
WHEN THE POWER IS OUT. DURING A
GRID DOWN SCENARIO MANY NEVADA
COUNTY RESIDENTS CAN'T CALL
NINE ONE ONE OR RECEIPT OF
ACTUATION NOTIFICATIONS WHEN
THEY NEED THEM THE MOST. IT
TAKES TIME TO EVACUATE
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS SOME OF
WHICH MAY HAVE ONLY ONE WAY IN
AND ONE WAY OUT. EARLY ALERT
MORNING ARE CRITICAL TO SAFELY
EVACUATE RESIDENTS WHO LIVE
WITH LIMITED EGRESS OPTIONS.
ANOTHER SET OF CHALLENGES ARE
COUNTY MUST CONSIDER OR THE
NOTIFICATION AND TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS OF OUR NEIGHBORS WITH
DISABILITIES IN OLDER ADULTS.
THE DATA SHOWS THAT THESE MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS ARE OF THE
HIGHEST LIKELIHOOD TO PERISH IN
A FAST MOVING WILDFIRE. OUR
COUNTY HAS A HIGH POPULATION OF
SENIORS THAT MAY REQUIRE EXTRA
TIME TO DOCUMENT. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE RESIDENTS WHO
FOR ONE REASON OR ANOTHER DO
NOT OR CANNOT DRIVE. THE
PROSPECT OF FINDING
TRANSPORTATION HAVING A PLAN IN
A PLACE TO GO. ABOVE SOME OF
OUR SENIORS CHOOSING TO RISK
THEIR LIVES. AND REMAIN WITHIN
THEIR HOMES INSTEAD OF
POTENTIALLY LOSING THEIR
INDEPENDENCE AND DIGNITY. THE
CARE OF WELL MEANING STRANGERS.
SHORTLY AFTER THE JONES FIRE I
TOOK A CALL FROM A WOMAN IN HER
EIGHTIES WHO LIVED ALONE AND
WAS ORDERED TO EVACUATE FOR THE
JONES FOR. JUST PICKED UP MY
FAMILY MEMBER WHO WAS UNABLE TO
CARE FOR HER AND HAD TO DROP
HER OFF IN AN ADULT CARE
FACILITY THAT WAS NOT ABLE TO
MEET HER NEEDS. SHE WAS LEFT IN
A WHEELCHAIR ALL NIGHT SITTING
IN SOILED CLOTHES SHE WAS
DESPERATE. AND FELT SHE HAD NO
OPTIONS SHOULD THERE BE ANOTHER
FOR. SHE FELT NEXT TIME SHE
MIGHT BE FORGOTTEN IN HER AND
IN HER WORDS LEFT TO BURN. OUR
PHONE LINES WERE DOWN DO IT PS
PS. SHE MAY NOT HAVE GOTTEN A
NOTIFICATION AT ALL. IN
CLOSING. WE ADVOCATE FOR
HOLDING TELECOMMUNICATIONS
UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE HARDENING
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT LANDLINES AND
CELLULAR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
REMAIN OPERATIONAL DURING
CRITICAL FIRE WEATHER WE ALSO
ASK THAT THE NEEDS OF OUR
ELDERS AND NEIGHBORS THE
DISABILITIES BE CENTERED IN THE
DISCUSSION OF POLICY. AS IT
RELATES TO EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TO DISASTERS. IT IS CRITICAL WE
MAINTAIN FUNCTIONING SYSTEMS OF
COMMUNICATION AND NOTIFICATION.
AS WELL AS OUR SYSTEMS OF
TRANSPORTATION AND SHELTER THAT
SERVE THE WHOLE COMMUNITY. OUR
CAN DOES HAVE A LOCAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN WE HAVE APPLIED
FOR HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAM FUNDS TO HELP MITIGATE
THE THREAT AREA. THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION TO SPEAK WITH
THE OFFICE MORE THIS AFTERNOON.
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU TO ALL THE PANELISTS-
FOR BEING HERE WITH US TODAY
AND PROVIDING A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PERSPECTIVE WHICH
IS. A MUCH NEEDED IN THIS ISSUE
AREA- DO YOU DO HAVE A QUESTION
SENATE MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE A QUICK COMMENT AND SAY
THANK YOU TO SUPERVISOR GORE.
INCOMING PRESIDENT NOW
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
AS WELL AS MISTER CUMMINGS
MISSPELLED IN THAT FOR THEIR
WORK LOOK I THINK THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WHILE PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE THERE IS OBVIOUS.
OBVIOUSLY MUCH MORE WORK AHEAD
IN PARTNERSHIP I THINK THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE THAT THREE YEAR
LEADERSHIP MADAM CHAIR AND
THOSE. IN THE LEGISLATURE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THESE LARGE MAKE A
WHILE THEN FIRES- IT IS UP TO
US TO BE A TO CONTINUE TO.
PARTNER UP WHETHER IT'S ISSUES
EMERGENCY ALERTS FOCUSING ON
ALL ISSUES OF EVACUATIONS HOW
WE CAN IMPROVE THAT. IN THE
BASICS OF JUST. BEING ABLE TO
GET MORE BOOTS ON THE GROUND IS
WELL SO AGAIN VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THE
PERSPECTIVES OF THOSE
GOVERNMENT LEADERS THAT WERE
WITH US TODAY ON THIS FINAL
PANEL. THANK YOU I. IF THERE
THERE'S NO OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS I'D I BELIEVE THERE ARE
NOT OKAY THANK YOU- NEXT I WANT
TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AND I WANT TO START WITH A
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM IF YOU CAN COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE AND I JUST WANT TO
REMIND YOU TO KEEP YOUR MASK ON
AND DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE- AND IF YOU COULD
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENT TWO
ONE MINUTE. WE'RE SORRY YES OR-
GET ENOUGH RECOGNITION-
CHAIRMAN RIVAS AND COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- TOUCH CEREMONY.
THERE IS- MY NAME IS PATRICK
BENEFIT. I WAS TALKING
LISTENING AREA VETERANS THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE WOMAN WHO WAS
BRIDGES WE BURN. HELLO I HAVE.
THE MIGHT IS ON I'M SORRY- AND-
I FEEL THAT WAY SOMETIMES TOO I
CAN REALLY RELATE TO THAT-
MONIES PATCH BANKER I SHOULD
SAY THAT I'M NOBODY SPECIAL-
I'M NO HERO AND I FEEL LIKE I'M
FAMILY NETWORK RIGHT NOW- BUT
I'M BASICALLY A MAN WHO- YOU
KNOW WASH DISHES IN A IN A
KITCHEN A SURVEYOR TO THOSE
LESS FORTUNATE. YOU KNOW THAT
WHEN PEOPLE AFTER ME AND DIDN'T
DO THE JOB YEAH ON THE MAN WHO
WE THINK BORN A SMALL TOWN
DISORDERS AND YOU KNOW LITTLE
GIRLS GIVE ME APPLES AND HUGS
YOU KNOW WITH THEIR MOTHERS. ON
THE MOUND. EIGHTY SEVEN POINT
SMALL TOWN BOYS HAVE STAFF
SEVEN KNOWS THE SECOND AIRBORNE.
DIVISION- A MAN WHO LOVES MY
WOMAN- ON THE- TRYING TO HER-
FROM SIN DEATH GOING ON IN OUR
TOWN- AND- I'M EMBARRASSED TO
ADMIT THIS BUT- YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN THROUGH US IN DIFFICULT
TIMES- SIX MONTHS A- HORROR AND
TERROR AND HELPLESSNESS- AND
YOU KNOW GUYS YOU KNOW
INFORMATION SECURITY ANALYST
I'VE PRETTY SURE YOU KNOW SOME
BUSINESS ON TELL ME IF THERE
ARE. YOU KNOW RAPING MY WOMEN
AND- DRUGGING HER AND- YOU KNOW
IT HURTS SO MUCH ELEVEN MONTHS
OF YOU KNOW PEOPLE BASED
ECONOMY. YOU KNOW AND THEY'RE
AND WHAT KINDS OF TERRIBLE
THANKS. FOR LET MINISTRY YOU
KNOW IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY.
YOU'RE NOT FIVE MONTHS PAST
FIVE MONTHS HAVE BEEN HUNDRED
UP. BUT YOU KNOW I'M NOT
PORTANTINO MY STORY IS NOT
IMPORTANT. WHO IS IMPORTANT TO
ME AS CHILDREN. DOES THAT.
RIGHTS UNLESS I NUMBER. COULD
NOT TO THEM AND LIKE THAT
NUMBERS TRYING TO DO WITH RIGHT
AND I AND I KNOW ON. AND I
DON'T KNOW BY SPECIAL AND I
KNOW KNOW OR THE OF I'M TRYING
TO GET. BURKE CHEN. THAT'S
RIGHT. YEAH I THINK THERE ARE
LIKE A SENTENCE THERE GOING
LINE TO EVERYBODY ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON BUT- CAN'T. YOU KNOW I
JUST. YOU KNOW I THINK THEY
MIGHT BE TRYING TO BLAME HER
BUT I THINK THERE'S A CALM
SITUATION FOR AND I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW. WE'RE ALL OWN APOLOGY
YOU KNOW THAT YOU KNOW. SO I'M
HERE TO APOLOGIZE ON BEHALF
THESE BUSINESSES AND I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT I HOPE YOU DON'T
KNOW. THAT YOU KNOW. I'M VERY
SKINNY. THEY'RE VERY SORRY. AND
I KNOW SOMETIMES MEN GET ON.
PASSIONATE ABOUT THINGS THAT
THEY REALLY BELIEVE AND STUFF
LIKE THAT. YOU KNOW. I BELIEVE
IN FAMILY COMMUNITY COUNTRY NOT
PLEASE KNOW WHAT'S RIGHT. AND
I'M JUST TRYING MY BEST I
BELIEVE IN ALL YOUR- I THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT HERE TO MOTHERS
AND FATHERS. I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU DO IT. YOU KNOW NOT BEEN
GRANDFATHER. SUNDAY MULTIPLE
SUNDAY TO WITH NORMAN I'M A-
SPY YOU KNOW. THEY'VE BEEN PUT
THAT PUT A BRAIN VIRUS LIKE
SOME TYPE OF DRUGS LIKE BURNING
TIRES ON MY DOORKNOB. FELL I
GOT A REALITY WAS. THEY PUT A-
THEY SAY THEY PUT. LIKE ALICE.
SOMETIME OF GENETIC. YOU KNOW
PLEASANT. IN THE- YOU KNOW I
MEAN. THIS NEW. I DON'T.
TECHNOLOGY WHATEVER. THAT'S
MOST LIKE THE- OF MY PRIVATE
PARTS AND- LIKE THAT. WHICH
BRINGS ME HEART BECAUSE IN OUR
ROOM A FATHER I'M- TO CLASS.
USA BE IN BETTER. BY. TO THE
YOU KNOW. THESE GUYS ARE DOING
THIS. KNOW HOW TO SAY. WHEN
THEY SAY DO YOU DO. ALL THE
STUFF LIKE YOU KNOW. GORE ON
STAFF. I SAY I DON'T KNOW TO ME.
YOU KNOW FOR. STOP TALKING TO
ME. AND I WANT TO. YOU KNOW
FIRST OF MANY YOU KNOW SOME.
CONOCER WHEN I WAS A- OWNER WE
HAVEN'T. PRAGYA PLACE I WAS WE
HAVE. SPREAD ALL THE- MOTHERS
AND FATHERS AND- YEAH I WAS
GONNA SAY. FIRST AND THEN.
THANK YOU SIR. THANK HAS ONCE I
YOU KNOW- THANKS NEED TO MOVE
ON. TO THE- PUBLIC COMMENT I.
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. OKAY ANYONE ELSE. IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD. TO MAKE.
OKAY.
HI CAN YOU GUYS HEAR ME
YES WE CAN EVERYBODY HEAR ME.
FEMA CAMPS WE DO NOT CONSENT.
CURRENT TEAM FOR FOURTEEN DAYS
NOW IF SOMEONE DRIVES MORE THAN
A HUNDRED FIFTY MILES IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WE DO NOT CONSENT.
HOTELS OR RESIDENTIAL TREVOR
TRAVEL OR TO ISOLATE AND
CAROTENE SO MODIFY TEAM
ACCOUNTS WE DO NOT CONSENT.
SOCIAL MEDIA SOCCER BURKE
BREAKING THE FIRST AMENDMENT
EVERY DAY WE DO NOT CONSENT. DR
PENN DO YOU USE SOCIAL MEDIA TO
CARE FOR YOUR PATIENCE ALL NO
YOU ONLY USE VACCINES THAT IS
YOUR STANDARD OF CARE WE DO NOT
CONSENT. FIVE G. WE DO NOT
CONSENT. THERE ARE ZERO STUDIES
COMPLETED FOR ITS SAFETY AND IT
ACTUALLY IS A WEAPONIZED
FREQUENCY AGAIN WE DO NOT
CONSENT. PAN PLUS MY CECILIA
AND I BELIEVE I FORGET ONE
PERSON'S NAME. JACKSON YEAH I'M
AFRAID NEITHER ALL OF YOU HERE
THE PEOPLE. YOU ALL FAILED SO
MANY OF THEM THROUGH MUDSLIDES
FLOODS FIRES TSUNAMIS AND
NINETEEN THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TWO DEAD DURING THE
PAST TEN MONTHS OF COLD IT. YES
YOU DARE TO TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE GOVERNMENT TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE INSULTING.
AND THE FRAUGHT ACCORDING TO
THE U. S. STYLE FOR GROWTH TEN
FORTY THANK YOU MA'AM WELL AS
FAR AS I AM CONCERNED I READ
YOUR WE ARE LIMITING PUBLIC
COMMENT TWO ONE MINUTE. AND YOU
ARE PAST YOUR ONE MINUTE LET ME.
YEAH HE NEVER DID. THANK YOU.
YOU. FOR TEN THIRTY EIGHT.
MA'AM YOU ARE AT MINUTE AND THE
HALF THANK YOU FOR YOUR COM
THANK YOU. FIVE LET ME SERVE
YOU ALL OF YOU WITH THE LATTER
OF LIABILITY DR PAN READY GOT
TALKING AND HE DIDN'T ANSWER
DIRECTLY IF YOU. OKAY SHOWING
THE DAY YOU YOU'RE WELCOME I'M
ANY ELSE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE MAKE A COMMENT. THE LAST-
JUST A REMINDER WERE LIMITING
PUBLIC COMMENT TWO ONE MINUTE
FRIENDS. ALL RIGHT- ALL THIS
TALK ABOUT FIRE AND YET IT IS
SO FREAKING COLD IN THIS ROOM
MAYBE IF WE FINALLY SET FIRE TO
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOURS
CAREERS. WIRELESS REMOTE LET ME
GET MY FIRST MATCH WHY WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT THE FEMA CAMPS WE
GOT FIVE HERE IN THE GREAT
STATE ECONOMY FORMULA YET
THEY'RE JUST AS HIDDEN AS
AGENDA TWENTY ONE IS. AGENDA
TWENTY ONE WILL BURN NOT JUST
THE WEST COAST WITH THE ENTIRE
WORLD TO THE GROUND. BUT THE
WORLD LEADERS WANT THAT THOUGH
THEY JUST CAN'T WAIT FOR THAT
IF YOU LIKE CHRISTMAS TO THEM.
ISN'T IT FUNNY HOW THE FIRES
THIS PAST SEASON TORCH THROUGH
THE WEST COAST TOP TO BOTTOM
BUT DIDN'T TOUCH CANADA OR
MEXICO. DID THEY SEE TRUMP'S
WALL AND JUST SAY OH NO. LET ME
STAY HERE. THE ARMY HAS
ADMITTED TO BEING ABLE TO
CONTROL THE WEATHER YEARS AGO
VIA LIGHTNING BOLTS. DOESN'T
LIGHTNING CAUSED FIRES ARE WE
GOING TO IGNORE THAT THE SAME
WAY WE DID WIN BILL GATES SAID
THE SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO DIE FROM
THE KOBE NINETEEN VACCINE.
BECAUSE HE MUST HAVE A DEGREE
IN SECOND PREDICTIONS YOU KNOW
UNLIKE THE MEDICAL ONE THAT HE
NEVER GOT. THANK YOU MA'AM.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT.
EXPECTING A DIFFERENT RESPONSE
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF MEETING. I JUST
WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT WE ARE
LIMITING PUBLIC COMMENT TWO ONE
MINUTE YOU GET NINETY SECONDS
TO THE OTHER PEOPLE. MIGHT
MCGUIRE KNOWS ME I'M A
DISPLACED PERSON FROM HIS
DISTRICT AND THE OTHER REVISED
GAVE ME TWO EXTRA MINUTES LAST
WEEK BECAUSE I'M A FIRE REFUGEE
I HAVEN'T MET YOU REVISED.
APPARENTLY THERE'S TO RE BOSSES
IN THE BUILDING. YES CONFUSING
AROUND HERE NOT FOR ME NOT FOR
YOU. NO IT ISN'T WELL YES WHAT
MA'AM YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE ME
THIS LEGISLATURE WORKS FOR ME I
CONTACT MIKE MCGUIRE HAVE YOU
LOST THAT ABILITY. YOU AND I
KEEP INTERACTING IN PERSON AND
YOU WELL IF YOU KNOWLEDGE ME AS
A HUMAN BEING. AND I'M STANDING
HERE REPRESENTING OF MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE BEING
UNDER REPRESENTED AND WE'RE
DONE WITH THAT WERE REALLY
REALLY DONE WITH IT. ALL EYES
FREE BOSS WHERE ARE YOUR ALL
RIGHTS YOU ALL BET ON THOSE
SCREENS THE ENTIRE TIME AND
APPARENTLY BIG FAN RAN AGAIN
DOESN'T HE STAY WHERE'S THE
REST OF THE COMMITTEE CECILIA
AGUIAR-CURRY DID SHE NEED TO
GET A BOSS THANK YOU MAY. HAVE
REGARDING YOUR TIME IS NOT
ALWAYS SHOPPING. YOU ARE IT
TALK ABOUT THE AGENDA. MA'AM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT.
WITH IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR COMING YOUR TIME IS UP. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT. THANK YOU- I BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE LIMITED ON TIME AND
WE- AND WE WE'RE ENCOURAGING
MA'AM. MA'AM PLEASE SIT DOWN.
WE ARE ENCOURAGING OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO SUBMIT
THEIR COMMENTS IN WRITING TO
THE COMMITTEE- I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A TECHNICAL ISSUE ON OUR
PHONE AND WE AREN'T ABLE TO
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU.
YOU DON'T HAVE A- MA'AM THIS
HEARING IS NOW. OVER THANK YOU
YEAH.